BELL YOUR ALSO.
WERE TODDLE.
JONES LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MONNING HERE MORLOCK.
MORRELL.
PAN.
ROTH SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
UMBERG.
Y. KASKI [inaudible]
WE HAVE
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECRETARY NOTICES THE PRESENCE
OF A QUORUM.
WE WILL COMMENCE TODAY'S.
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE HEARING THIS IS OUR
SECOND FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR THIS YEAR AND WE'RE
GOING TO FOCUS TODAY ON AN AREA.
THAT HAS APPROPRIATELY SO
RECEIVED MUCH ATTENTION
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES AND
EMERGENCY READINESS AND RESPONSE.
LET ME BE CLEAR COLLEAGUES
TODAY'S HEARING WILL NOT FOCUS
ON P. JEANNIE.
OR THEIR FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY
THIS WEEK THERE WILL BE.
OTHER HEARING TO THE FUTURE TO
DELVE MORE DEEPLY ON AN
APPROPRIATELY INTO THAT VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE BUT THAT IS NOT
OUR GOAL TODAY.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE
SEASON WAS PARTICULARLY
DEVASTATING WITH THE LARGEST
WILDFIRE RECORDED THE MENDOCINO
COMPLEX FIRE.
WHICH HAS ALL OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND ALL OF US HERE IN
THIS ROOM NOW BURNED FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
ACRES.
AND THE DEADLIEST WILDFIRE THE
CAMP FIRE WHICH KILLED EIGHTY
SIX CALIFORNIANS AND DESTROYED
ALMOST NINETEEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES.
IN TODAY'S HEARING WILL HAVE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROCESS
AND ROLES OF STATE AGENCIES AS
THEY RELATE TO WILDFIRES AND
OTHER DISASTERS A DISCUSSION ON
CURRENT YEAR SPENDING
AUGMENTATIONS.
AND HEAR ABOUT THE STATUS ON
RECOVERY FROM RECENT DISASTERS
IN ADDITION THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WILL PROVIDE US A
SYNOPSIS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
WILDFIRE RELATED PROPOSALS WILL
TALK ABOUT CAL FIRE AND YES IS.
FOR WILDFIRE RELATED
RESPONSIBILITY THE IN THE
STATE'S MONEY TO PREVENT AND
SUPPRESS WILDFIRES.
LASTLY WE'LL HAVE A DISCUSSION
ON THE GOVERNOR'S DISASTER READY
THIS PROPOSALS INCLUDING NINE
ONE ONE FOLLOWED BY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
COLLEAGUES AND SO WE WILL NOT BE
TAKING VOTE TODAY.
CENTER NIELSEN WOULD LIKE
PROVIDING THE ONLY REMARKS
BEFORE WE GET STARTED.
WELL I APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON
THIS OBVIOUSLY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
THAT THIS IS THE AREA THAT IS
AFFECTED.
THE AREA OF STATE THAT I'M.
THE CLUES HONORED TO REPRESENT.
BUT IT HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
DEVASTATED.
THE HOPE IS THAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE NOW.
AND CHANGE SOME OF THE PATTERNS
OF THE PAST THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO WHAT WE NOW DEAL
WITH.
MAKE PEOPLE IS HOLE AS WE CAN.
AND TO PREVENT.
IN THE FUTURE.
MORE SUCH CATACLYSMIC DISASTERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR BEFORE
WE GET STARTED COLLEAGUES WE
JUST WANT TO BRING TO EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION THEY'VE BEEN NOTICED
IN THE FILE BUT WE WILL HAVE.
FOR AT THIS POINT SCHEDULED
ADDITIONAL FULL SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARINGS --
EXCUSE ME THREE MORE SCHEDULED
AND ONE VERY LIKELY TO COME IN
EARLY SPRING.
ON THE SEVENTH OF FEBRUARY WILL
FOCUS ON BUDGET RESILIENCY AND
PAYING DOWN DEBT.
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH.
APPROPRIATELY FELL HEALTHCARE.
HARD BALLANTINE'S DAY
[inaudible]
GO.
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS
WITHOUT WITH CLINTON BEGIN WITH
TODAY'S FIRST PANEL I'LL INVITE
TO THE TABLE.
HELEN KIRSTEN FROM THE LA ELS
OFFICE.
MARTIN YOU DUE TO DIRECTOR OF
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
SCOTT SMITH LINE DIRECTOR OF
CALORIE CYCLE.
COLLEAGUES IF YOU WILL JUST MAKE
NOTE OF YOUR QUESTIONS AND WILL
HOLD THEM AT THE END OF THE FULL
PANEL PRESENTATION WILL OPEN IT
UP FOR MOVE ON TO THE SECOND
PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
THIS CURSED IN.
THE MORNING.
MY NAME IS TELLING CRISTINA THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
SURGEON SHOULD HAVE PASSED OUT A
HAND OUT THAT'LL BE REFERENCING
TODAY SO I HOPE YOU HAVE THAT
IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE ONLINE --
SO AS PART OF THIS FIRST PANEL
ALL BE GOING FOR THE FIRST SIX
PAGES ABOUT HAND OUT IN THE
REMAINING PAGES WILL GO OVER AS
PART OF THE SECOND THIRD PANELS --
THIS MORNING I'LL BE SETTING THE
STAGE ON THE TOPIC OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IN REDDING S. FOCUSING
MOSTLY ON FIRES ALL START OUT BY
TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
STATE'S DISASTER RESPONSE SYSTEM --
AND THE DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES
INVOLVED --
I WILL ALSO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF
THE RECENT ACTIONS LEGISLATURE'S
TAKEN ON WILD FIRES --
AND SOME OF THE FUNDING THAT IS
PROVIDED FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRES.
SO HE TURNED TO PAGE ONE OF YOUR
HAND OUT --
WE DISCUSSED SOME OF THE MAJOR
STATE AGENCIES INVOLVED IN
BEFORE I GET INTO THAT I I
REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
LOCALS ARE ALSO VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
IN THE STATE'S DISASTER RESPONSE
SYSTEM SO THEY'RE USUALLY THE
FIRST FOLKS TO GET THE CALL THE
NINE ONE ONE CALL --
HE RESPONDS --
AND AND REALLY ADDRESS DISASTER
SITUATIONS OF IT SOMETIMES LOCAL
RESOURCES ARE EXCEEDED AND THEN
THERE ARE AVARIETY OF STATE
ENTITIES THAT --
PROVIDE A LOT OF ASSISTANCE TO
LOCALS AND AND THEIR TIMES OF
DISTRESS.
SO WE HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE KEY
STATE DEPARTMENTS INVOLVED THERE
ARE A WHOLE HOST OF STATE
DEPARTMENT TO HAVE DIFFERENT
ROLES --
SAID THIS IS BY NO MEANS
COMPREHENSIVE BUT JUST WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF A
FLAVOR.
AS WE START OUT WITH A DISASTER
PLANNING AND COORDINATION THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IS
REALLY A CRITICAL DEPARTMENT IN
THIS AREA AND YOU'LL HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE FROM THEM LATER --
SO THEY COORDINATE AND SUPPORT
DISASTER PLANNING ACTIVITIES
THEY ALSO COORDINATE DISASTER
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY ACTIVITIES
AND ONE OF THE KEY THINGS THEY
DO IS CALLED MISSION TASKING SO
THEY CAN TELL OTHER DEPARTMENTS
HEY WE NEED YOUR RESOURCES HERE --
PLEASE COME IN SUPPORT THE STATE
PLEASE COME IN SUPPORT LOCALS --
AND THEY CAN ALSO --
A COORDINATE THE MUTUAL A
COMMUNITIES PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO EACH OTHER AND THEIR TIMES OF
NEED.
ANOTHER REALLY CRITICAL ROLE AT
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
PLAYS IS --
RELATED TO FUNDING SO THEY SERVE
AS A CONDUIT FOR A LOT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING WE'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
IN A FEW MINUTES THE STATE CAN
CAN SOMETIMES GET QUITE A BIT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING --
DATE MINISTER THAT THEY ALSO
ADMINISTER KEEP PROGRAM CALLED
THE CALIFORNIA DISASTER
ASSISTANCE ACT PROGRAM --
AND THAT FUNDS --
REPAIR AND REPAIR AND
REPLACEMENT OF PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REIMBURSES
SOME LOCAL COSTS SO.
THOSE ARE SOME CRITICAL OF
MORALS THAT --
YES PLACE.
IN TERMS OF FIRE ANOTHER
DISASTER RESPONSE THERE ARE A
FEW KEY DEPARTMENTS THERE --
THEY'VE DEPARTMENT FORESTRY AND
FIRE IN STATE --
DEPARTMENT INVOLVED IN FIRE
RESPONSE SO THEY'RE PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE STATE-RESPONSIBILITY AREAS THAT'S
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE STATE --
THAT THE STATE IS HER FIRST
MAINLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING A MOST OF THAT IS
PRIVATE LANDS --
BUT THEY ALSO ARE JUST CRITICAL
IN GENERAL WITH REGARD TO FIRES.
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO --
AN IMPORTANT DEPARTMENT THAT CAN
BE --
HARNESS REALLY WHEN THERE'S A
NEED THEY CAN BRING TO BEAR A
LOT OF FEDERAL RESOURCES
MILITARY TYPES OF EQUIPMENT
AIRCRAFT FOR EXAMPLE BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE STAFF THAT CAN SERVE A
VARIETY OF ROLES IN HELPING TO
RESPOND.
AND RECOVER FROM DISASTERS.
I'M ALSO JUST WANT TO MENTION OF
WATER RESOURCES DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES WE DON'T THINK ABOUT
THEM VERY MUCH --
SOMETIMES IN CONTACT THE FIRES
BUT THEY CAN BE IMPORTANT THAT
CAN PROVIDE SANDBAGS IN THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS IF THERE'S GONNA
BE A MUD SLIDE.
BUT THEY ALSO ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT IF WE IF WE GET A
FLOOD EVENT AND THAT COURSE THE
STATE IS NOT JUST FROM THE FIRES
BUT WERE FOREIGN FRONT TO FLOODS.
EARTHQUAKES AND AND OTHER TYPES
OF DISASTERS AS WELL.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE --
TWO WE HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE
DEPARTMENTS INVOLVED IN RECOVERY
ASSISTANCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL --
THEY'RE THEY'RE KIND OF FIRST --
ON THE GROUND IN TERMS OF
CLEANING UP THE DEBRIS THEY GET
ALL OF THE REALLY HAZARDOUS AND
TOXIC KINDS OF MATERIALS OF
THEIR PROPANE TANKS ARE AS BEST
AS THEY COME IN AND MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE COLLECTED AFTER
FIRE RATHER MAJOR DISASTER --
SO THEY DON'T CONTAMINATE --
CONTAMINATE OUR BEAUTIFUL
ENVIRONMENT POWER CYCLE PAYS A
REALLY CRITICAL ROLE NAY THEY
ACTUALLY GET THE BULK OF THE
MATERIAL ASH THE CONCRETE THE
METALS AND THEY CLEAN THAT UP
AND WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT AND YOU KNOW WE'LL
WE'LL ALSO HEAR FROM COVER CYCLE
TODAY -- BUT
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE
WITH REGARD TO FIRES IN
PARTICULAR --
ALSO JUST QUICKLY TO MENTION THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES THEY
ADMINISTER TEMPORARY SHELTERS
AND THEY ALSO RUN A PROGRAM THE
STATE HAD TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL CASH ASSISTANCE TO
FOLKS -- ITS
IT'S ABOUT UP TO TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
FULLY MAKE PEOPLE WHOLE BUT IT
IS IS CERTAINLY CONTRIBUTION.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE WE
SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE STATE
FUNDING THAT'S PROVIDED FOR
DISASTER RESPONSE AND RECOVERY.
I'M JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
THINGS SO CAL FIRE HAS A FACT
BASED BUDGET FOR FIRE CONTROL
RELATED ACTIVITIES THAT'S
USUALLY ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR --
THEY ALSO HAVE A BASE BUDGET FOR
THEIR EMERGENCY FUNDS AND THAT'S
USED WHEN A FIRE INCIDENT EXCEED
THE FIRST TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF
RESPONSE AND USUALLY THAT'S
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
SEVEN ADDITION --
YES ALSO HAS THE CDA PROGRAM
WHICH I REFERENCED --
PREVIOUSLY AND THEY HAVE A SET
UP FOR THAT PROGRAM.
SO IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE ARE SOME BUDGET
MECHANISMS THAT THE STATE HAS
HISTORICALLY HAD TO MAKE MJOR
ADJUSTMENTS THIS IS PRETTY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE NEVER KNOW
WHEN THE NEXT DISASTER GOING TO
HIT AND WHAT LEVEL OF RESOURCES
WE'RE GONNA NEED AND WE NEED TO
MAKE BE.
ABLE TO MAKE CURRENT YEAR
ADJUSTMENTS --
OFTEN IF THERE IS A NEED TO ADD
A NEED FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
SO THERE THE E. FUND HAS A
PROVISION WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN MAKE AUGMENTATIONS --
AND THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER ACCOUNT
AND I KNOW --
THIS IS ESTHER RESPONSE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT
THIS ACCOUNT ACTUALLY CENTS
ADDED -- AS
OF JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR --
BUT IT'S BEEN HAVE AN IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR THE STATE TO USE --
TO WHERE BY AGAIN --
THE ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN ALLOCATE FUNDS FROM
ONE OF THE STATE'S RESERVE
ACCOUNTS. TO PAY FOR
UNANTICIPATED COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH DISASTERS.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE --
FOUR WOULD PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
OF INFORMATION ON FEDERAL
FUNDING --
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PLAYS
A REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
HELPING TO FIND DISASTER
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY COSTS IN
THE CASE OF A VERY MAJOR
DISASTER.
ON THERE ARE LOTS OF FEDERAL
PROGRAMS IN THE KEY THINGS THEY
FIND OUR RESPONSE --
DEBRIS REMOVAL REBUILDING PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE --
THEY ALSO HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED
THE HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT AS PER THE THIRD
PANEL -- AND
THAT FIND SOME PROJECTS THAT CAN
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF FUTURE
DISASTERS SO THAT'S AT THE KIND
OF INTERESTING AND HELPFUL
PROGRAM THAT THEY HOP TO HELP US
REBUILD.
AND ALSO BE MORE RESILIENT AND
THE FUTURE.
I AM SO IN GENERAL THE STATE
GETS ABOUT A 75% COST YOU'RE
THAT KIND OF A RULE OF THUMB
THAT THE SEVENTY THAT THE FEDS
COME IN AND PAY ABOUT 75%.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS 75% IT CAN BE
MORE WE CAN SOME WE CAN REQUEST
A HIGHER LEVEL OF REIMBURSEMENT
AND WE HAVE REQUESTED A HIGHER
LEVEL OF REIMBURSEMENT BOOK FOR
BOTH TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FIRES.
I THINK WE REQUESTED A 100% FOR
CERTAIN CATEGORIES IN FOR I
THINK NINETY DAYS --
WE MAY OR MAY NOT GET THAT BUT
ALSO SOME ACTIVITIES ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE SO SOMETIMES THAT WE
CAN GET A LOWER REIMBURSEMENT --
SHARE IF ULTIMATELY SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES WE UNDERTAKE AREN'T
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT --
SO IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT VOCALS TYPICALLY CONTRIBUTE --
IF IT'S IF THEIR LOCAL COST SO
USUALLY THERE'S A 75% FED CUP
FEDERAL COSTS CHAIR.
AND THEN THE STATE LOCAL THE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT REMAINING
25% IF IT'S A STATE COST WE
PRODUCED THE FULL 25% THE LOCAL
COST THE STATE USUALLY COVERS
75% OF THAT 25% AND LOCALS COVER.
UP 25% OF THE 25% WHICH IS ABOUT
6% -- BUT
THE STATE AND SOME CASES HAS
WAIT THAT LOCAL COST SHARE THAT
SOMETHING YOU MAY HEAR A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT --
LATER TODAY AS WELL.
I'M ALSO SOME OF THE TIMING OF
THESE REIMBURSEMENTS CAN VERY SO
IN TERMS OF CASH FLOW THAT
MATTERS RIGHT BECAUSE INITIALLY
WE HAVE TO MAKE THE OUTLAYS.
AND SOMETIMES IT MIGHT BE A YEAR --
TO BEFORE WE ACTUALLY SEE THE
REIMBURSEMENTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE --
FIVE AS AS FOLKS I'M SURE WHERE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS.
REALLY A VERY VERY DESTRUCTIVE --
WILDFIRE SEASON --
WE HAD THE MAJOR ONE COUNTRY
FIRES WE HAD A THOMAS FIRE IN
THE SUBSEQUENT MED SIDES IT WAS --
VERY VERY DESTRUCTIVE IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO AND IN RESPONSE
TO THAT AT THE DEADLY AND
DEVASTATING FIRES OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET REFLECTED SOME OF THOSE
ACTIONS.
IT PROVIDED AUGMENTATIONS ARE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION AMANAT COVERED OF RIGHT
YOU THINGS LIKE IT THERE'S OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
MILLION --
FOR FORCED HELL FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES THERE'S MONEY FOR
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES INCLUDING
HELICOPTERS --
AND ALSO SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING --
FOR HELPING FOLKS RECOVER FROM
THOSE FIRES.
ALSO NOTABLY --
THERE WAS A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE
ACTION IN TERMS OF POLICY BILLS --
THAT REALLY ADDRESSED SOME OF
THE UNDERLYING CAUSES AND TRY TO
MAKE THE STATE MORE RESILIENT
FOR TOWARDS FIRES WE HIGHLY JUST
A FEW OF THEM HERE ON PAGE --
FIVE THERE CERTAINLY MORE THAT
THAT -- WERE
WERE PASSED LAST YEAR THERE
REALLY A BUT WAS QUITE A
COMPREHENSIVE --
SET OF BILLS THAT WERE PASSED
BOTH RELATED TO WILDFIRE
SPECIFICALLY AS WELL AS A NUMBER
OF BILLS.
ADDRESSING DISASTERS MORE
GENERALLY ON SOMEBODY GOT THESE
THROUGH THESE VERY QUICKLY --
JUST IN THE INTEREST OF TIME SB --
NINE OH ONE BY SENATOR DODD FOR
EXAMPLE THAT WAS THE RESULT OF
OF COURSE THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ON WILDFIRES THAT WAS
CHANGES INCLUDING EXPANDING
REQUIREMENTS FOR UTILITIES TO
DEVELOP WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLAN.
AND IT ALSO REQUIRED SUBSTANTIAL
FUNDING ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES --
SB TWELVE SIXTY BY SENATOR
JACKSON CREATED A BIRD FOSTER
VACATION PROGRAM ENHANCED SMOKE
MONITORING FROM PRESCRIBED FIRES --
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EIGHT MEN --
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS TO ESTABLISH
A FORESTRY A CORE PROGRAM AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN BY
AGUIAR-CURRY THAT REQUIRED A
FORCED HEALTH TASK FORCE TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS ON AND
WOOD PRODUCTS MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES AND TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A GOOD MARKET
FOR SOME OF THOSE FOREST
PRODUCTS --
AND AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
REQUIRED BY THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION TO
ENGAGE IN CERTAIN LAND USE
PLANNING ACTIVITIES AMANAT BILL
HAD A LOT OF PROVISIONS RELATED
TO DEFENSIBLE SPACE IN.
A CLEARANCE REQUIREMENTS ON
TRYING TO MAKE US A LITTLE BIT
BETTER PROTECTED FOR THOSE FIRES.
ANOTHER A NUMBER OF OTHER BELLS
A PERSON REQUIRE HAD --
SB -- EIGHT
THIRTY THREE THEIR WHOLE WHOLE
HOST OF BILLS A LAST YEAR THAT
WERE REALLY CHECK TRYING TO
BETTER POSITION THE STATE FOR
THESE DISASTERS AND FIRES.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SIX
UNFORTUNATELY AS AS YOU ALL ARE
AWARE --
EVEN DESPITE ALL THE ACTIONS
THAT WE TOOK IN 200-017-2000 AND
EIGHTEEN WAS EVEN WORSE --
IT WAS REALLY A VERY DEVASTATING
YOU AND I KNOW WE'LL HEAR A LOT
MORE ABOUT THAT --
SO I'M NOT GOING TO A LOT O
DETAIL BUT THE CAMPFIRE WAS --
WAS EXTREMELY DEVASTATING A
PARTICULAR TO THE COMMUNITY
PARADISE ON THE WALL THE IN
HELL'S FIRES WERE ALSO VERY VERY
DESTRUCTIVE AND THERE WERE
OTHERS AS WELL AS WE HEARD SO --
IS REALLY DEVASTATING YEAR --
PAGE SIX HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL --
PIECES I KNOW WE'LL HEAR MORE
ABOUT THE SORT OF PERSON
PERSONAL PIECES SOON --
BUT THE STATE USE THAT TRIO A
PROCESS THAT I MENTIONS TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. TO HELP ADDRESS RESPONSE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
FIRES AND THE TABLE ON PAGE SIX
SUMMARIZES --
THAT FINANCIAL OUTLAY THAT THE
STATE MADE SO OR IS MAKING --
SO YOU'LL SEE A FEW THINGS JUST
THE BOTTOM LINE NUMBERS ARE
PRETTY STRIKING --
OVER THREE BILLION DOLLARS AN
ESTIMATED COSTS IN TERMS OF
LARGE IN TERMS OF RESPONDING TO
AND RECOVERING FROM THOSE.
DISASTERS.
WE DO ANTICIPATE BUT THE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL MEMBERS
ARE QUITE A BIT --
SO THIS IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATE THEY'RE ESTIMATING --
75% OF ELIGIBLE COSTS OF COURSE
THAT COULD BE HIGHER OR LOWER --
BUT I'M EVEN WITHOUT MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF STATE NAT COSTS
THE GENERAL FUND SO THAT'S QUITE
SUBSTANTIAL --
YOU'LL ALSO THERE'S A COUPLE
OTHER THINGS HERE JUST THE
NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS INVOLVED
IN THIS IS ACTUALLY A CONDENSED
WEST -- SO
THEY'RE ACTUALLY EVEN MORE
DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS HERE THAT THIS
DIRECTION COULD SEVERAL SO LOT
OF DEPARTMENTS INVOLVED --
BUT YOU'LL ALSO NOTICE BY FAR
THE MOST SUBSTANTIAL ACTIVITY IN
TERMS OF COST IS DEBRIS REMOVAL --
SAID THE DEBRIS REMOVAL COSTS
ARE REALLY --
QUITE LARGE --
WELL OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS
JUST FOR THE CAMPFIRE --
SO IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE ON IT THE
BIG BIG EFFORT AND I WILL HEAR
MORE ABOUT THAT --
IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT ACTUALLY
ENTAILS BUT JUST FROM A DOLLARS
AND CENTS AS WELL PERSPECTIVE --
THAT THE IT'S A LOT OF IT'S A
LOT SO --
THIS IS HOPEFULLY GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF A SENSE OF SOME OF
THE FOLKS INVOLVED --
AND I'M GONNA STOP HERE --
AND I WILL PASS --
PASSED THE MIKE ON TO A YES AND
CAL RECYCLED TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRES [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
SHE'S NOT GONNA BE THE LA ALONG
WE'RE GONNA BRING OVER --
YES SHE'S SHE'S AN EXPERT NOW
AND THE DISASTER MANAGEMENT.
GOOD MORNING --
CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS --
THANKS PROBABLY UP TO TO TO
SPEND SOME TIME WITH YOU THIS
MORNING --
JUST BUILDING ON HELEN'S
COMMENTS I THINK --
GETS -- THEY
ARE NOT GONNA NOTICE YOUR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WAS REALLY AND
I'M PRESIDENT A YEAR FOR
DISASTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TOTAL --
THE GOVERNOR PROCLAIM SIXTEEN
STATES OF EMERGENCY IN --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PUT ON WE
ALL FIRE RELATED --
OF THOSE --
SIXTEEN MAJOR EMERGENCIES --
THREE WERE WHERE WE PROCLAIM BY
THE PRESIDENT IS MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATIONS MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATIONS DON'T COME EASY
THERE'S THAT'S A THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE DAMAGE.
AND THE REQUIREMENTS TO UP TO ME
TO GET THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
TWO WAY AND TO A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA --
THAT OF COURSE WHAT WAS --
ON THE HEELS OF LAST YEAR'S --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES
WHICH YOU KNOW ALL WE ALL KNOW
WELL RESULT IN THE LOSS OF
ALMOST ELEVEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES AND ALSO RESULTED IN --
IN IN A COUPLE OF BY A MAJOR
DISASTER DECLARATION FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE ALSO
RECEIVED --
WERE ABLE TO GET TWELVE SEPARATE
FIRE MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
GRANTS FROM THE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THESE ARE THESE ARE SPECIALIZED
GRANTS THAT WE GET ON THE FRONT
END OF A FIRE FIRE TO GET EIGHT
AND A HALF MEN I GUESS THEY'RE
CALLED --
THE CRITERIA --
INDICATES THAT IT HAS TO BE
THERE'S AN IMMINENT TO A CAN TO
STRUCTURE FOR MORE AND THAT
THERE'S A POTENTIAL FOR THAT A
BAND TO GO INTO A MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATION SO THESE ARE.
VERY FAST MOVING FIRES AND AND
VERY COMPLICATED AND AND WE HAD
TWELVE OF THOSE --
IN TWO THOUSAND AD EIGHTEEN
OVERALL --
IN THE YEAR STARTING AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WITH THE MINUS YOU KNOW
MIGHT FLOW AS A RESULT THAT CAME
OUT OF THE THOMAS FIRE.
AND THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FIRE SEE EACH --
BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STARTED WITH THEM ON A
C. THE MUD FLOW WITH EXPERIENCE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN
MAJOR FIRES WE HAD SOMETHING
LIKE SEVEN THOUSAND OVERALL
FIRED WITH THIRTEEN MAJOR FIRES
IMPACTED OVER EIGHTEEN COUNTIES --
ENDING OF COURSE OF THE YEAR.
WITH THE CAMPFIRE THE WALLS THE
AND THE HELL'S FIRE SO --
THE WHOLE YEAR WAS FRAMED BY --
A SERIES OF VERY VERY COMPLEX
AND AND COMPLICATED EVENTS --
OVERALL --
OVER MILLION ACRES BURNED INTO
AND EIGHTEEN THE LOSS OF OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX LIVES --
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND STRUCTURES
DESTROYED THAT'S ON TOP TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE ADAMS
LEVIN THOUSAND STRUCTURES
DESTROYED.
SO LAST COUPLE YEARS PHENOMENAL --
LAID RESOURCE WISE ONE OF THE
ROLES OF OF YES OF COURSE
MANAGING AND COORDINATING THE
STATE'S MUTUAL AID SYSTEM --
IN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
RECORDED ALMOST THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND RESOURCES THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM --
INITIAL CHARGE BY ME TO GIVE YOU
SOME AND I THINK IT OR IN YOUR
PACKAGE AS WELL --
SOME IDEAS ABOUT THE THE THE THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE AND RESOURCES
THAT WERE MOVING --
AND THE END OF HOW FAST WERE
HAVING TO MOVE THOSE RESOURCES
MORE MORE AND EVEN THOUGH --
WE WE HAD WE MOVED ALMOST --
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND RESOURCES
WE ALSO HAD TO GO OUT OF STATE --
THOSE ARE IN STAY WHERE TO GO
OUT OF STATE FOR A NUMBER OF OF
ASSETS --
FOUR HUNDRED ENGINES FROM STATES
FROM THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES --
THERE'S A GRAPHIC HERE THAT
SHOWS ALL THE STATES THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO PULL FROM --
AND YOU COULD SEE THAT --
YOU KNOW ADVANCE.
MOVE RIGHT OUT AND WE'RE JUST A
LITTLE [inaudible]
GO [inaudible]
THIS IS.
CAN YOU GUYS SIT THERE.
SENATORS TO HURT.
I THINK SUPPORT TO SEE THE
GRAPHICS BECAUSE IT IT REALLY
DOES A POINT OUT THE THAT THAT
YOU KNOW.
RESPONDING TO THE THESE EVENTS --
REQUIRE ALL HANDS ON DECK AND
YOU WE HAVE A A VERY ELABORATE --
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY THROUGH
WHAT WE CALL THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE COMPACT
WHERE WE'RE ABLE TO PULL IN
RESOURCES FROM THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES WE ALSO GO TO OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AT THE U. S.
FOR SERVICE AND AND THROUGH FEMA
TO PULL AN ASSET AND WE'VE GONE
OUT OF COUNTRY.
BOTH FROM AUSTRALIA AND CANADA
TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT OF STATE --
THIS TEST TO HAVE PULLED OUT OF
COUNTRY RESOURCES AND WE'VE ALSO
GONE TO OUR OUR MILITARY FORCES --
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
BRINGING IN DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE --
ASSETS -- SO
YOU CAN SEE HERE THE NUMBER OF
STATES THE PROVIDED RESOURCES IN
THE CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS A A
PHENOMENAL.
EFFORT -- AS
WELL WE HAVE OF X. NOT JUST FIRE
ASSETS --
WE'VE WE HAD THOUSANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
OFFICERS FROM FROM JURISDICTIONS
FROM FROM ONE END OF THE THE
STATE TO THE OTHER --
AND THEY CAME FROM ACTUALLY
FIFTY FIVE DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES WERE VERY INVOLVED IN
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SIDE OF IT
CHP WITH FISH AND WILDLIFE PARK
CD C. R. A. B. C. EXCEPT HER
WE'D WE LEVERAGE ALL OF THOSE.
ASSETS AS WELL AS FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES FROM PARKS
AND BE A LAMB.
AND THE ROLE IS A NUMBER OF
THINGS EVACUATION SUPPORT.
TRAFFIC CONTROL SEARCH AND
RESCUE --
PATROL TO PROTECT PROTECTION IN
CORNER SERVICES UNFORTUNATELY IN
THE CASE OF THE CAMP FIRES YOU
KNOW -- WE
HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
FATALITIES.
AND AND IT WAS A VERY VERY
COMPLEX MASS FATALITY MANAGEMENT
ISSUE THAT REQUIRED SOME VERY
INNOVATIVE --
BUT CAPABILITIES BUT BUT YOU
KNOW THAT WE WERE TRYING TO MOVE
IN A AT A SPEED AT WHICH WE
COULD GET EVERYBODY ACCOUNTED --
FOR IN A TIMELY ENOUGH FASHION
AND WERE ABLE TO TO YOU SOME
SOME TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS
ACTUALLY --
VERY PROMISING INVENT VERY
PHENOMENAL TO HELP US GET WHAT
WE NEEDED TO GET --
TO AS WELL ARE ARE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD.
ABSOLUTELY PHENOMENAL IN SUPPORT
OF THE OVERALL MISSION OF THESE
DISASTERS.
OVERALL IN TWO THOUSAND A
ROUTINE WE DEPLOYED OVER --
THREE THOUSAND NATIONAL GUARD
MEMBERS THROUGH MISSION TASKING
ASSIGNMENTS HAVE MENTIONED
MISSION TASKING AND AND AND THE
NATIONAL GUARD DOES EVERYTHING
FIVE BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND AND
AND SUPPORTING FIRE OPERATIONS.
TO LOGISTICS TO YOU KNOW THEY
ARE REALLY THE THE ACTION ARM
ACROSS THE BOARD --
AS WELL AS THE POINT OVER EIGHTY
AIRCRAFT IN SUPPORT OF
FIREFIGHTING OPERATION THEY
DROPPED OVER THREE MILLION
GALLONS OF WATER.
AND AND SUPPORTED --
WITH SURVEILLANCE AIRCRAFT AND
AND OTHER KINDS OF SATELLITE --
BY EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS --
SO -- FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF RESOURCES AND
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT ALL OF THIS
COORDINATED THROUGH THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER WAS ACTIVATED
AT THE HUNDRED AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN DAYS LAST YEAR --
THAT WAS IN FOLLOWING TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS LIKE A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE DAYS SO IF
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE OPERATIONS
CENTER GOING BASICALLY TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOR THAT LONG --
TO MANAGE THE THAT NOT JUST THE
RESPONSE BUT AS WE WE AS YOU
UNDERSTAND WE WILL FROM RESPONSE
INTO THE RECOVERY.
OF RECOVERY STARTS ALMOST
CONCURRENTLY WITH RESPONSE
BECAUSE YOU START THINKING ABOUT
THE CASCADING --
IMPACTS AND AND HOW WE'RE GOING
TO ADDRESS THAT BUT THEN
EVENTUALLY ROLLS INTO THINGS AS
A TELE MENTIONED --
NOT JUST --
AYE SHELTERING BUT THEN THEN WE
ROLL INTO --
ON MY KIND OF MID TERM HOUSING
SOLUTIONS AND THEN DEBRIS --
CLARENCE --
AND THEN ULTIMATELY THE ABILITY --
TO TO GET THESE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BACK UP ONLINE
THROUGH THE STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES OF REBUILDING THE
COMMUNITY NOW.
FROM FOR ME DESCRIBING IT SOUNDS
VERY SMOOTH AND FAST AND AND AND
BUT I'M I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT NONE OF THAT IS.
IS IS LANIER --
IT IS A VERY COMPLEX --
SET OF OF CHALLENGES YEARS
REGULATORY THERE'S LEGISLATIVE
THERE'S FINANCIAL --
LOCAL STATE FEDERAL --
PRIVATE ALL OF YOU KNOW ALL OF
THESE FACTORS COME INTO PLAY AND
THEN YOU CAN NEVER LOSE SIGHT
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THAT PROCESS.
TO THE DISASTER SURVIVOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES AND BEING ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO PIVOT AROUND ENSURE THAT.
THAT THOSE FOLKS --
ARE BEING CARED FOR AS MUCH AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN --
TO DO THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS WE
ESTABLISH SOMETHING AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER CALLED UNIFIED
COORDINATION GROUP IS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL STATE COORDINATION
BODY -- IT'S
IT'S MADE UP THE GOVERNOR'S
CABINET --
AS WELL AS OUR REPRESENTATIVES
FROM FROM FEMA ARE ARE FEDERAL
COUNTERPART. TO BE ABLE TO SET
THE OBJECTIVES AND PRIORITIES BY
WHICH WE ARE ARE ARE THAT THE
STATE IS POSITIONING ITSELF TO
RESPOND --
IN THIS CASE WE WERE MANAGING
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
TO SIGNIFICANT CATASTROPHIC
EVENTS TWO SEPARATE ENDS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MUCH LIKE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHAT WE
HAD THE NORTH BAY FIRES AND THEN
WE HAD THE FIRES THE THOMAS FIRE
AND RIVER AND VENTURA.
AND THEN THE MINUS YOU TO MUD
SLIDES AGAIN THIS YEAR WE'RE
MANAGING THE CAMPFIRE ON THE
HEELS OF THE CAR FIRING SHASTA
COUNTY WHICH WAS ALSO A
PRESIDENTIAL DECLARED DISASTER.
AND THE MINUS YOUR COMPLEX FIRE
WHICH NOW TO THIS DATE IS THE
LARGEST LAND MASS FIRE THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY.
AS WELL AS THE WALLS IN HILLS
FIRE THAT WERE HAPPENING IN
MALIBU AND AND THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS A BIT AND BEEN TURNED
LA COUNTY.
SO RESOURCES HAVING TO BALANCE
THOSE RESOURCES OUT NOT JUST IN
THE RESPONSE IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAD WHAT WE HAD THERE BUT BUT
BAND BEGINNING THOSE RECOVERY
PROCESS SEES --
TO ESTABLISH --
PRIORITIES AND OBJECTIVES
COORDINATION GROUP --
WE BUILD A SECONDARY TASK FORCES --
THAT WILL.
HELP -- TO
MANAGE COMPONENTS SO FOR EXAMPLE
THESE TASK FORCES INCLUDE
SHELTER.
HOUSING SCHOOLS ANIMALS
WATERSHED AND DEBRIS THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE ARE ARE ARE AREAS
WHERE WE WILL THEN HAVE --
UP TECHNICAL EXPERTS PIECE IN
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE STATE
LOCAL FEDERAL POSSIBLY PRIVATE
ALL COMING TOGETHER.
IN THOSE TASK FORCES FIRST TASK
FORCES ARE TYPICALLY LEAD --
BY -- YES
BUT CAN BE OTHER STATE AGENCIES
AND LET ME BE CLEAR OF YES IS
ROLE IS --
TO PULL ALL THIS TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE IT TO LEVERAGE THE THE
AUTHORITIES VESTED IN THE
GOVERNOR AND THROUGH THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT THROUGH
ME TO INSURE THAT WE AS A STATE
ARE ON THE RIGHT PATH WAY MOVING
FORWARD. TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
ALSO REMAIN OUT IN FRONT OF
THESE THESE THESE CHALLENGES --
AND WE CANNOT DO THIS ALONE THIS
IS A THIS IS REALLY AT ALL ALL
WHILE ALL HANDS ON DECK ITS IT'S
ALL OF YOU IN YOUR JURISDICTIONS
IT'S AS TRUSTED AGENTS IT'S ALSO
LOCAL AUTHORITIES --
AND IT'S THE PUBLIC AS WELL THAT
WE ALL NEED TO TO WORK THROUGH
AND ULTIMATELY WE ESTABLISH WHAT
ARE CALLED OUR RECOVERY OF
FRAMEWORKS.
AND AND THEY BUILD AROUND THINGS
LIKE COMMUNITY PLANNING AND
CAPACITY BUILDING ECONOMIC
RECOVERY HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE
REBUILDING AND NATURAL AND
CULTURAL RESOURCES AND THEN MATT
IS THAT.
THAT LAST PIECE AS WE MOVE INTO
THE RECOVERY OF A COMMUNITY THAT
HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY DISASTER
ALL THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
IS AN INFUSION OF STATE DOLLARS
THROUGH THE DISASTER PROGRAMS.
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT ARE
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE THROUGH
FEMA -- AND
A DISASTER PROGRAMS THROUGH THE
STAFFORD ACT --
AND THEN OUR OUR WORK WITH THE
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION IN
SEEKING A SUPPLEMENTAL DISASTER
APPROPRIATION BASED UPON WHAT WE
EXPECT THE COST OF DISASTER
WOULD BE SO IN THE CASE OF OF
THE OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FIRES.
WE ARE SEEKING A A SUPPLEMENTAL
ABOUT FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION --
AND I THINK --
LAST YEAR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WAS LIKE FOUR BILLION --
AND AND AND THAT MONEY THAT
COMES IN AND OUT ACTUALLY GOES
TO FEDERAL AGENCIES LIKE HIDE.
AND U. S. T. A. AND AND MANY
OTHERS FEMA.
WHERE THOSE AGENCIES DâN FEELS
THE COFFERS FOR THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE TO MEET
THESE --
RECOVERY FRAMEWORK STRATEGIES
CELL AND I'VE I'VE JUST BOUGHT
FIVE MESSAGE CAN ONLY GO TO OVER
BUT THAT'S GENERALLY WERE BRAD
ON THE DISASTER RESPONSE
RECOVERY.
A GOOD MORNING ERIC.
UP SCOTT SMITH LINE WITH CAL
RECYCLE A THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO GIVE A BRIEF UPDATE ON D. --
TO BE REMOVAL OPERATIONS AND
WHAT COVER CYCLES ROLE ISN'T AT
ALL NEVER --
TO DO THAT CONCISELY HERE OVER
THE NEXT FEW MINUTES NOT BE
HAPPENING INTERN YOUR QUESTIONS
AFTER THAT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN COVER
CYCLES BEEN MISSION TASKED BY
CALLAWAY YES TO ASSIST IN TWENTY
THREE TO BREE REMOVAL PROJECTS
THAT'S CLEARED ASH AND DEBRIS
FROM APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED PROPERTIES --
WE USE THE TERM PROPERTIES
BECAUSE WE'RE CLEARING ENTIRE
PROPERTIES WERE NOT AS FOCUSED
AS THE NUMBER OF STRUCTURES ON
ON EACH PROPERTY.
THE MAJORITY OF THESE INCIDENTS
HAPPEN DUE TO DESTRUCTIVE --
DISASTER RECOVERY EFFORTS AS
YOU'VE HEARD ARE A MULTI AGENCY
EFFORT.
WE COLLABORATE VERY CLOSELY WITH --
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
FOR PRIMARY MANAGEMENT OF THESE
OPERATIONS WE ALSO CORNET
CLOSELY WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE TSC INDEED
YES.
AS WELL AS BEING ON US EPA.
WE ALSO COR NAY WOULD TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS MORE TROUBLE
MONITORING IS INDICATED IN OF
COURSE WE COLLABORATE VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
WHO HAVE REQUESTED THIS
ASSISTANT?
WE HAVE A FEW CORE PRINCIPLES IN
OUR OPERATIONS THOSE ARE SAFETY
COMMUNICATION AND DOCUMENTATION
SAFETY IS ALWAYS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
THAT INSURERS CREW SAFETY
RESIDENTS SAFETY COMMUNITY
SAFETY.
DURING AND AFTER OUR OPERATIONS.
COMMUNICATION MEANS
COMMUNICATING WITH RESIDENTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PARTNER
AGENCIES AND WITHIN THE TEAMS.
TO MAINTAIN AWARENESS AND BE
ABLE TO PROBLEM SOLVE
EFFECTIVELY.
WE DOCUMENT SITES WE DOCUMENT
EXPECTATIONS WE DOCUMENT
DELIVERABLES AND OUTCOMES.
AND THAT ENSURES FISCAL AND
OPERATIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE STATE OVERALL PROGRAM
REFLECTS THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS A STRUCTURAL
FIRES.
AS WELL AS TO FACILITATE THE
QUICKEST POSSIBLE RECOVERY FOR
EACH COMMUNITY.
IT INVOLVES THE REMOVAL OF
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE AS WAS
INDICATED INITIALLY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL.
AND THEN THE STRUCTURALLY SOUND
GERMANY'S.
HAZARD TREES BURN VEHICLES.
BURNED PERSONAL EFFECTS AND
POSSESSIONS.
ASH CONCRETE METAL AND
CONTAMINATED SOILS.
ONCE A PARTIAL IS CLEARED AND
SOIL SEVEN X. SO EXPERT ME SOIL
SAMPLING CONFIRMS THAT WE
RESTORE CLEAN UP GOAL.
WHICH MEANS ALIGNING THE PARTIAL
TO PRE FIRE CONDITIONS.
EROSION CONTROL MEASURES ARE PUT
IN PLACE AND PROPERTIES RETURNED
THE COUNTY INTO THE SURVIVOR.
AND IS READY FOR REBUILDING.
COVER CYCLE SPECIFICALLY
CONTRACTS FOR DEBRIS REMOVAL
CONTRACTOR AND FOR AN ASSESSMENT
AND MONITORING CONSOLE.
THIS INCLUDES THE SOLICITATION
AWARD AN ONGOING MANAGEMENT OF
THESE CONTRACTS.
WE PROVIDE STEP RESOURCES TO THE
IMPACTED AREA TO SUPPORT THE
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM AS WAS
DISCUSSED.
WHICH OVERSEES PROJECT
OPERATIONS HEALTH AND SAFETY
PLANNING.
AND FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES.
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
DEBRIS REMOVAL PROJECT WERE
LIMITED TO ONE OR TWO INCIDENTS
PER YEAR.
WITH A MAXIMUM PROPERTY NUMBER
OF THAT TIME OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX PROPERTIES.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OBVIOUSLY IN BOTH THE
SEVERITY AND THE NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS. FOR YEAR.
WE ARE NOW REGULARLY MANAGING
MULTIPLE CONCURRENT DEBRIS
REMOVAL CLEANUPS WHICH NOW
SPANNED YEAR ROUND.
COSTS THAT WERE ONCE IN THE LOW
SINGLE DIGIT MILLIONS ARE NOW IN
THE BILLION DOLLAR RANGE AND THE
COMPLEXITY.
OF THESE NOW MASSIVE CLEANUP
HAVE DRASTICALLY INCREASED.
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN COVER
CYCLE REMOVE DEBRIS FROM
APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN HUNDRED
PROPERTIES RESULTING FROM
DESTRUCTIVE THOMAS KLAMATH ON
CAR.
MENDOCINO COMPLEX PANI FIRES THE
LATER FOR WHICH WERE CONCURRENT.
DEBRIS REMOVAL PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE REMOVE DEBRIS
FROM THE RESULTING MUDSLIDES
ANTENNA BARBARA COUNTY THAT
FOLLOW THE THOMAS FIRE.
THAT DEBRIS TOGETHER WAS ALMOST
A MILLION TONS OF DEBRIS.
KERN TO BE CLEAN UP OPERATIONS
INCLUDE THE CAMP WILLS IN HELL
FIRES.
THE CAMPFIRE LOAN IS AN
ESTIMATED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
PROPERTIES REQUIRED REMOVAL
DEBRIS REMOVAL OPERATION FOR THE
CAMPFIRE ARE ESTIMATED AT TWELVE
MONTHS.
AN INITIAL ESTIMATE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION THE CAMPFIRE
DEBRIS REMOVAL PROJECT WILL BE
THE LARGEST AND MOST EXPENSIVE
DISASTER CLEANUP THAT WE HAVE
UNDERTAKEN.
THE WALLS IN HELL FIRES OF A
COMBINED ESTIMATE OF THIRTEEN
HUNDRED PROPERTIES.
WHICH WILL REQUIRE DEBRIS
REMOVAL WITH AN ESTIMATED COST
OF A HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
MILLION AND TO WORK NOTING.
THAT WE NOT AT THE CAMPFIRE THE
WILL BE FAR WOULD'VE BEEN THE
LARGEST PART WE NEVER HAD.
IN TERMS OF PROPERTIES. FOR THE
FIRST TIME DEBRIS REMOVAL
OPERATIONS.
FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR WILL BE
ON GOING.
THROUGH THE ENTIRE NEXT FIRE
SEASON.
THAT WILL CREATE NEW CHALLENGES.
OVERALL THE MANAGEMENT WHILE BY
RECOVERY EFFORTS HAVE BEEN ON
ONGOING YEAR ROUND EFFORT AT CAL
OR CYCLE FOR A FEW YEARS NOW.
WE ARE ENGAGED IN CONVERSATION
WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE STATE GIVEN
THESE TRENDS INCREASED WILDFIRE.
SO THANK YOU NOT BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL JUST
SIT HERE TRYING TO WRAP MY HEAD
YOU SAID A HUNDRED MILLION TONS
OF DEBRIS. ONE MILLION ONE
MILLION OKAY START.
THAT'S VIOLATE HONORED THAT I
MISSPOKE HIGH I THINK I JUST GOT
SO OVERWHELMED WITH YOUR NUMBER
I MADE IT EVEN MORE EACH FISHY
BUT A MILLION TONS OF DEBRIS IS
CHEST BEYOND.
THE PALE AND IT'S I'VE GOT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST
COLLEAGUES SO YOU'LL KNOW --
YOU'LL NOTICE ON THE AGENDA.
SECURE DID SHE WILL BE WITH US
THE ANSWER QUESTIONS ON THE
FINAL THE SECOND AND THIRD
PANELS WE APPRECIATE --
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO STAY FOR THE
ENTIRE HEARING I HAVE LASTED A
MINING FIRST FOLLOWED BY FIFTY
MCGUIRE.
WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
FOR YOUR STAFF FOR ORGANIZING.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TIMELY I WANT
TO THANK THE DIRECTOR AND ALL OF
YOUR TEAM --
RESOURCES AND RECYCLING.
LA -- YOU
PAINT A DRAMATIC PICTURE.
MANY YEARS OF US HAVE LIVED
THROUGH IT IN MANY ARE
CONTINUING TO TRY TO RECOVER
FROM THE IMPACTS.
MY QUESTIONS RELATE.
TO PROJECTIONS I HEARD NO
REFERENCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
OR CHANGED CONDITION I THINK
GOVERNOR BROWN DESCRIBED IT IS
THE NEW ABNORMAL.
WHAT DO YOU PROJECT BASED ON
THESE LAST TWO YEARS OF?
VIRTUALLY YEAR ROUND FIRE OF
ANTS.
AND THEN FOLLOWED.
BY FLOOD EVENTS.
HOW DO YOU PREPARE MOVING
FORWARD FOR YOUR PROJECTIONS
WILL THIS?
NEXT CALENDAR YEAR --
DO YOU ANTICIPATE SIMILAR
MULTIPLE INCIDENTS HAPPENING --
SO THAT'S ONE QUESTION
PROJECTIONS FOR THE FUTURE.
AND CONNECTIONS TO CLIMATE
[inaudible]
CHANGE.
I BELIEVE OUR BUDGET IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT NINE OUR FIRE
SUPPRESSION BUDGET WAS AROUND
SEVENTY MILLION.
NOW WE'RE UP TO ABOUT A BILLION --
IN SECOND COMPONENT IS.
THE FEDERAL SHARE.
YOU ESTIMATED BEING ABOUT 75%
HOW MUCH OF THAT FEDERAL SHARE
FOR THIS.
THESE RECENT FIRES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HAS BEEN RECEIVED OR
COMMITTED OR WHEN WE GET ANSWERS
TO THAT.
THANK YOU A QUICK QUESTION --
WELL BOTHER LOOKING MY CRYSTAL
BALL ABOUT NEXT YEAR.
AND THIS COMING YEAR --
YOU KNOW GOVERNOR BROWN WAS WAS
CORRECT I MEAN IS IT IS THE NEW
ABNORMAL I IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WEEK WE ARE --
WE HAVE READ GAUGED FOR AND AND
ANTICIPATING --
BASICALLY THIS BEING THE WAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
DEALING WITH THINGS WE CANNOT.
WAIT.
AND SEE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN --
WE NEED TO REMAIN OUT IN FRONT
OF WHAT WE BELIEVE WITH ALL THE
AVAILABLE.
SCIENCE AND THEN LOOKING BACK AT
THE EXPERIENCES OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS --
I GOT WILL TELL YOU THAT THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL SUFFERING
THE RESULTS OF OF THE OR THE
OUTCOMES OF A SIX YEAR DROUGHT
THAT WAS.
THAT IN PART TO THE STATE THAT
STILL HAPPENING IN IN THAT WITH
THE DROUGHT AND SO --
THOSE ARE FACTORS WHERE --
WE ARE -- WE
ARE GEARING UP WANT ONE FOR
EXAMPLE WE ARE UP TO ADDRESS
THAT WE HAVE RESTRUCTURE THE
STATE'S HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN --
THAT IF THAT IS THE THE STATE'S
SORT OF BIBLE FROM FOR
MEDICATION TO INCORPORATE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE ADAPTATION
SECTION WITH A SERIES OF ACTIONS
TO BUY DOWN THE THE RISK OF OF
CLIMATE RELATED IMPACTS.
WE PUSH THAT DOWN TO ALL OF OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO AS THEY
BUILD THEIR OR HOW AN UPDATE OR
HAS A MITIGATION PLAN AROUND THE
STATE'S PLAN --
THAT WE THINK THAT WITH THE
FEDERAL WE HAVE --
GOOD OBVIOUSLY ALL THE WORK THAT
THAT THE YOU ARE HOT DOWN OVER
THE LAST YEAR TO HELP US PREPARE
AND GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE ARE --
BETTER THAN WE WERE THE PREVIOUS
YEAR -- ONE
AREA FOR EXAMPLE THAT WERE WERE
WERE WORKING ON NOW WE START IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WAS.
WORKING --
TO GET A BETTER FIDELITY OF ALL.
WERE RED FLAG CONDITIONS PRIOR
TO FIRE IGNITIONS --
AND THEN PRE POSITIONING ASSETS
INTO AREAS WHERE THEY WOULD BE
BETTER -- A
BETTER POSITION TO RESPOND MORE
RAPIDLY --
TO SUPPRESS FIRES AND WE WE WE
AND AND IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WE THAT THAT WAS EIGHTY SIX
TIMES WE WE DO WE PRE DEPLOYED.
ASSETS ANOTHER FIRE ASSETS TO
RESCUE ASSETS HELICOPTERS
DISPATCHERS ECCENTRIC WHERE WERE
WE UPS UP STAFF THE SYSTEM
THAT'S A LESSON LEARNED FROM THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES AND
MUCH OF THE WORK THAT WAS DONE
ON THE A SHOOTING THAT IS NOW A
PROGRAM THAT IS.
IN PLACE AND CONTINUES TO BE
REFINED WITHIN WITHIN --
YES -- AND
SO I GUESS THE SHORT PART OF
THAT A SENATOR IS THAT --
WELL WE HAVE TO EXPECT THAT THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE A
MUCH LIKE --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND SO WE
CAN'T SIT BACK AND AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TO BUILD
OUT ON THAT --
THANK YOU AND THEN THE FEDERAL
JOB ON THE FEDERAL PIECE --
SO -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE WERE ABLE
TO GET --
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME INITIALLY
ON THAT FIRE A 100% --
COST RECOVERY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE FIRST THIRTY
DAYS AS FOR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRST THIRTY DAYS FOR
EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE MEASURES --
AND AND RESPONSE COSTS AND THEN
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK --
WITH -- THE
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION AND
THEY WROTE IN --
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS BILL A
NINETY TEN COST WAIVER FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE DISASTER --
WHICH IS VERY HELPFUL BECAUSE
THAT WAS YOU KNOW THE THE THE
PRE OPERATION AND CINNAMON APPLE
LAKE EXCEPT YOUR WAS A CLOSE
ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS SO
THAT WAS A A HUGE.
FACTOR FOR THE STATE THIS YEAR --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ESTABLISHED THE THE AMOUNT AT
THE THE DESIGNATED --
STATUETTE WHICH IS SEVENTY SHARE
WEAVER WE HAVE WE HAVE SOUGHT
THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS OF OF
SEEKING COST YOUR WAIVER FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE --
AND SO FAR THAT HAS NOT.
MATERIALIZED SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH IT IS BEEN WORKING
WITH THE CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION AND IT IS IS BEING
WRITTEN INTO A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION BILL FOR NINETY
TEN FOR FOR ALL THE FIRES BOTH
THE NORTH AND SOUTH.
AND WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR THAT
BILL TO TO GET THROUGH --
BOTH HOUSES THANK YOU IN A FINAL
QUESTION IF I MIGHT MADAM CHAIR
I KNOW OTHERS HAVE QUESTIONS BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE MULTIPLE
LARGE INCIDENT SIGN OF THE
MUTUAL AID IS CRITICAL IN ITS
MULTI STATE ITS MULTINATIONAL.
BUT HOW ARE WE EQUIPPED FOR
ADEQUATE PERSONNEL.
AND THEN THE FATIGUE FACTOR IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH FACTOR OF THIS
NEW ABNORMAL --
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO PROTECT
THE FIREFIGHTERS ON THE FRONT
LINE FROM --
FOR THEIR OWN HEALTH AND SAFETY
IN LONG TERM MENTAL HEALTH.
INSURANCE SO --
IT'S A HUGE ISSUE --
AS I MENTIONED IN MY MY EARLIER
TESTIMONY YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
WE'VE BEEN GOING TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN THREE SIXTY FIVE FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS NOW ACTUALLY --
I THINK I'M I MENTIONED LEAVE AT
TWELVE PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER
DECLARATIONS BEFORE THAT THE THE
MOST PREVIOUS ONE WAS IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SO AGES
THIRTEEN TO THROUGH EIGHTEEN
WE'VE HAD TWELVE SO.
THE AMOUNT OF OF OF EFFORT --
AND WHAT THE FIREFIGHTERS SEE WE
ALSO -- WILL
TELL YOU THAT --
JUST IN THE CAMP FIRE ALONE --
THERE WERE SOME OVER THREE
THOUSAND UNABLE TO FILL ORDERS --
THAT -- THAT
THAT WE YOU KNOW WE JUST HAD TO
WORK AROUND THAT MEANS FOR
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE LINE.
MORE MANAGEMENT PERSONNEL MORE
EMERGENCY MEASURE PERSONNEL MORE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THE LINE IN
THE FIELD FOR LONGER PERIODS OF
TIME THAT'S MORE EXPOSURE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT TO THE SITUATION.
IT'S MORE STRESS WE'RE SEEING A
HIGHER RATE OF OF OF POST IS
DISASTER AND POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS --
IMPACTS AND THE I I THINK IT'S
REALLY SOMETHING THAT THE THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS IN THIS CAR
BUDGET IS PROPOSED --
A WELLNESS --
A STUDY INTO TO LOOK AT SOME
WAYS TO ADDRESS THAT --
BUT I I THINK WE AS A BODY NEED
TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
WE WERE REALLY WERE LEARNING YOU
KNOW BURN OUT OUR FOLKS AND IT
IS -- AND
IT'S WHAT WHAT IS THE BALANCE
YOU HAVE ADVANCE THEIR HAPPENING
YOU HAVE TO RESPOND TO HIM YOU
HAVE TO RECOVER FROM.
YOU KNOW WHAT WERE OR YES
MANAGING IT WE DON'T EAT ME AS A
RESPONSE BUT THEN WE WE ALSO
MANAGING THE RECOVERY.
AND BUT THERE'S NO YOU KNOW
FAILURE IS NOT AN OPTION SO YOU
HAVE.
TO SUCK IT UP AND AND RESPONDED
SO.
YOU TRY TO WORK WITH LIKE WORK
LIFE BALANCE WITH YOUR EMPLOYEES
BUT I I WILL TELL YOU I'M I'M
SEEING IT.
WITH MY STAFF I'VE SEEN IT WITH
MANY OTHERS.
SOME FIRE FOLKS SOME RESPOND THE
COME OFF UNLESS THEY'RE ORDERED
BACK THEN YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
WANT TO COME BACK OF TO WORK TO
WORK FOR A WHILE THEY NEED THAT
BREAK --
ENTERS CASCADING IMPACTS TO
REMEMBER OUR WHAT OUR OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE PART OF THE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY FAMILY AS WELL SO
IT'S NOT THE THE FIREFIGHTER ON
THE LINE BUT IT'S THE WIVES AND
THE CHILDREN AND AND THE SPOUSES
AND ECCENTRICITY.
WE NEED TO IT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS VERY VERY CONCERNING AND THE
MORE WE GET BUT THESE EVENTS AND
IF IT CONTINUES LIKE THIS.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO TO REALLY DO --
MUCH MORE INVESTMENT IN.
JUST ON THAT POINT.
I AM.
PLEASED TO HEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
STUDYING THE SAME PACKS.
BUT I WOULD SUBMIT FUTURE
BUDGETS NEED.
TO INCLUDE.
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR
RELIEF TREATMENT --
IN ORDER.
OPEN DOORS FOR FOLLOW UP THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TEAMS.
EXTRAORDINARY WORK THE ALWAYS
BUT ESPECIALLY THESE LAST TWO
YEARS.
GREATLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU
SAID SENATOR MCGUIRE FOLLOWED BY
SENATORS MORE LOCK IN STERN
CENTER MCGUIRE BECAUSE MUCH
VENTURE AND APPRECIATE YOU HAVE
SINCE HERE AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT. TO SAY THANK YOU TO A
DOCTOR DUE TO FOR HIS INCREDIBLE
WORK AT GETTING KNOWN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN IN THE VALLEY
FIRE AND ALL THROUGHOUT.
THE NORTH A FIRE STORM THERE'S
NO ONE THAT DOES A BETTER AND
WE'RE SO GLAD THAT HE IS NOT
RETIRED --
SO -- I'M
NOT SURE IF HE'S SAYING THAT BUT
BUT YEAH HE IS --
HE'S TRULY A GIFT TO THE STATE
ALONG WITH HIS TEAM JUST WANT TO
SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE --
HOW ARE UNDER RESOURCE WE ARE
SPECIAL WITH CAL FIRE IN REGARDS
TO A FIRE ENGINES?
WERE THIRTY ONE SHORT THIS YEAR
THIRTY ONE SHORT OF WHERE WE'RE
AT IN --
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND
GRATEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR IN --
IS ADVANCING --
FUNDING FOR THIRTEEN BUT BUT
EVEN AT THAT WERE STILL BELOW
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE STAFFING
LEVELS.
WHEN IT COMES ENGINES PERSONNEL
FOR CAUGHT FIRE?
AND WE'RE SEEING THE WORST
WILDLAND FIRE DISASTERS --
IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
IS SIX MILLION IN THE BUDGET
THAT THE GOVERNOR --
THANKS TO LEADERSHIP OF BOTH
CALIFORNIA WE S. FOR ADDITIONAL
A PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES. FOR
FIREFIGHTERS BUT NEED TO ADVANCE
THAT FIVE MILLION FOR THE LONG
TERM STUDY.
IN THE IMPACTS OF WILDLAND FIRE
SMOKE THE TOXIC SMOKE A IT WAS A
BILL THAT I CENTER LEYVA ADVANCE
ASSN BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
ASSURING CRUCIATE HER LEADERSHIP
ON THAT ALONG WITH.
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
COW FROM PROFESSIONAL FIRE HERE --
WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT PRE
POSITIONING JUST REAL QUICK YET
MENTION IT THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR FIGHT ON THAT --
ONE AS WE TAKE A LOOK INTO THIS
YEAR LESSONS LEARNED IF YOU
DON'T MIND BEING QUICK ON THAT --
AND THEN I WOULD LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT RECEIVE HER.
TO NINE ONE ONE GO TO SELL
LESSONS LEARNED ON PRE
POSITIONING WELL ON THE ON THE
PRE POSITION I I YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT WE WE CAN WE CONTINUE.
TO REFINE THE THE THE WAY THE
CRITERIA AND THE WAY WE MOVE
THESE RESOURCES THE PRE
POSITIONED THEM --
ONE ONE BIG FACTOR IN PRE
POSITIONING OBVIOUSLY IS THAT --
YOU KNOW IF AND I USE THIS
EXAMPLE --
YOU KNOW THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE SAYS THESE ARE GOING TO
BE A RED FLAG CONDITIONS YOU
KNOW OVER OVER ARCHING SEVEN
COUNTIES SO THE QUESTION IS WHAT
WHERE DO YOU PLACE THOSE
RESOURCES.
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO BE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND SO SO ONE OF THE?
LESSONS LEARNED WEEK WE'VE WE'VE
KNOWN IT AND WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS ADDRESSING IT--
AND HOPEFULLY THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WILL GET THROUGH --
NINE THROUGH --
THE ASSESSMENT --
AND ANALYSIS OF OF MICRO
CLIMATES --
WITHIN PORTIONS OF THE COUNTY
BASED UON HIGH HIGH SURVEYOR
HIGH EVERITY TEAR WANTING TO
TEAR -- TO
MAPS THAT MAKE IT MAKE IT BETTER
EDUCATION THAT IF WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A WEATHER EVENT.
INS IN IN A PARTICULAR COUNTY.
THEY WE CAN CROSS OVER WITHOUT
THE DATA ANALYTICS THAT THAT WE
HAVE AND THEN LOOK AT REAL TIME --
WHETHER -- I
DATED THAT WERE COMING OUT OF
KEY AREAS --
WITHIN THE WITHIN THE WHILE
THERE BY LAND URBAN INTERFACE --
AND AND AND TAKE THAT THEY LIVE
MAKE ANALYSIS TO HELP US
DETERMINE THAT INSTEAD OF
STICKING RESOURCES IN THE MIDDLE
OF A FIVE COUNTY AREA WE'RE
GONNA PUT RESOURCES WHERE WE
BELIEVE THAT FIRE STARTS ARE
GOING TO EITHER START OR OR OR
THERE IS THE HIGHEST RISK OF OF
IMPACT.
WE CAN THEN BUILD AROUND THAT --
BUT WE CAN BUILD AROUND THAT IN
ALERT AND WARNING OF THE PUBLIC
AS IN THAT AREA WE CAN GET THEM
BETTER PREPARED --
AND AND AND AND IT HELPS US.
BUT A COUPLE STEPS OUT IN FRONT
OF IT SO WE'RE CONTINUING TO
EVOLVE THAT PROCESS --
CENTER IN AND I I I I THINK ALSO
SAY THAT WE WE'VE WE'VE LEARNED
ALREADY THAT THE PRE POSITIONING
IS A A POSITIVE --
ADDITION AND IT HELPS TO GET
RESOURCES --
ON ON FIRES FAST WE'VE HAD SOME
REALLY SUCCESSFUL RESULTS OF
THAT IN -- I
IT ALSO HELPS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE THE PRE POSITIONED RESOURCES
IS A IT'S NOT JUST AN
AUGMENTATION FOR FOR THE STATE
IT THIS HELPS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AS WELL --
IN MAY ONE UP HELPS THEM PLAN IT
UP SOME PLAN FOR SURE IT MAKES
THEM START THINKING ABOUT WHAT
WHAT IS THE CHALLENGE IT WITHIN
THEIR THEIR RESPECTIVE
JURISDICTION --
AND UP AND AND AND IT ALLOWS US
TO HAVE A BETTER A COLLABORATION
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
AND THEN YOU AS YOU SAW FROM THE
SLIDES --
YOU KNOW THE MAJORITY OF ASSETS
THAT E YOU KNOW CAL FIRE AS A
LOT ASSETS THERE BUT THE
MAJORITY OF ASSETS THAT COME.
ON A ON A TO RESPOND ALL THESE
FIRES COMES FROM THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM AND THAT'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO WE'RE REALLY
PRESSING --
THEM AND AND WE WE KNOW THAT ONE
TO EVOLVE TO LESSON LEARNED IS
TO GET THIS.
A LOT OF LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY
BETTER GOOD SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
GET A BETTER IDEA ABOUT WHERE
THE THREAT IS ACTUALLY NO THANK
YOU --
EMERGENCY ALERTS IF YOU COULD
BRIEFLY JUST COMING TO ON YOU
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
ADVANCING THOSE NEW GUIDELINES
PART OF FIRE SEASON.
HITTING US HERE IF YOU CAN JUST
UPDATE US ON THAT --
AND THEN I JUST HAVE A QUICK%
QUESTION FOR DIRECTOR SMITH LINE
AS WELL --
SO --
BULLARD MORNING --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING DID
DILIGENTLY WE CONVENE.
A TECHNICAL COMMITTEE --
AS PART OF THE STATE'S
STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT --
ADVISORY BODY IT'S IT'S THE BOB
BODY THIS IN STATUTE THE DRIVES
ARE STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT TECHNICAL
COMMITTEE WAS MADE UP OF LOCAL
STATE AND AND AND FEDERAL.
COUNTERPARTS --
AND THEY CAME UP WITH SOME JUST
TO PROVE THE EVERYBODY AND LAST
THE WEEK I THINK OR MAYBE MONDAY
I CAN KNOW WHAT DAY IT IS TODAY --
SO -- WE
DOES DOES GUIDELINE SHOULD BE
HITTING THE STREET HERE --
WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK OR SO AND
BATTLE THEN BEGIN TH PROCESS OF
WORKING --
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH A CONTACT
WITH ALL THE COUNTIES --
AND AND THE CITY'S --
TO BEGIN THE PROCESS OF INSURING
THAT -- THAT --
YOU KNOW THOSE GUIDELINES ARE
BEING INCORPORATED INTO --
LOCAL AUTHORITIES WE CAN GET
THAT BASS LINE WHERE AT LEAST
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME
PAGE ON ON A WRITTEN WARNING.
YEAH AND I THINK THAT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP
ON MAKING SURE THAT EVERY COUNTY
HAS THE ABILITY WHITE WE AND I
KNOW THERE'S THAT THERE'S SOME
STICK IN THERE AS WELL --
IF COUNTIES ARE IN IMPLEMENTING
THE COULD SEE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT GRANTS --
GOING AWAY BUT WE CAN TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT.
MANAGER JUST ONE LAST QUESTION
FOR DIRECTORS MISALIGNED --
BUT ONE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
WAS ADVANCED LAST YEAR IN THE
BUDGET TO BE ABLE TO STAFF UP
AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
CHRISTMAS TIME FOR YOUR WORK YOU
YOU HAVE.
A RELATIVELY SMALL SHOP WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DEBRIS REMOVAL AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO YOUR
TEAM YOURSELF --
AND WANT TO SEE WHERE YOU'RE AT
ON THAT BECAUSE WERE SEEN.
AS THAT MAN CHAIR HAD JUST
MENTION RECORD LEVELS OF BURKE
DEBRIS UNDERSTAND THIS BEEN A
FEDERAL OPERATION.
BUT IN THE NEW REALITY THAT
WE'RE IN WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
STATE OPERATION NUMBER --
ONE THE EXPERTISE WITHIN YOUR
SHOP IT'S JUST LIKE FEMA DIES AT
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE IN A QUICK
AND EFFICIENT MANNER INTO
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE IMPACTED.
BY WILDFIRE OR BY EARTHQUAKES IN
DIRECTOR GEORGE PLEASE --
CHIME IN ON THIS ONE AS WELL IF
YOU'D LIKE BUT THIS IS MY FIND
WHERE YOU AT WITH STAFF AND UP
AND YOUR THOUGHT ON THOSE PRIME
CONTRACTORS --
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
INQUIRY --
THESE ARE CRITICAL RESOURCES FOR
THE DEPARTMENT --
WE HAVE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
FILLING THOSE POSITIONS FOR
NUMBER OF REASONS --
WE WERE AUTHORIZED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AND SHORTLY
THEREAFTER WE WERE.
DEALT DIRECTLY BACK INTO WILD
FIRE NAM AND IT'S THE SAME
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE BUILDING
THAT TEAM MATTER IMMEDIATELY
DEPLOYED. FOR EMERGENCY WORK --
WE ALSO --
GENERALLY HAVE.
BUT AS I'M LEARNING HAVE A HARD
TIME STEPPING UP SOME THESE
CLASSIFICATIONS WITHIN
GOVERNMENT IN GENERAL ALL THAT
NOT WITHSTANDING --
IS NOT TO SAY IT'S NOT BEEN A
TOP PRIORITY FOR US.
DANCE YOUR QUESTION DIRECTLY
WHERE WE ARE IS THAT WE HAVE
HIRED THE TEAM LEADER THE
SUPERVISOR FOR THAT POSITION --
SO WE HAVE FILLED THAT POSITION
WE'VE FILLED ONE OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY POSITIONS --
WITH RESPECT TO WASTE MANAGEMENT
ENGINEER CLASSIFICATIONS WE ARE
CURRENTLY SCHEDULING INTERVIEWS.
WE HAD --
SOME CHALLENGES GETTING
QUALIFIED RESPONSE ON THE LIST
THAT WERE AVAILABLE TO US SO WE
HAD TO GO OUT WE'RE ON OUR THIRD
LIST I BELIEVE --
AND WE'RE BEING AS CREATIVE AS
WE CAN TO ATTRACT PEOPLE TO
THESE POSITIONS AND THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY HIRING ARE --
INTERVIEWING FOR THOSE WAYS
MENTION ENGINEER POSITIONS.
I WOULD LIKE THAT AWFUL UP
ONLINE OFFLINE MAYBE --
FOLLOW UP WITH A CHAIR MAKOWSKI
THE BUDGET SEVEN AND WE CAN BE
TOGETHER WITH DIRECTORS FOR
FLYING ONTHAT AND SO EVENTUALLY --
PRIME CONTRACTORS BEING ABLE TO
BRING THEM IN TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE DEBRIS MANAGEMENT AND
REMOVAL CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT
ABSOLUTE I THINK THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THIS --
GIVEN THE DIRECTION THAT WE'RE
GOING HAVING AT A PROCESS TO
FACILITATE BRING ON CONTRACTORS
IS GONNA BE VERY IMPORTANT --
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES ON
THAT VERY ISSUE ALONG WITH --
YES TO TRYING TO STREAMLINE THAT
PROCESS.
AND WE DO THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
TO YOU SEE THIS MY LAST QUESTION
MANAGER YOU SEE EVENTUALLY ONCE
YOU'RE ABLE TO GET FULLY STAFFED --
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS THE
PROCUREMENT SOME TYPE.
OF A PRIME CONTRACTOR PROCESS
SEEN TO BE TO SECURE THOSE
VENDORS.
I'M SORRY TAKE SECURE IT TO
SECURE THE VENDORS WHO YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE ON CONTRACTS AND WE
DO SEE DISASTER CAN BE REMOVED A
DIFFERENT APPROACH MASTER
SERVICES APPROACH YES OKAY.
THAT'S GREAT BEFORE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
MISTER SMITH LINE I JUST WANT TO
ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS --
ON STATE RESPONSIBILITY --
I WAS A YOUNG TEENAGER AND MY
DAD MOM WOKE ME UP IN THE MIDDLE
AND I WE HAD A RUSH OUT OF THE
HOUSE BECAUSE THE HOUSE NEXT
DOOR WAS ON FIRE THE GARAGE IT
STARTED.
BURNING UNFORTUNATELY THE
FIREWALL KEPT IT FROM HITTING
THE REST OF THE HOUSE BUT IT WAS
A MEMORABLE NIGHT THEY'LL NEVER
FORGET EVEN WATCH MY DAD TRYING
TO OPEN THE CAR DOORS TO MOVE
THEM AWAY FROM.
THE OFFICE.
BUT BUT IT WAS THE HOMEOWNERS
RESPONSIBILITY THERE TO REMOVE
ALL OF THE DEBRIS AND IN WHEN
YOU LOOK AT A HOMEOWNER'S
INSURANCE POLICY IT IT'S IT
THERE'S A COMPONENT AND THEY'RE
BUILT ON A REMOVAL OF THE DEBRIS.
SO FOR THOSE OF US AND URBAN AND
SUBURBAN.
AREAS WE WE KIND OF WONDER WHY
WITH THE STATE HAVE TO COME IN.
AND REMOVE DEBRIS FROM THESE
WILDFIRES OWNS AND AYE AYE AYE
AND ALWAYS WILL BE CLINICAL ICE
WHEN TRYING TO THE DEFINITION OF
MAYBE THE HISTORY OF HOW.
THAT STARTED IN WHY A EVERYONE
IS RESPONSIBLE.
FOR AIN'T THROUGH THEIR TAXES
FOR FOR THIS SERVICE --
FALL INTO THE PART I CAN I MIGHT
DEFERRED TO DIRECTOR GO DUE TO
FOR PART OF THE CENTER AS WELL --
THE COST PER DEBRIS REMOVAL
GENERALLY EXCEED THE COMPONENTS
OF THE INSURANCE THAT ARE
ALLOTTED FOR DEBRIS REMOVAL WE
DO RECOVER THAT COMPONENT UNDER
INSURANCE THAT IS A LOT OF FOR
DEBRIS REMOVAL --
I'M GONNA.
WITH RESPECT TO THE REQUEST FOR
ASSISTANCE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND IF I WOULD I WOULD DEFER TO
TRADITION.
SO CENTER I THINK ON THE THE
CASE BY CASE SOMEBODY WAS HOME
BURNS DOWN AND THEIR FIRE
INSURANCE TYPICALLY HANDLED BY.
HOWEVER THE INSURANCE COMPANY I
HIRES -- IS
THE THE NORMAL PROCESS FOR A
CASE BY CASE EVEN A MODERATELY
SMALL MAYBE A COUPLE HOMES.
BUT WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
KIND OF OF FIRE IMPACTS THE
LOSSES THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEN --
HERE --
THESE EVENTS RESULT IN A COUPLE
THINGS FIRST OF ALL THEY RESULT
IN A VERY SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAKE THE
CAMPFIRE FOR EXAMPLE --
MOST OF THESE HOMES WERE BUILT
IN THE SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES THE
APP'S BEST THIS AND OTHER KINDS
OF HOUSES MATERIALS IN THEM.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT --
WHEN YOU'VE GOT A MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF LOSSES LIKE THAT IT'S A VERY
LEVEL OF SOME PEOPLE ARE UNDER
SURE SOME PEOPLE ARE NOT INSURED --
AND ULTIMATELY IT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY FOR THE STATE.
TO COME IN AND OF WORK TO REMOVE
FIRST OF ALL --
IDENTIFY ALL THE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE PAINS PASSED THE
SIDES -- ALL
OF THOSE THINGS THAT ARE YOU
KNOW PROPANE.
AND GET THOSE OFF OF THE WAY
DISPOSE OF THEM APPROPRIATELY
AND THEN COME IN --
AND AND BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
DOING THE DEBRIS REMOVAL
ULTIMATELY THOUGH I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT EACH AND EVERY
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNER WATCH WE
START --
THAT FACE TO OF DEBRIS REMOVAL
UP TO THE HOMEOWNER THEMSELVES
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THE THEY
WANTED A STEP INTO THE
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM OR NOT. 99% A
TIME THEY THEY ALL DO BECAUSE IT
IS -- IT IS
THE MOST EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
WAY OF DOING IT --
IF THERE ARE INSURANCE PROCEEDS
THAT -- ARE
NOT TIED TO YOU TO THAT
INDIVIDUALS INSURANCE --
PACKAGE THAT CALLS FOR DEBRIS.
WHEN WE MAKE THIS CLEAR TO THEM
AND THEY FIND THE RIGHT OF ENTRY
FORM WHILE WE WORK WITH THE
COUNTY TO GO IN AND PULL BACK
THOSE?
THOSE SECTIONS OF THE INSURANCE
PROCEEDS THAT ARE DESIGNATED FOR
DEBRIS CLARENCE TO REIMBURSE THE
GOVERNMENT.
SO ULTIMATELY IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S ABOUT REALLY HEALTH AND
SAFETY THE SECOND PIECE IS
ECONOMIC RECOVERY THE SOONER WE
CAN GET --
THESE COMMUNITIES CLEARED OF A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF FIRE DEBRIS
THE SOONER THAT COMMUNITY CAN
GET BACK UP ONLINE.
REBUILDING CAN START TAX BASE
CAN START TO BE GENERATED AND
THAT BACK COMMUNITY CAN CAN MOVE
FORWARD.
OFFICE POINT TO US IS THE CINEMA
COUNTY AND AND JUST ABOUT A YEAR
AFTER THE 5% REBUILT.
AND THAT IS REALLY BECAUSE WE
RAPIDLY WHEN AND WERE ABLE TO
MOVE OUT WE KNOW HISTORICALLY
THAT IF LEFT UP TO EACH AND
EVERY PERFECTLY THAT SIZE OF A
DISASTER.
THAT THAT WE WOULD SIT THERE FOR
YEARS BEFORE IT GETS THEN IT
GOES TO THE COUNTY HAS TO GET
INTO ABATEMENT PROGRAM
ULTIMATELY IT BECOMES ANOTHER
FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR THE COUNTY.
THEREBY EXASPERATING THE
INABILITY TO DO GOOD ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND GET BACK GOING
AGAIN.
SO AND ME TO SAY THAT THAT AT
ANY TIME DEPENDS ON ON THE
COUNTIES EACH COUNCIL DIFFERENT.
IN THE CASE OF SANTA'S SAN DIEGO
LAST YEAR DURING DURING THE THE
I THINK WAS THE WEST FIRE.
THE COUNTY HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ALSO STEP IN AND DO THE
DEBRIS AND WE WORK WITH US ON
SOME COST REIMBURSEMENT THINGS
SO IF THE COUNTY HAS THE ABILITY
AND MANY COUNTIES LIKE TO DO
THAT IF IT'S A MANAGEABLE SIZE
DISASTER.
BUT WE'RE SEEING THE CHI
DISASTERS WE'VE BEEN SEEING THEM
IT REALLY IS A A VERY MASSIVE
FILES SORT OF RECOVERY.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO BE
CLINICAL ABOUT IT NOT AND
UNEMOTIONAL BECAUSE CERTAINLY
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THE THE ISSUE IS.
WE'RE STILL BUILDING.
AND WILDFIRES OWNS AND I HAVE
THE MY COUNTY.
LAGUNA BEACH CERTAINLY HAD A
MASSIVE CONFLAGRATION IN NINETY
THREE FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
HOMES AND WE SEE IT SANTA
BARBARA MONTECITO --
OAKLAND HILLS AND IT'S SO.
I'M JUST SITTING HERE OKAY WE
DID LEARN SOME THINGS OVER THE
YEARS LIKE DON'T YOU SHAKE
GROUPS ANYMORE --
BUT I IS THERE.
IS THERE --
AYE AYE DIFFERENTIAL AND I I
APOLOGIZE FOR A LOOKING AT THIS.
IN IN HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
POLICY RATES BETWEEN UP
WILDFIRES OWN HOMEOWNER AND
DIFFERENTIAL BE REFLECTED.
THERE'S DEFINITELY ACOSTA FOR
ANGEL IF YOU'RE LIVING IN THE
WHAT WE AND AND I'M AS I'M TOLD
THEM.
YOU KNOW BUT THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER A POPPY TALKED AND
TALKED TO THEM BUT TO GIVE YOU
BETTER FIDELITY ON THIS BUT THE
THE REALITY IS IS THAT --
INSURANCE RATES IN THE IN THE
WALL THEM BERMAN AND INTERFACE
IN THOSE HIGH INTENSITY ZONES --
HAVE GONE UP --
AND IDEAS IS THAT --
YOU KNOW --
INSURANCE ALL OF COURSE IS THE
FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE FOR FOR
ANY KIND OF DISASTER
INDIVIDUALLY SHOULD PROTECT YOUR
INVESTMENTS BY HAVING GOOD
INSURANCE AND NOT YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS ARE.
ARE NOT A MAKE YOUR WHOLE
PROGRAM THERE STRICTLY --
BUT THE REALITY IS IS THAT THOSE
INSURANCE RATES ARE HIGHER IN
THOSE AREAS LET ME ALSO STATE
THAT -- THAT
THE BUILDING CODES THAT WE DID
THAT WE CALIFORNIA HOUSE FOR FOR
CONSTRUCTION IN THE WHILE IN
URBAN --
INTERFACE ARE THE MOST STRINGENT.
CODES -- IN
THE WORLD AND THAT KIND OF THING
THAT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
CAN'T AND SHOULDN'T AND WON'T.
DO MORE IN THAT AREA WHICH WHICH
WE'VE BEEN WHICH WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT AND AND LOOKING AT
TRYING TO FIND.
OTHER PROGRAMS IN OTHER WAYS TO
INCREASE THAT RESILIENCY
CAPABILITY ALONG IT'S MORE THAN
JUST DEFENSIBLE SPACE CLEARING
IT IS REALLY WHAT IS YOUR
STRUCTURE LOOK LIKE.
AND MAYBE THAT'S THROUGH --
INCENTIVES TO DO RETROFITTING
FOR HOMEOWNERS WORKING MORE WITH
THE ENSURE I'D LIKE TO SEE THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES QUITE
FRANKLY COME TO THE TABLE MORE
AND COME UP WITH WITH.
TAKING SOME INTEREST MONEY THAT
YOU'RE MAKING AND PUTTING IT
INTO A MITIGATION PROGRAM THAT
COULD.
COULD COULD MATCH --
MAYBE MATCH THAT WHAT WE'RE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN'T MATCH --
WITH STATE DOLLARS OR OR DO A
PROGRAM A GRANT TO THE HOMEOWNER
AND IF THE HOMEOWNER DOES IT.
THEN BRING DOWN THEIR INSURANCE
PREMIUMS MAYBE 20% --
OR SO -- UP
THERE OF A OF A OF THE BENEFIT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DONE SOMETHING
POSITIVE TO BUY DOWN THE RISK OF
THE OF THE DISASTER WE'VE DONE
THIS IN THE EARTHQUAKE AREA AND
IS PROVING TO BE.
PRETTY POSITIVE AND I I THINK
THAT'S AN AREA WE NEED.
TO GET THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
LIMIT MORTGAGE WITH.
THANK YOU ASK THE BASIC QUESTION
AND YOU EXCEEDED EXPECTATIONS
YOU COVERED.
ACTUALLY WHERE I SORT OF WANTED
MY MOM WOULD BE HAPPY.
TO TALK.
WELL ALL THROUGH MY SCHOOL YEARS
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH THE HOW
TO BALANCE A LOT OF THINGS WE
HAVE --
WE'RE NOT TALKING P. JEANNIE BUT
WHAT WE DO ABOUT [inaudible]
THIS.
UTILITY WHAT WE DO ABOUT
INSURANCE.
ISSUERS AND AND AND WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE.
THERE THAT HAVE TO SOMEHOW BE
STAYING IN BALANCE AND SO I LIKE
THE IDEA OF INCENTIVIZING A
HOMEOWNER DO SOMETHING WHETHER
TO DIFFERENT SPRINKLER SYSTEM OR
WHATEVER.
IT MAY BE ON THE OUTSIDE OF THE
HOME -- SO
I'M BUT WE'RE JUST LOOKING IDEAS
I APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE MY
LAST QUESTION IS WITH REGARDS --
TO RED FLAG DAYS --
WE HAVE OUR CONDITIONS YOU YOU
MENTION THOSE VISIT AND WHEN WE
HAVE ZERO HUMIDITY ORANGE COUNTY
I THINK WE PUT OUR HELICOPTERS
UP WHICH ARE LOOKING.
YOU KNOW AND AND START
MONITORING RIGHT AWAY BUT EVEN
THAT DOESN'T HELP EVEN WITH THE
WITH THE SPEED OF THE WIND
THINGS CISCO SO SO QUICKLY --
TALKING TO ONE OF THE UTILITIES
THIS WEEK THEY ACTUALLY HIRED A
METEOROLOGIST TO TO DO THE
WEATHER --
AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING DOES
IT DOES --
YES FOLLOW THE SAME APPROACH OR
DO YOU JUST RELY ON THE FEDERAL
WEATHER SERVICE WELL I I I MADE
BY NIGHT KIND OF GLOSSED OVER
THAT.
YOU KNOW I SAID NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE WE WE ACTUALLY HAVE UP
OF RELATIVELY WE I SAY WE CAL
FIRE AND WORKING WITH US AND AND
AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
HAVE.
A LEVEL OF CAPACITY WE HAVE FIRE
FORECASTERS WITHIN OUR OPERATION
CENTERS --
NORTH AND SOUTH --
WE WHEN WE HAVE A FIRE READING
INDEX THAT THAT GIVES AS GIVES
US -- A LOT
A LOT THAT HELPS AT SOME LEVEL
YOU'RE IN THAT AND SO I IN ORDER
HELICOPTERS GO FOR FIRE STARTS --
BUT WE'RE NOT WHERE WE NEED TO
BE CENTER WE WE WE WE NEED WE
NEED TO HAVE BETTER YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S BEEN DONE LIKE THIS.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS WE NEED TO GO
TO THE NEXT LEVEL WE NEED TO
BECOME MORE SOPHISTICATED.
USE TECHNOLOGY SO WE'RE ALL
SEEING IT IN A REAL TIME WAY
THAT TECHNOLOGY THOSE MICHAEL
CLIMATE STATIONS --
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR IN HIS
BUDGET HAS --
HAS --
PROPOSE SOME SOME MICRO CLIMATE
STATIONS IN CAMERA SYSTEMS --
THAT THAT'S THE KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH OUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND THEN AND THEN ALL THAT NEEDS
TO BE COMING INTO A PLACE WHERE
YOU HAVE ANALYSTS.
THAT ARE --
THAT ARE EVALUATING IT AND AND
CONNECTING THE DOTS AS TO WITH
THESE ARE GOING TO BE THE AREAS
OF OF MOST CONCERN AND THAT WE
NEED TO ACT ACCORDINGLY SO WE WE
DO HAVE CAPABILITY AND AND WE'VE
BEEN USING IT OUT TO THE TO THE
TO THE DATE THIS.
IS HOW WE'RE DOING IT BUT I'LL
TELL YOU THAT THERE IS
DEFINITELY MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIRDLE CHI ARE
REALLY APPRECIATE RESPONSES AND
MISTER SMITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
AND I WON THE ECHO MY MY
COLLEAGUES --
COMMENDATION.
THERE TO GIVE THE DG YOU KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN JUST ON THE SPOT IN
THE TOUGHEST SPOTS THERE ARE IN
THE WHOLE STATE AND SEEING SOME
REAL HUMAN TRAGEDY OF THESE LAST
FEW YEARS AND HERE TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AND AND ALL THAT ARE
WORKING STAFF CAL RECYCLING
THROUGHOUT.
THE COORDINATING AGENCIES WE
APPRECIATE IT YOU KNOW
GOVERNMENT.
WE DON'T NOTICES UNTIL IT REALLY
MATTERS.
AND IT REALLY MATTERS RIGHT NOW
SO -- YOU
KNOW MY MY INITIAL QUESTION JUST
A VERY SIMPLE HIGH LEVEL ONE
WHICH IS HOW.
HOW DO YOU DEFINE?
PREPAREDNESS WAR READINESS YET.
HAD HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU DEFINE
IF WE'RE READY.
THAT IS A SIMPLE QUESTION WITH A
VERY.
COMPLICATED ANSWER --
CALIFORNIA A IS EXTREMELY --
UNIQUE IN MANY WAYS --
YOU KNOW.
WHERE WE AND WE ASK YOU KNOW WE
WE HAVE TO WE TALK ABOUT REASONS?
APPEARED AS WE LOOK AT LEVELS OF
RESILIENCY WERE AT ALL HAZARDS
STATE SO YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU FIND A COMMON PLACE --
WHERE WE HAVE UP LEVELS LEVELS
OF OF -- OF
PREPAREDNESS AND WHEN I SAY ALL
HOUSE WITH THAT MEANS THAT IT'S
NOT JUST WALL VIRUS EARTHQUAKE
FIRE FLOOD AND AND AND OTHER
KINDS OF THREATS --
WE'VE GOT.
IN.
ONE SENSE OF THE WORD LA COUNTY
THE LARGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE
WITH.
WHAT IS EIGHTY MILLION PEOPLE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND ALPINE
COUNTY THE SMALLEST COUNTY IN
THE STATE WITH JUST A FEW
HUNDRED PEOPLE RIGHT?
OUR ROLE IS TO TRY TO BALANCE
OFF THE CAPABILITY THE ABILITY
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES TO BUILD
SOME LEVEL OF CAPACITY WE'VE GOT
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
A FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES FIFTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT CULTURES FIFTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT WAYS OF LOOKING
AT BUSINESS RIGHT.
SO -- WE NO
AND IT COMES IN DIFFERENT FORMS
IT'S NOT JUST THE GOVERNMENT
SOLUTIONS HAS TO BE A WHOLE OF
COMMUNITY APPROACH SO IT'S THE
IT'S THE PUBLIC.
BATH TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
I SAID THERE'S SOMETHING I CALL
THE NINE ONE ONE SYNDROME PEOPLE
USED TO DIAL 911- AND GET
EVERYTHING COMING THEY DON'T
REALLY.
SOME MIGHT THING TO WORRY ABOUT
I JUST DAHLE I'M A ONE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT COMES BUT IN DISASTER.
AS WE SEEN.
WHEN YOU DIAL 911- YOU MAY NOT
GET THOSE FIREFIGHTERS RIGHT
AWAY?
THEY MAY NOT COME FOR A FEW
HOURS OR MAYBE A DAY BECAUSE
WE'RE IN A STATEWIDE RED FLY
CONDITION AND WE'VE GOT.
A MAJOR CATASTROPHE IN THE NORTH
PULLING RESOURCES IN A MAJOR
CATASTROPHE THE SOUTH FULLY
RESOURCES.
MUCH MOST OF THE STATION SEVEN
BROWNED OUT.
AND AND THERE'S JUST A WERE
RESOURCES IMMEDIATELY.
SO PART OF PREPAREDNESS.
HIS FIRST IN WORKING TO GET
INDIVIDUALS ENGAGED IN BUILDING
EMPOWERING THEMSELVES AND
BUILDING A CAPABILITY THE SECOND
THING IS THEN WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
TO TO UNDERSTAND THAT EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT IT IT'S IT'S A
COMPLEX BUSINESS AND IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT.
RESPONDING AT PUTTING THE WET
STUFF ON THE REST OF IT IS.
IT IS IS PRE EVENT MITIGATION.
THE ABILITY TO PREPARE THE
COMMUNITY AND HARDEN IT. TO DO
GOOD ANALYSIS OF OF THE THREATS
THAT THEY FACE FIRST WHAT THE
RECOGNIZED THE THREATS.
AND THEN AND THEN PUT MITIGATION
EFFORTS IN AND THAT MEANS
LEVERAGING EVERY MEDICATION
DOLLARS THAT MEANS OUR LOCAL.
ELECTED BODIES NEED TO
PRIORITIZE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AND MEDICATION AS A AS A P. A
FACTOR AND IT ALSO GOES DOWN
INTO OUR LOCAL PLANNING
COMMISSIONS WHICH WHICH AS THEY
BUILD OUT COMMUNITIES.
THEY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT WHAT
IF IS THAT COMMUNITY RESILIENT
ENOUGH TO A DISASTER OKAY AND
THEN FROM THAT.
BUILDING IN ENOUGH CAPACITY OF
AFTER YEARS OF OF DOWNTURN IN
ECONOMICS EXCEPT FOR A WHILE WE
STILL HAVE FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ENTITIES.
THAT HAVE NOT COME UP TO FULL
SPEED YET AND HAVE RESOURCE
ISSUES RIGHT --
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THERE WE HAVE
EMERGENCY MANAGERS IT'S ALL OVER
THE MAP IN CALIFORNIA SUMMER
LOCATED BURIED IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES
SUMMER IN THE CEO'S OFFICE IT'S
IT RUNS THE GAMUT --
AND SO WE NEED TO RAISE THE
STATURE OF THAT ROLE SO THAT
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL --
CAN ACTUALLY HELP THE COMMUNITY
RECOGNIZED THE THREATS BEYOND
THE TRADITIONAL FIRE IN AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
CAN I JUMP IN JAIL JUST TO HELP
SORRY I THOUGHT IT WAS A
COMPLICATED ANSWER IT.
WAS SO THE DEPARTMENT DEFENSE
DEFINES ME READING IS FOR
THEMSELVES THE ABILITY IT
DEPENDING ON THE ADMINISTRATION.
THE SORT OF TWO AND A HALF FOR
ONE AND A HALF STRATEGY TO MAJOR --
WARS AT THE SAME TIME AS WELL AS
THREE SMALL ARMED CONFLICTS IS
SORT OF THE STANDARD WORKING
DEFINITION OF RATING IS TO
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE DO YOU GET TO
THAT SORT OF QUANTITATIVE.
THINKING I I I GET THE SORT OF
THE THE HOLISTIC THINKING BUT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT IS IF
THERE'S SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN A
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY I HAVE THREE
MAJOR --
MAJOR FIRE DISASTERSAT THE SAME
TIME -- YOU
KNOW WITH YOU ANALYZE THOSE
COUNTIES RESOURCES LIKE TO DO WE
HAVE THE I MEAN THE USER DEFINED
IN LIKE IF WE HAVE FOUR TO TIME
AND TWO SMALL ARE WE READY WITH
AN EARTHQUAKE ON TOP LIKE HOW
HOW DO YOU SORT OF DO THAT
SIMPLE.
SNOT SIMPLE MATH SO THAT'S
THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN I
WHEN I THOUGHT YOU'RE ASKING
YEAH OVERALL BUT YEAH YEAH SO
YOUR TALK ABOUT READING THIS AND
WHAT WE OF THE STATE THE STATE
YEAH AND AND IN A COMBINED WHEN
I GO TO THERE'S A LOCAL RULE BUT
SORT.
OF DOING THE OVERALL MATH HERE
ON WHAT.
WE DO DO WE DO HAVE A VERY
SIMILAR --
CONSTRUCT WHERE WE CAN WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO MANAGE AT
LEAST TO WHAT WE CALL LEVEL --
ONE THOSE ARE CATASTROPHIC
EVENTS SIMULTANEOUSLY IN THE
STATE AND ALL AND THEN A LEVEL --
TO AND SO YOU HAVE GOT TO LEVEL
ONE LEVEL TWO AND LEVEL TWO IS
JUST YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY. FOR THE CUTS A BAD
DAY BUT IT'S IT'S NOT
CATASTROPHIC AND AND THAT IS.
IT WHEN I SEE THAT IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE ALL
HANDS ON TRAINING TO TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN EFFECTIVELY.
DO THAT THE THAT THAT'S THE
GENERAL --
CONDO.
WE'RE WOLSEY IN CAMP BOTH LEVEL
ONES YES SO DURING THAT THAT
INCIDENT WHO WHO AND WE AND
EIGHT ON THE HEELS OF CAR AND
MODESTY THOUGH --
SORT OF LEADING IN BEING
STRETCHED THIN WE WEREN'T PRE
POSITIONED IN WILL SEE RIGHT
BACK THERE WAS NO PRE
POSITIONING WE WEREN'T ON THE
SEASONAL ROTATION MINUSES THAT
THAT SHIFTED NOW IN TERMS OF
POLICY THAT'S SORT OF WHAT
CENTER MCGUIRE WAS GETTING AT
TERMS OF REFORMS TO THE PRE.
POSITIONING PLAN WHICH I
APPRECIATE --
BUT WHEN YOU KNOW WE HAD BIG
TOWN HALL JUST LAST WEEKEND WITH
LA COUNTY FIRE WITH ABOUT A
THOUSAND VERY UPSET RESIDENCE
WHEN THEY SAY YOU KNOW WE ASK
FOR SEVENTY TRUCKS.
YOUR YOUR HUNKER DOWN IT CAN'T.
VENTURA COUNTY IS UP IT HILL.
DO IN THEIR THING AND THE
RESPONSE BACK WAS WITH IT.
WE DON'T HAVE IT.
AND SO.
THEY WERE SEVENTY ENGINES AND
THEY THEY DIDN'T GET THERE AND
THEN YOU KNOW THINGS HAPPEN --
AND SO I JUST SORT OF GET BOTH
THE GRANULAR NEAR TERM THIS YEAR
BUDGETARY STRATEGY IN TERMS OF
HOW TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE READY
REALLY GETTING DOWN TO BRASS
TACKS ON WHAT THAT QUANTIFIED.
WHAT THAT MEANS --
AND THEN I I WON THE LA WAS
COMMENTARY ON THIS MULTI YEAR --
QUESTION CENTER MONEY I THINK
YOU BROUGHT IT UP NICELY WHICH
IS -- WHAT
WOULD YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH SO WE GOT ALMOST A
BILLION DOLLAR TAB IF THE FEDS
ARE GENEROUS ENOUGH TO KEEP HELP
IN FOR THAT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
COSTS BUT?
YOU KNOW YOU GO BACK IN TIME.
AND IT JUST IT IT KEEPS RAMPING
BUT YOU KNOW WE SORT OF DO THE
E. FINDER WE DO THE SFE WE SORT
OF QUICK INFUSIONS OF CAPITAL
BUT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR LIABILITIES
THAT CAN KIND OF POP OUT OF NO
WHERE SO JUST FROM A SCHOOL
READINESS I GUESS --
FISCAL PREPAREDNESS HOW HOW DO
WE SHOULD APPROACH A MULTI YOUR
STRATEGY INTELLIGENTLY SO THAT
WE'RE NOT.
CAUGHT FLAT FOOTED IN THAT FOR
ALL THESE OTHER CRUCIAL
PRIORITIES WE'VE GOTTEN THE
BUDGET THING CARE PEOPLE'S
HEALTH CARE MAKING SURE KIDS AND
GET TO SCHOOL YOU KNOW LIKE ALL
ALL THE CRUCIAL FUNCTION OF
NORMAL DAILY LIFE.
HOW DO WE NOT SWALLOW UP THOSE
OF HER OTHER PRIORITIES HERE AND
BE A LITTLE MORE SYSTEMATIC
ABOUT THE OVERALL NUMBER I'M
JUST?
MAYBE INGO IN JUMP IN THAT I LA --
I MEAN YOU HAVE A THOUGHT ON
THAT.
ONE TOP PROVIDE SOME INITIAL
COMMENTS IN MY COLLEAGUES AS
COMPUTERS IT'S IT'S HERE ALSO
AND SHE CAN PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTS ON THAT.
HELLFIRE SIDE --
BUT IN TERMS SAID THAT THE
STATE'S BUDGETARY READY DAYS --
WE DO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT RESERVE
FIND WHICH THE LEGISLATURE HAS
I'M TAKING QUITE A BIT OF ACTION
TO REALLY --
REALLY PROVIDE SOME FUNDING
THERE AND BASICALLY WE'VE BEEN
USING THAT TO HELP TO HELP US --
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
UNANTICIPATED COSTS AND IT'S
BEEN VERY VERY VALUABLE --
IT PROBABLY IS WORTH US THINKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE HOW
MUCH THAT SHOULD BE IF IT'S
GOING TO ACTUALLY --
OF COURSE --
SERVICE AS AS BOTH SORT OF A
SELF INSURANCE FOR SOME OF THESE
MAJOR DISASTERS IN HELPING US
THAT WE NEED TO IS CASH FLOW
NEEDS AS WELL AS BUDGETARY
RESILIENCE OF THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS I THINK
WE'LL CONTINUE TO HAVE --
BUT THANKFULLY WE'VE BEEN AND
ALSO WOULD HAVE GOOD BUDGET
SITUATION --
THIS YEAR AND LAST YEAR AND AND
THAT'S BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN IN
ALLOWING US TO MAKE THESE KINDS
OF EXPENDITURE SO I THINK IT'S A
CONTINUING CONVERSATION --
WE DON'T HAVE LIKE A RAINY DAY
FUND IN THE SAME WAY FOR THIS WE
SORT OF SET ASIDE OUT OF OTHER
RESERVES TO GET READY BUT IF THE
BUDGET TAKES A TURN AND WE'RE
NOT LOOKING THAT GOOD IN TO OR
THREE YEARS BUT THE FIRES
ACTUALLY GET WORSE THAN.
WHAT HAPPENED?
EXACTLY RIGHT SO WE DON'T HAVE A
DESIGNATED RESERVE IT'S JUST FOR
DISASTERS INSTEAD WE WERE USING
OUR OUR SIR GENERAL RESERVE FUND --
TO HELP US ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
FISCAL CHALLENGES WE HAVE HAD
DISASTERS --
SO I THINK IT IS WORTH HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT --
HOW HOW WHAT WE WANT THOSE
RESERVE LEVELS TO BE TO INSURE
THAT WE CAN HAVE IT MEET THOSE
NEEDS AS WELL AS OTHER THINGS
AND CERTAINLY?
YOU KNOW WE MAY NOT WANT TO
DRIVE DOWN THAT RESERVE FOLEY --
BECAUSE IN YOUR EVEN WHEN WE
HAVE A AND ECONOMIC KIND OF
STRESS IN OUR IN OUR STATE
BECAUSE WE WANT.
TO YOU TO THINK THAT WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM WE DO WILL PROBABLY WANT
TO HAVE SOME CUSHION THERE --
FOR THE EVENT THAT WE HAVE SOME
MAJOR DISASTER COSTS I'M SO I
THINK THOSE ARE CUT CONVERSATION
THEIR OFFICE WOULD BE VERY
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO HAVE.
A WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND I'M
CERTAINLY VERY.
I'M JUST IN TERMS OF FIRE
ANALYSTS ARE FAVORITE TO LOOK
OVER YOUR SHOULDER ALL AREA.
BUT IT AND SO I AM I WOULD ALSO
KNOW IN TERMS OF THE FINANCIAL-READING IS THAT AND THE BUDGET --
DOES INCLUDE A HIGHER AND NOW
I'VE SORT OF BE SLAIN BUDGETED
AMOUNT FOR THAT YOU FIND --
AND THAT'S JUST A FUNCTION OF
LOOKING AT HOW THAT YOU FIND
COSTS HAVE BEEN GROWING IN
RECENT YEARS AND SO THERE IS
SOME --
PLANNING AHEAD FOR POTENTIALLY
HIGHER --
COSTS ON THE FIRE RESPONSE SIDE
ON IN TERMS OF THE MULTI YEAR WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THIS A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THE NEXT PANEL BUT I
THINK IT GETS TO THE HEART OF
SOME YOUR QUESTION SENATOR STERN
HAVE --
LOOKING OUT WAIT WHAT IS THE
IDEAL LEVEL OF READINESS OR
RESPONSE AND PREPAREDNESS AND
AND SO -- WE
CAN TALK ABOUT IT MORE BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU MAY WANT
TO THINK ABOUT WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THIS WHOLE
PACKAGE OF HOW DO WE RESPOND TO
WILDFIRES AND DISASTERS IS --
EIGHTEEN THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T PUT FORWARD AN ASSESSMENT
RECENTLY OF WHAT THE CAPACITY IS
OF STATE AND LOCAL SYSTEMS
COMBINED ON IF THERE'S ANY GAPS
AND SAID YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
AUGMENTING RESOURCES ADDING FIRE
ENGINES ADDING.
AN AIR RESOURCES I YOU MAY WANT
TO HAVE MORE OF AN ASSESSMENT
LIKE THAT BECAUSE THIS IS VERY
LIKELY NOT GOING TO BE A ONE
YEAR --
THING OF INCREASING RESOURCES
WE'VE DONE IN RECENT YEARS IT'S
VERY LIKELY TO CONTINUE THAT
TREND IN FUTURE YEARS AS WE HAVE
THESE VERY AS SEVERE FIRE
SEASONS AND SO.
I YOU MAY WANT TO THINK MORE
ABOUT IT A MULTI YOUR STRATEGY
WE CAN TALK MORE ABOUT THE NEXT.
OKAY THANKS CAN I JUST SAY ONE
THING PLEASE ARE SO.
KEEP IN MIND THAT OVER THE
COURSE OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S
MYSTERY IT'S IN THE OVER ARCHING
PREPAREDNESS LEVEL RIGHT YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S TECHNOLOGY
WHETHER IT'S MEETING WE HAVE WE
FINALLY MET THE LAST YEAR THE
BLUE RIBBON.
FIRE COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THE NUMBER OF OF WE ASK
ENGINES THAT NEEDED TO BE PUT IN
THE SYSTEM THAT'S A AUGMENTING
FORCE THAT IS BE A ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE EXISTING AND WE ARE
NOW MEETING THAT.
THAT IS THAT THE NEXT STEP IS TO
GO BACK AND RE EVALUATE IS THAT
GIVEN THE CURRENT THREAT WE
CONSTANTLY HAVE TO BE LOOKING AT
THE NEXT STEP.
BUT I THINK THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY --
BETTERTO HELP BY DOWN THE RISK --
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE'LL TAKE IT
TAKE A PAGE OUT A HOMELAND
SECURITY --
YOU CAN YOU CAN SPEND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON ON
RESOURCES AND ARE STILL GOING TO
BE A SECURITY THREAT SO.
IT'S ALL IN HOW YOU BEST UTILIZE
THAT TO TO MOVE US FORWARD I
THINK THERE'S SOME DIFFERENT
AREAS WE CAN AND I AND I LOVE
THAT FRAME BECAUSE IT.
I TO GETTING THAT MATH TIGHT FOR
US ON BUDGET COMMITTEE SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND OKAY WE'RE
MAKING A BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT BUT ACTUALLY GET ME
JUST LIKE WE DO ON FIND OUT
PENSION LIABILITIES ARE DEBTS
RIGHT YOU'RE ACTUALLY.
YOU'RE SPENDING MONEY TO SAVE
MONEY RIGHT THIS WORKS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE IT HAPPENS AND
HEALTHCARE SORT OF LOOKING AT
THOSE ARE LONG TERM OUTCOME FOR
RIGHT NOW IT FEELS.
A LITTLE BIT LIKE.
BUT WE'RE NOT QUANTIFYING THE
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING EVEN LIKE
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO CAPTURE THOSE
METRICS ACCURATELY IN A WAY I
KNOW IT'S A ROUGH SCIENCE HERE
WE'RE NEVER GONNA GET TO A POINT
WHERE LIKE PERFECTLY QUANTIFIED
OF EXACTLY WHAT IS.
RATING IS MEAN OR EXACTLY HOW
MUCH RISK AND WE BOUGHT DOWN AND
WILDFIRES ARE INHERENTLY CHAOTIC
THAT'S WHAT NATURAL DISASTERS
ARE RIGHT THERE UNPREDICTABLE
AND SOMEWHAT ACTS OF GOD OR THE
WERE CONTRIBUTING TO IT NOW
GIVEN OUR FOSSIL FUEL PATTERNS
BUT YEAH.
LET'S LET'S START TIGHTER SO
WHEN.
HOW MUCH RISK ARE WE BUYING DOWN
RIGHT WHAT COST SAVINGS ARE WE
GENERATING FOR THE STATE WITH?
EITHER HOME HARDENING A SMARTER
INSURANCE POSTURE GETTING MORE
LOCAL COORDINATION SOME OF THESE
SUBPOENAS TO ADVANCE SUPPRESSION
EFFORTS PRESCRIBED BURNS RIGHT
CERTAIN THAT THEY ALL SORT OF
FEED TO A CENTRAL MATH THAT
HELPS US.
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW WELL WE'RE
DOING EVEN THINGS LIKE GREED
GREED MANAGEMENT --
SETTING ASIDE THE SORT OF
RESTRUCTURING QUESTION PENDING
UP UP NORTH OF PGA ANY YOU KNOW.
IF IF THESE COMMUNITIES WERE
MORE SELF POWERED AND WE
ACTUALLY COULD SHUT OFF POWER
WITHOUT THE LIGHTS GOING OFF ON
THE CENTRAL GREED ON THOSE HIGH
FIRE DAYS ANDYOU HAD.
FIRE STATIONS AND HOSPITALS IN
AND CRITICAL RESOURCE EVEN
CRITICALLY POSITION COMMUNITIES
ABLE TO SUSTAIN WITHOUT GRID
BASED POWER AND HAVE SOLAR AND
BATTERY IN MY CREW GREAT SYSTEMS
LIKE OKAY THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
BUT HOW MUCH RISK ARE YOU SAVING
THEN ON THE BACK AND FROM ALL
THE OTHER BILLIONS WE SPENT.
AND SORT OF TRYING TO BUILD THAT
SYSTEM ANYWAY I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT AND REALLY APPRECIATE
ALEJO'S HELP GOING FORWARD.
TO AND THANK YOU FOR THAT YET
GIVE ME A MOMENT TO GET INTO WE
CAN TALK ON THE NEXT PANEL AND
THEN.
FINALLY ON ON MISTER SMITH LINES --
SIDE -- JUST
WANT TO BRIEFLY THANK YOU AND
YES WE CAN THE IMPORTANT OPTING
IN RIGHT OF ENTRY AND REALLY
GETTING THAT DONE --
IN THESE COMMUTING GETTING THE
WORD OUT THAT IT'S A COST SAVER
FOR THE HOMEOWNER --
YOU KNOW YOU CAN COME IN AND DO
THAT INSPECTION AND IT IS TRUE
THAT YOU CAN ALSO CHANGE YOUR
MIND AT THAT AFTER THAT SO IF
YOU DECIDE THAT YOUR INSURANCE
KICKS IN.
AND YOU'RE READY TO YOU KNOW GO
TO YOUR YOUR PRIVATE PLANNING
SURE TO WANT.
TO RETAILER NON COUNTY OR NON
STATE SOLUTION YOU CAN DO THAT
RIGHT YOU CAN OPT IN. TO THE R.
O. E. AND THEN YOU CAN CHANGE
YOUR MIND LATER.
WOULD YOU SAY THE MOST BILL
SHOULD JUST BE OPTING IN RIGHT
NOW AND JUST GET IN THE SYSTEM
AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
EFFICIENCIES WE GAIN BY THE
MAJORITY OR EVERYBODY OPTING IN --
JUST ACROSS THE ENTIRE PROCESS --
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TENS OR EVEN SOMETIMES HUNDREDS
OF CREWS WORKING IN THE
COMMUNITY SO WE'RE WORKING WITH
A HOPSCOTCH OF PROPERTY SOME
THAT ARE IN AND OTHERS THAT
AREN'T IT IMPACTS OUR EFFICIENCY
JUST FRANKLY.
MUCH ABOUT THERE'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO TO LEAVE A LEAVE A
COMMUNITY WITH ROPERTIES THAT
ARE CLEANED UP I MEAN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT PILES OF ACTION YOU
KNOW THERE'S THAT MATERIALS NOT
SAFE.
RIGHT IN WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
LEAVE THOSE COMMUNITIES CLEAN
AND SAFE READY TO REBUILD --
SO FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS THAT
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO AND WE WORK
WITH --
YESTERDAY AND THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMMUNICATE THAT
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEASURE.
I'M GOING TO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
AND EACH SECTION I'M GONNA TRY
TO TAILOR MY QUESTIONS INTO THE
PURPOSE OF THIS.
SECTION.
DOES THE FIRST A COUPLE OF
OBSERVATIONS.
SOMETIMES WE GET PRETTY
DISGUSTED ABOUT SOCIETY. ONE OF
THE VERY INTERESTING THINGS TO
ME AND I LOOK AT YOUR MAP THERE
THE OUT OF STATE RESOURCES.
DURING THE FIRE PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT WAS RAGING.
BEING UP THERE ON SITE. ONE OF
THE THINGS IT WAS INSTRUCTIVE TO
ME THE AMOUNT OF COMMENTS FROM
OUT OF STATE RESPONDERS WHO SAID
THAT THEY'VE BEEN RESPONDING ALL
OVER AMERICA KATRINA YOU NAME IT.
TO EMERGENCIES THEY SAID WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN THE OUTPOURING OF
SUPPORT. FOR A COMMUNITY THAT
WE'RE SEEING HERE.
AND THAT WAS MANIFESTED IN MANY
WAYS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT GIVES US A
LITTLE BIT OF HOPE.
ANOTHER OBSERVATION WHICH WILL
APPLY TO OTHER SECTIONS OF THIS
AS WELL AND THAT IS MANAGING THE
FORCE IN THE WILD PLANTS.
POST FIRE.
AS ONE UP THERE THE FIRST THING
THAT REALLY STRUCK ME.
WAS A LARGE TREES.
SCORCHED BUT THE LORD BARK.
MAYBE TWELVE FEET UP MAYBE LESS.
BUT THE CANOPIES LARGELY
UNTOUCHED. NINE FORESTER BY THE
HAD TO BE A PRODUCT OF PARTLY
THE AMOUNT OF ACCUMULATED FUEL.
AVAILABLE TO THE FIRE
[inaudible]
THE WINDS.
AND THEN THE CANYONS.
THE CHANNEL THOSE.
THAT WAS THE ONLY GOOD THING
THAT I SAW OF THAT.
IS THE CHARACTER OF THAT RICH
AND IT'S NOT JUST PARADISE THE
CITY YOU'VE GOT AT THE RICH IS
FOR I REFER.
TO WHAT HAS BEEN SUCH A VALUE TO
THEM A STATICALLY WORE THOSE
GREAT TREES.
AND I'M HOPEFUL BASED ON WHAT
I'VE SEEN LITTLE LOT OF THOSE
TALLER TREES.
THAT WERE SCORCHED.
BUT WON'T BE WE CAN SUCH A DEAL
DIE.
WITH THE CANOPIES INTACT AND
STILL YET HEALTHY AFTER ALL
THESE WEEKS IN ANOTHER LITERALLY
EVERY WEEK --
THERE'S SOME HOPE THAT THE
CHARACTER THAT COMMUNITY.
CAN TO THEM TO SOME DEGREE
RETURN.
OF MISTER SMITH.
ONE HOW ARE YOU FEELING YOU WERE
PROGRESSING.
WITH.
THE CLEANUP UP THERE NOW AND I
KNOW WE HAVE ONE HERE ISSUE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH DIRECTOR
GIL OUR DUTY ON ASSEMBLY CAN
GALLAGHER NOT ACT COMMUNICATING
TO THE CITIZENS OF THE NEED FOR
THE RIGHT TO RETREAT --
AND WE'VE GOT A WAYS TO GO THANK
YOU FOR EXTENDING THE TIME FOR
RESPONSE.
BUT HOW DO YOU FEEL IT IN AND
WHAT WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
STATUS RIGHT NOW OF THE CLEAN UP.
ROUGHLY ON SCHEDULE --
I WOULD SAY YES ROUGHLY ON
SCHEDULE I MEAN I I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT THEY ARE A WE
NUMBER.
IS POTENTIALLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY A LITTLE BIT
LOWER.
DURING THIS POINT IN THE CLEANUP
THAN WE'VE SEEN BUT GENERALLY
ONCE WE START --
A PRESENCE IN THE COMMUNITY
WHICH WE'RE DOING NOW.
WE GENERALLY SEE A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT UPTICK IN THE NUMBER
OF ARE WE USE THAT THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE'VE SEEN --
SO.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE ALARMED AT
THE NUMBER I THINK IT'S VERY SAY
MIGHT BE A LITTLE LOWER
DISPROPORTIONATELY NUMBER WE
SEEN BUT WE EXPECT TO SEE AN
UPTCK NOW THAT ACTIVITIES
BEGINNING --
SO -- I
DON'T WANT TO SERVE IT WELL WE
GET IT DOES AND WE'RE GOING TO
COULD.
I WAS GOING TO SAY TO THEM
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
THE FIRST.
MONTH AND A HALF OR SO.
REALLY WAS TO GETTING ALL THAT
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE OFF WE
ARE NOW COLLECTIVELY COMPLETE
FOR AN ALTERED TO PURPOSES AND
THAT THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
SEVERAL. THIRTY FORTY THOUSAND
PROPERTIES THE GOING TO DO THAT
SO THERE WAS A WHOLE BIG EFFORT.
BUT TO THE POINT OF OF DIRECTORS
MISALIGNED SAM.
COMICS THOSE ARE EASY YOU KNOW
SENATOR ARE ARE REALLY.
ARE REALLY THAT CASE HE'LL AND
AND OUR ABILITY TO GET IN AND DO
THAT AND AND YOURS AND SOME
MEMBER GALLAGHER IS WORKING THIS
HAS BEEN.
SO INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING TO
GET THAT MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY IF WE DON'T
GET IF THOSE DON'T GET CLEANED
UP IN THE COUNTY AS YOU KNOW HAS
TO DO AN ABATEMENT AND THEN --
PUBLIC ALL COMES BACK DOES AND
IN THE END ANYWAY SO IT'S NOT A
VERY EFFICIENT WAY OF DOING IT
IT IS IT CERTAINLY IS A
CHALLENGE AND I WANTED NEVER
LOSE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
WHOEVER MAY BE WATCHING OUT
THERE PLEASE.
SIGN UP.
A THINK YOU'RE HELPING YOUR
NEIGHBORS AS WELL QUESTION
RELATED TO THE A CONSIDERATION
FOR PRE POSITIONING.
IS PART OF THE CONSIDERATION
RELATED TO GEOGRAPHY NOW THE
REASON I MAKE THIS POINT.
THAT RIDGE IS VERY UNIQUE
[inaudible]
CANYONS.
THE VERY CONDUCIVE TO THE WINDS
AND THE EXPLOSION FIRE NOT.
RIP REPETITIVE THE SPREADING OF
THE FIRE IS THE GEOGRAPHY
SOMETIMES A CONSIDERATION OR IT
CAN BE A CONSIDERATION IN OUR
PERFECT PRE POSITIONING.
THE TREASURY'S YES IT IS AND AND
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE FOR
EXAMPLE --
AN THE LOS ANGELES AREA WE SEE
THE SANTA ANA WINDS IN SANTA
BARBARA WE SEE THE SUNDOWNERS
THAT THE TOPOGRAPHY --
FRAMES HOW THAT WIND EVENT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN --
IN THE NORTH WE HAVE THE
NORTHERNERS AND AND AND THE
NORTH WINDS.
AND AND SO --
THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES IT IS
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT WITH REGARDS --
TO WHAT ARE THE UNIQUE --
RED FLAG IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA.
OKAY.
OF MANAGER THAT'S ENOUGH FOR NOW
BEEN BE EXCEEDS ALL THESE
QUESTIONS IN THE OTHER SECTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SENATOR NIELSEN AND THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO TRANSITION OVER
TO OUR SECOND PANEL.
THERE.
WERE WILL FOCUS ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE.
WE'LL BE JOINED AT THE TABLE BY
MATT L. ME.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JESSICA PETERS AGAIN WITH THE LA
JOH.
TOM PORTER DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION CAL FIRE WILL BE
JOINING AND WILL MAKE HIMSELF
AVAILABLE.
ONLY IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS THAT SHOULD BE
DIRECTED TO HIM.
WE'LL GET STARTED.
WITH MATH.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR -- IN
MEMBERS ATT ALL ME DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE --
BUILDING ON SENATOR MUNNINGS --
COMMENTS FROM EARLIER.
CLIMATE CHANGE CONTINUES TO
LENGTHEN FIRE SEASON IN
CALIFORNIA.
OF FOUR CONSECUTIVE YEARS OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES HAVE
SURPASSED ALL PREVIOUS RECORDS.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALENDAR
YEAR BROUGHT THE LARGEST
DEADLIEST AND MOST DAMAGING
FIRES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
DESPITE ADDITIONAL PRECIPITATION
OVER THE PAST EVERAL YEARS
VEGETATION REMAINS CRITICALLY
DRY.
AND WEATHER EVENTS ARE MORE
EXTREME.
THE CENTRALAND SOUTHERN SIERRA
CONTINUE TO BE AFFECTED BY TREE
MORTALITY WHICH HAS RESULTED IN
OVER A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION.
TREES AND CREATED MORE VOLATILE
AND FLAMMABLE FLAMMABLE
VEGETATION [inaudible]
ACCORDINGLY.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS. TO
INCREASE FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AND
ENHANCE THE STATE'S FIREFIGHTING
CAPABILITIES.
SO.
THE A LOT FOUR HUNDRED FORTY ONE
MILLION CAN REALLY BE.
CATEGORIZED INTO TWO BUCKETS.
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR INCREASING FIRE
PREVENTION.
IN TWO HUNDRED AND SIX MILLION
FOR WHILE FIRE RESPONSE.
THE SPECIFICALLY THE BUDGET
PROPOSES A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO INCREASE
FIRE PREVENTION AND FOR SELF
ACTIVITIES.
AND IMPLEMENT THE RECENTLY
ENACTED WELL FIRE PREVENTION AND
RECOVERY LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE.
THIS INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS FOR CAL FIRE TO COMPLETE
MORE FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS. TO
THE OPERATION OF PRESCRIBED FIRE
CREWS IN GRANTS FOR FORCED OFF
PROJECTS THE WILL SUPPORT
COMMUNITY LEVEL FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES.
AS WELL AS THREE FIVE MILLION
FOR MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR CAL FIRE.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS.
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD THE PUBLIC
YOU TO IN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
IN THE STATE WATER BOARD.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET PROPOSES
TWO HUNDRED SIX MILLION FOR CAL
FIRE IN THE COURT TO ENHANCE THE
STATE'S FIRE PROTECTION
CAPABILITIES TO ENABLE THE STATE
TO RESPOND TO INCREASED WILDFIRE
RESTS.
THESE RESOURCES INCLUDE. SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
CALIFORNIA CORPS AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE. TO EXPAND
THE STATE'S FIREFIGHTING SEARCH
CAPACITY IN TAKE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING CALPERS
OPERATIONAL NEEDS.
WHICH INCLUDES FUNDING TO ADD
THIRTEEN NEW FIRE ISSUES BEING
THIRTEEN NEW YEAR ROUND FIRE
ENGINES WILL BE LOCATED IN AREAS
OF THE STATE WITH THE HIGHEST
FIRE RISK.
THESE ENGINES WILL ENHANCE CAL
FIRES EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES AND WILL MITIGATE
THE POTENTIAL FOR CATASTROPHIC
WHILE THE VENTS IN AT RISK
COMMUNITIES.
WHEN NOT ENGAGED IN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE THESE ENGINES WILL
SERVE TO SUPPORT PRESCRIBED FIRE
AND OTHER HAZARDOUS FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS?
TOOL FURTHER REDUCE THE THREAT
OF WILDFIRES IN FIRE THREATEN
COMMUNITIES.
THIS INCLUDES ALSO INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR THE OPERATION OF
FIVE ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS FIRE CREWS --
WHICH ARE STAFFED BY CORE
MEMBERS INNER COST EFFECTIVE
HlNH CREWS CAPABLE OF REACHING.
A CAPABLE OF REACHING REMOTE AND
RUGGED TERRAIN.
NOT ACCESSIBLE BY OTHER FIRE
SUPPRESSION RESOURCES.
FUNDING TO EXPAND HEAVY FIRE
EQUIPMENT OPERATOR STAFFING TO
SUPPORT CAL FIRES BULLDOZER
OPERATIONS DURING EMERGENCY
WILDFIRE VINCE.
AS WELL AS XLR THE REPLACEMENT
OF FIRE ENGINES AND OTHER MOBILE
EQUIPMENT.
WE WOULD FURTHER NOTE THAT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED FIFTH TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO ENHANCE CALIFORNIA'S
AVIATION RESOURCES.
WHICH INCLUDES THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE FIRST PHASE OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SEVEN C.
ONE THIRTY LARGER TANKERS TO
WILL BE TRANSFERRED TO CAL FIRE.
PURSUANT TO FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
THESE AIRCRAFT WILL HAVE
INCREASED TACTICAL CAPABILITIES
SO SUPPORT CAL FIRES AVIATION
FLEET IN MEETING THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH SEVERE WILDFIRE
ACTIVITY.
AS WELL AS A HUNDRED AND NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE THE
REPLACEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
VIETNAM ERA HELICOPTERS WITH NEW
STATE OF THE ART.
HELICOPTERS.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER --
THE BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES A SIX
POINT SIX MILLION TO EXPAND CAL
FIRES HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PROGRAM.
NOT NECESSARILY FOR STUDY BUT TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES AS WELL
AS PEER SUPPORT --
TO FIREFIGHTERS TO MAINTAIN THE
LONG TERM HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF OUR EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
FINALLY THE BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES
NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO IMPROVE THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY AND SUPPORT CAL FIRE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
CAPABILITIES --
DIRECTOR GALA TO CHEAT ALLUDED
TO THOSE SO I WILL STOP THERE
AND HAPPY ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WILL HOLD ON QUESTIONS
AGAIN ALCOHOLICS TO THE AND
LET'S GO AHEAD.
AND HERE FROM THE ALLEY OUT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE -- IF
WE COULD RETURN TO THE HAND OUT
THAT WE HAD ON THE FIRST PANEL
ON PAGE SEVEN WE HAVE A SUMMARY
OF THE GOVERNOR'S A WILD FIRE
RELATED BUDGET PROPOSALS --
AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE AND THE
TABLE ON PAGE SEVEN WE'VE WE
PACKAGE THESE THINGS TOGETHER A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY.
THAN THAN WHAT MR ALL ME
DESCRIBE AND AT THE SAME AND THE
SAME COMPONENTS THE NUMBERS ARE
NUMBERS ARE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
WE'VE INCLUDED IN HERE THE LOCAL
AND RECOVERY ASSISTANCE IT'S
INCLUDED --
SOME OF WHICH ARE CURRENT YOUR
ACTIONS ON THAT THE GOVERNOR IS --
ASKING FOR TO WAIVE THE LOCAL
SHARE OF DEBRIS REMOVAL COSTS
FOR PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO SOME --
FEDERAL DISASTER RECOVERY GRANT
FUNDS AND SO WE'VE INCLUDED THAT
IN.
AND AS MR ARMEY NOTED A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
SPENDING TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IS.
TO IMPLEMENT THE A PACKAGE OF
BILLS THAT WERE PASSED IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND AND REALLY A
LOT OF THE NEW PIECES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET BEYOND
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY
INDICATED IS HOPING FOR FALLEN
THIS ENHANCED FIRE PROTECTION --
AND THESE ARE THE THE CAL FIRE
RESOURCES THAT MR ARMEY DISCUSS
THAT THE THIRTEEN YEAR ROUND
FIRE ENGINES THE FIRST PHASE OF
THAT IS THE ONE THIRTY AIRCRAFT.
AND THAT THE NUMBERS THAT MISTER
ARMEY PRESENTED OR A LITTLE
HIGHER FOR THE ENHANCE FIRE
PROTECTION I THINK THE
MINISTRATION IS ALSO --
POINTING OUT THE HUNDRED AND
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HELICOPTERS THAT'S NOT A BUDGET
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU THIS YEAR
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
APPROVED IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
AND IT'S A MULTI YEAR PLAN --
BUT THAT IS ONE THING TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT THERE IS ADDITIONAL
COSTS I RELATED TO THE CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION ON THE
HELICOPTERS.
I'M AND THEN THERE'S JUST A FEW
TIMES SMALLER PROPOSALS RELATED
TO THE MANAGEMENT OF STATE LANDS --
AND SO WE JUST WANTED TO PRESENT
THAT IS A DIFFERENT WAY OF SORT
OF THINKING ABOUT.
WHAT ALL THE PROPOSALS ARE?
I'M WE'RE OBVIOUSLY STILL IN THE
VERY PRELIMINARY STAGES OF
REVIEWING THESE BETTER PROPOSALS
ON AND WE WILL HAVE A MORE
DETAILED --
COMMENTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
YOU AS WE GET INTO THE SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS AND THAT FOR
TODAY WE WANT TO JUST MAKE SOME
INITIAL ANSWER OF HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS ON HOW YOU MIGHT WANT.
TO START THINKING ABOUT OVERALL
AND WILD FIRES FINDING AND THEN
HOW TO BALANCE PRIORITIES.
AND SO FIRST I YOU'RE GONNA WANT
TO THINK ABOUT.
FIRE RESPONSE AND FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE PREVENTION I IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
THAT WE'RE FINDING IN THE BUDGET
AND THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE WAS
VERY FOCUSED ON FOREST HEALTH.
AND FIRE PREVENTION.
WHERE THE GOVERNOR'S COMING IN
AND MAKING A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
AND THAT?
HAS BEEN THE REQUESTS ARE TEND
TO BE ON THE FIRE SUPPRESSION
AND FIRE RESPONSE SIDE BOTH OF
THESE THINGS ARE NEEDED.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO CONSIDER
IS THE X. TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU'RE ADDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BEYOND WAY THE LEGISLATURE
ALREADY INDICATED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE LAST YEAR.
DO YOU WANT TO BALANCE BETWEEN
MORE FOREST HEALTH OR MORE AT
FIRE SUPPRESSION RESOURCES AND
SO THAT'S SOMETHING TO CONSIDER.
WHEN YOU'R LOOKING AT THE FIRE
SUPPRESSION RESOURCES AND WE
TOUCHED ON THIS A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
NOT PUT FORWARD IT RECENTLY A
VERY COMPREHENSIVE PLAN LOOKING
AT STATE VERSUS?
LOCAL AND CAPACITY AND GAPS
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THIS
INFORMATION IS AND NOT BEING
CONSIDERED AND IT'S IT'S NOT A
CRITICISM OF THE WORK THAT THE
L. YES AND HOW FIRES DOING
CURRENTLY.
BUT IF YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
ADDING THESE BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF THEM IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND NUMBER OF THEM IN THE
PRIOR YEAR.
I'M LOOKING AT ADICIONAL FIRE
ENGINES LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL
STAFF SEEN HELICOPTERS AIRCRAFT
AND AND THEN HOW YOU FACTOR IN
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM --
THE PRE POSITIONING RESOURCES AT
WEAR THAT.
AND THAT CAPACITY IS IN THE GAPS
ARE IS SOMETHING THAT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO THINK ABOUT IT COULD AND
FORMER OF A MULTI YEAR STRATEGY
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THESE VERY SEVERE FIRE
SEASONS --
AND MORE AND MORE RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED --
ADDITIONAL YOU KNOW FIRE ENGINES
POTENTIALLY IN FUTURE YEARS
WHERE YOU LOCATE THOSE --
RIGHT NOW FOR CALIFORNIA --
SORT OF CONSTRAINED AS BEST
WHERE THEY PUT YOU FIRE ENGINES
BASED ON WHERE THEY HAVE A
STATION THAT CAN ACCEPT A NEW
ENGINE.
DO WE NEED TO BE THINKING LONGER
TERM ABOUT CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS TO THE NEED TO BE
BUILDING NEW STATIONS JUST
HAVING A BROADER ASSESSMENT
COULD HELP AND FORMER OF A MULTI
YEAR STRATEGY.
SO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHERE
WHERE WE TRYING TO GET TO IN
TERMS OF READINESS --
AND ALSO WHAT THOSE COSTS ARE
GOING TO BE OVER THE LONG TERM
AND AND IS THE LEVEL THAT WERE
YOU WERE TAKING ON IN THIS YEAR
THE LEVEL THAT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH --
KNOWING WHERE IT MIGHT GO IN THE
FUTURE --
AND I WILL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT
AND ACTUALLY WANT ONE MORE THING
I YOU'VE YOU'VE ALREADY AND
PROBABLY A HER A NOTED THIS IN A
PREVIOUS REPORT THAT WE'VE COME
OUT WITH AND BUT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE PROPERTY TAX BACK
FILLS THERE'S JUST POLICY
CHOICES FOR YOU. TO CONSIDER
YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO THINK ABOUT.
THE NATURE OF HOW YOU DO IT IS
THAT I'M YOU KNOW ONE TIME IS
THAT MULTIPLE YEARS AND SO
THERE'S JUST POLICY CHOICES WE
JUST WANTED TO REMIND YOU OF
THAT AND SO WITH AYE AYE WILL
END AND THE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
WE OFTEN FOLLOWED BY LUMIGAN
ABSURD TO AYE KOWSKI STERN.
AND WHAT YOU NAY MCGUIRE.
THE TO NIELSEN.
THIS SHOULD BE UP.
AND OBSERVATION [inaudible]
BUT IT'S I GOING FORWARD
OBSERVATION.
APPLICABLE THE THINGS THAT WE DO.
PROTECT THE IN TERMS OF
PREVENTION.
THE FIRE TAX WAS IMPOSED SEVERAL
YEARS AGO.
IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS THEREAFTER
IN MY INQUIRIES IN THE BUDGET.
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ABOUT HOW THOSE MONIES WERE USED.
AND THE PUBLIC WAS PROMISED
SUPPRESSION [inaudible]
WELL.
THAT DIDN'T EXACTLY HAPPEN.
AND IT DID NOT INSPIRE IN ME
CONFIDENCE.
THAT THAT WAS A VERY GOOD
INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE CAL FIRE DIDN'T USED.
FOR THE PURPOSES IT WAS
PRESENTED AND PROMISED.
AND I TAKE IT CANNOT BE MUCH
ARGUED THAT.
IT WASN'T A GRAND SUCCESS BASED
ON WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH THESE
FIRES.
MY POINT TO THAT IS WHATEVER WE
DO PROSPECTIVELY WE NEED TO HAVE
SET UP TRACKING.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEES NEED TO BE VERY TOUGH
IN THEIR SCRUTINY OF HOW
RESOURCES THAT ARE DEPLOYED AS
WE WILL BE IN THIS BUDGET.
NUMBER THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
WHAT HE'S BEING WILLING TO
DEPLOY.
WITH THAT KEEP AN EYE ON AND
MAKE SURE IT IS USED FOR THE
PURPOSES INTENDED AND PROMISED.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S
NECESSARILY BEEN SOLD HERE THUS
FAR.
IT WILL BE THE SAME THING AS WE
GET INTO ANOTHER SECTION HERE
AND THAT'S THE NINE ONE ONE
ISSUE THE GOVERNOR'S CAMANCHE
WITH THE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
SOMEONE NOW THE GENERAL FUND AND
THEN THEY'LL BE SOME.
DECIDING FOR THE NEXT RESOURCES
ARE GOING TO BE.
IN OUR DISCUSSIONS LAST YEAR
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT CAME UP
AT THE VERY END OF THE YEAR.
THERE WAS NOT MUCH CLARITY ABOUT.
WHAT KIND OF SYSTEM ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
THAT WE NEED AN IMPROVEMENT I
DON'T THINK IS IN QUESTION.
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS BLOWN SO MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ON TECHNOLOGICAL APPLICATIONS.
THAT DIDN'T WORK.
AND MY SENSITIVITY HERE WHATEVER
WE'RE GOING TO DO ABOUT NINE ONE
ONE AND THEN PROVING THAT
COMMUNICATION AND THAT ALSO DOES
INCLUDE THE COMMUNICATION IN THE
FIELD NOT JUST TO THE NINE ONE
ONE OPERATOR.
WE BETTER MAKE DARN SURE.
THAT WHOEVER WE'RE CONTRACTING
WHETHER WHATEVER PRODUCT WE'RE
CONTRACTING.
FOR WE HAVE THE HIGHEST DEGREE
OF ASSURANCE.
THAT IS GOING TO WORK.
AND WE HAVE SOME BENCHMARKS.
THE PROVIDER HAS GOT TO HEED. TO
ENSURE.
IT DOES THE JOB AND WE JUST KEEP
DOT KEEP THROWING MONEY AT AS I
THINK SO MANY TIMES WE DO HERE
[inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THE SO THE GETTING BACK TO TWO
THE THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
AS WE MOVE AHEAD.
ARE WE GOING TO BE.
PAYING A LOT OF ATTENTION TO
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND NOT JUST
AROUND THE HOMES. FOR THE
PROPERTIES.
BUT THE AREAS. ONE OF THE THINGS
CHANGED IN THE RECENT YEARS
THESE FIRES NOW OR ENCROACHING
ON THE SIX READING SANTA ROSA
FOR EXAMPLE IS THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AHEAD TO
NOW.
OF DO NOT HOW WE HAVE THESE
BUFFER ZONES IF YOU WILL OR WHAT
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT IN TERMS
OF THE PREVENTION AND
ANTICIPATING WHERE THE FIRES ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE THE MOST
LIKELY.
TO DO THE MOST DAMAGE.
I GATHER THAT'S PARTY OF PRE
POSITIONING THE CONSIDERATION IS
NOT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT'S TRUE THAT'S COUPLE OF
OBSERVATIONS AS WE MOVE AHEAD.
I I JUST LIKE TO HAVE THAT.
TO BIG KNOWLEDGE AND AND WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE AS WE GO THROUGH
THE BUDGET COME TO US WITH SOME
FACTS AND SOME INFORMATION.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT WITH
THESE COMMUNICATION PROCEDURES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO EMPLOY AND
DEPLOY? ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS PROACTIVE IN THIS PROBABLY
OF SMALL.
SIGNIFICANCE BUT NOT IN
CONSEQUENCE.
I'M A BIG DOUBLE K. F. C. C. C..
A PARTICULAR NOW WHEN INMATE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE NOT AS RELIABLE.
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS OR IN TERMS
OF THE QUALITY THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE OUT IN THE CAMPS.
AND SO I'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR CCC
DEPLOYMENT AND UP ON THE RIDGE
WE WERE ABLE TO OPEN UP A CCC
CAMP.
NOW I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF
THOSE.
FOLKS WORKED ON THE FIRE LINES
WITH THEY WERE RIGHT WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE THEY WERE PRE
POSITION IF YOU WILL. FOR THOSE
WHO SOME CONSIDERATIONS I THINK
THIS PROSPECTIVELY WOULD BE.
VERY HELPFUL TO US.
JUST SOME OBSERVATIONS BUT THESE
ARE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE A
PART OF OUR CONTINUING DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY.
ON THE EARLY --
MISS PETERS CAM WE JUMPED TO THE
CHART ON PAGE SIX BECAUSE THE
NET GENERAL FUND COSTS IS GOING
TO BE NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
YOUR PRESENTATION WAS THAT
NORMALLY THERE'S A LOCAL SPLIT
WITH THAT. SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE SO THE LOCALS UNDER THE
NORMAL COURSE WOULD BE EXPECTED
TO PAY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS HOWEVER THE
GOVERNOR HAS SUGGESTED THAT.
THAT WE WAIVE A HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS SO THAT
WOULD LEAVE THE LOCALS WITH.
ROUGHLY EIGHTY MILLION BUCKS NOT
COUNTING THE THIRTY ONE THAT
WE'RE GONNA BACK TO ON THE
PROPERTY TAXES THAT'S ANOTHER
THING BUT ARE WE ARE WE
EXPECTING THE LOCAL.
AREAS TO CHIP IN FOR THEIR SEVEN
TO AN EIGHTY MILLION. TO MY
UNDERSTANDING AND AND FINANCE
CAN ALWAYS CLARIFY THIS --
WHEN WE GET TO THE NEXT PANEL OF
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THESE
NUMBERS ACTUALLY REFLECT ALREADY
REFLECT THE STATE COVERING THE
LOCAL CULTURE?
SO THAT THE THE NUMBERS THAT ARE
ON THIS CHART WHICH WE'VE TAKEN
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATES ON ALREADY REFLECT US
COTTON SUPPORT WILL GET TOGETHER.
HEADS UP ON NOW LET'S JUMP TO
THE OUT WILDLIFE.
URBAN INTERFACE AYE AYES ICY IT
THOUGH --
WILDLAND FIRE FIGHTERS YOU KNOW
THE MANAGE FOR FIRES THERE'S
WE'VE READ A LOT SINCE WE WERE
KIDS ABOUT NATURAL OCCURRING
FIRES THE NEED FOR THE SEATS. TO
POP UP URBAN FIREFIGHTERS WITH
THE CHART WITH THE THE MUTUAL
AID THEY'RE DESIGNED TO TAKE OUT.
THOSE THOSE FIRES WHATEVER IT IS
THEY RUSSIAN AND THEY AND THEY
PUT IT OUT HOW DO WE TREAT THESE
WILDFIRES IN THIS WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE AND GIVEN THE NOON OR
ABNORMAL THAT WE HAVE WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING GOING FORWARD ON
THESE -- THE
INTERFACE AREAS NOT THE OUT THE
BACK LAND THE INTERFACE.
HELLO AGAIN --
TOM BORDER CAL FIRE --
DIRECTOR --
AND SENATOR I WANTED.
TO MAKE SURE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT --
WHY I WILDLAND FIRE AND --
INTERFACE BUYER ARE THE SAME
FIRE.
IN IN OUR OUR RESPECTED --
WE WE ARE OUR INTENT IS TO PUT
EVERY FIRE OUT THE STARTS --
THAT WE DON'T WE ARE USING AS A
PRESCRIBED FIRE --
AT TEN ACRES OR LESS AND WE MEET
THAT 95% OF THE TIME AND THAT'S
IN ALL HONESTY RESPONSIBILITY
AREA THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR
SERVICE HAS A SIMILAR --
GOALS AS WELL --
IN.
CALIFORNIA --
IS --
RESPONSE WE WE DO NOT MANAGE
FIRE -- WE
FIGHT FIRE AND WE PUT BY HERSELF
AND AND THAT'S ON ALL LANDS THAT
WERE RESPONSIBLE [inaudible]
FOR SO --
WHEN YOU GET TO THE NATIONAL
FOREST SYSTEM THERE ARE SOME
AREAS OF THE STATE --
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE BACK WOODS
AREAS WHERE NATURAL STARTS --
WILL BE MANAGED --
BUT AGAIN WE ARE NOT PART OF
THAT SYSTEM THAT WOULD BE THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM.
AND WE WATCH THOSE VERY
CAREFULLY BECAUSE OFTEN WHAT
HAPPENS IS THOSE FIRES GROW TO A
POINT WHERE THEY COME OUT OF
THERE PRESCRIPTION.
AND START TO COME INTO THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA SO WE
MONITOR THOSE CLICK CLOSELY --
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE FOR
SERVICES MEETING THER
OBLIGATIONS TO KEEP THEIR FIRES
OFF OF PRIVATE LAND AS WELL.
GIVEN THE EVOLVING SCIENCE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE FREQUENCY
OF SEVERE WEATHER AND FIRES HAS
THAT CHANGED YOUR THINKING OR
THE COMMUNITIES THINKING ABOUT.
FOR PUTTING ON EVERY FIRE IS
THERE ASEFI GOING ON THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME FIRES THAT WE NEED
TO MANAGE BY LETTING THEM BURN
SINCE THAT.
BE A NATURALLY OCCURRING PIC OF
PHENOMENA IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT
THAT IS A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
AGAIN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM AND AND AND CAL
FIRE --
WORKING WITH THE PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS.
IS THAT THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
EVERY SINGLE PRIVATE LANDOWNER
OR A STATE CONSERVANCY OR STATE
LANDOWNER.
IN THE STATE AND EVERYONE OF
THEM HAS A DIFFERENT --
MANAGEMENT REGIME THAT THEY SEE
FOR THEIR PRIVATE LAND --
WE CANNOT --
ENTER INTO --
WHAT WOULD BE IN?
MILLIONS OF DIFFERENT AGREEMENTS --
ON THE NUMBER OF PARCELS THAT
ARE OUT THERE IN THE IN THE WILD
LAND -- IN
ORDER TO HAVE BE ABLE TO HAVE A
FIDELITY OF WHICH WHICH
LANDOWNER WANTS FIRE TO BURN
ACROSS THEIR PRIVATE LAND.
OR NOT.
SO WE HAVE TO ASSUME ALL OF THE
FIRES OUT --
TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY AND
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE THE 95% --
OF ALL FIRES LESS THAN TEN ACRES
AND AND I I DO UNDERSTAND THE
ECOLOGICAL --
PIECE OF WHAT YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING.
TO AND THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE --
ADDRESSED THROUGH ARE PRESCRIBED
FIRE -- AND
FUELS MANAGEMENT GOALS THAT
WE'RE INCREASING --
CURRENTLY ACROSS THE STATE
THERE'S ABOUT --
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
ON STATE AND PRIVATE LANDS THAT
ARE DONE ANNUALLY.
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO DOUBLE THAT
IN IN THROUGH THROUGH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE FORCE
CARBON PLAN.
AND TO MEET THE RESILIENCY GOAL
SO WE WILL BE DOING A LOT MORE
FUELS REDUCTION PROJECT WORK AND
PRESCRIBED BURNING THAT WILL BE
UNDER UNDER OUR TERMS.
ON LANDS THAT WE HAVE AGREEMENTS --
WHERE THE LAND OWNERS WANT THAT
TYPE OF ACTIVITY TO HAPPENED?
EVEN WITH A DOUBLING OF OUR IN
THE IN THE ADDITIONAL MONEY SAID
PUT AND I'LL GET TO THE
SUPPRESSION PREVENTION BALANCE.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES AT A
THIRTY THREE MILLION ACRES IS
THAT ENOUGH GIVEN GIVEN THE M.
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF GROWTH OF OF
PEOPLE MOVING IT LIVING IN THESE
CONDITIONS IN THE IN THE WILD
LANDS.
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS NOT TO STATE.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER GOOD QUESTION --
AS OF TODAY AND THAT IS WHAT THE
SCIENCE SAYS IS ENOUGH TO TO TO
START TO RESTORE FORCED
RESILIENCY --
IT IS BALANCED BY A HALF
NATIONAL FOREST IS TRYING TO DO
IN CALIFORNIA AT THE SAME TIME
SO.
IT'S ACTUALLY ONE MILLION ACRES
ACROSS --
BOTH LANDSCAPES --
AND THAT'S WHAT THE FORCE CARBON
PLAN KIND OF HONED IN ON AND AND
CAME UP WITH THAT'S THE NUMBER
THAT WE NEED TO DO --
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TREAT
EVERY SINGLE ACRE THAT THAT
COULD USE --
THAT KIND OF TREATMENT --
WILL HAVE TO DO THE ONES THAT
THAT ARE ARE ACCESSIBLE TO US
AND WE OR WHERE WE HAVE
AGREEMENTS TO DO SO --
AND THEN --
IT'S GOING TO TAKE DECADES TO OF
RETURN FOREST HEALTH TO WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE AND THERE ARE GOING
TO BE CHANGES ALONG THE WAY IT
COULD BE THAT THE NEXT ITERATION
OF THE OF THE CARBON PLAN --
COULD TELL US SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BUT RIGHT NOW THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE COULD YOU HELP US
UNDERSTAND THE TREE REMOVAL --
CATASTROPHE THAT WE HAVE YOUR
PREDECESSOR TESTIFIED HIS
THROUGH SEPT TWO LAST YEAR THAT
THAT.
YOU OVER --
TO GET A MILLION TREES REMOVED
THERE'S A HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DEAD TREES IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S TAKING CAL FIRE TWO YEARS.
SO THIS IS THE PRESCRIBED BURNS
IS A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
BUDGET ON THAT DEAD TREES.
WHAT'S WHAT SHOULD WE BE TO AND
WHAT SHOULD I BE DEMANDING OF%
CAL FIRE AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND COUNTIES AND PRIVATE LAND
OWNERS.
THE AND THEN ANOTHER REALLY GOOD
QUESTION BECAUSE ACROSS THE
HUNDRED A HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN MILLION.
TREES THAT ARE OUT THERE DEAD OR
APPROXIMATELY --
IT'S NOT REASONABLE TO THINK
THAT WE'RE GOING.
TO TAKE DOWN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE OUR ACROSS THIS ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE IN PLACES WHERE --
DEAD TREES ARE PART OF THE OF
THE THE LANDSCAPE AND AND THAT
AND SOME OF THAT'S OKAY.
SO.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON ON THOSE AREAS WHERE
HUMAN AND --
BUT WHERE ARE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
AND WHERE THERE IS CRITICAL NEED
TO REMOVE TREES IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THOSE.
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE --
WHEN WE GET INTO THE THE DEEPER
WOODS OR THE BACK COUNTRY THEN
WE HAVE THERE THERE'S A A
DECISION THAT HAS TO BE MADE AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN EXPECT?
THE FOREST TO RECOVER ON ITS OWN --
WHETHER THEY'RE ST PLANTING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE WHETHER SOME OF
THOSE TREES NEED TO BE REMOVED
OR NOT BASED ON ALL OF THOSE
FACTORS --
WHAT I WILL --
IT WOULD POINT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT IS WHEN THOSE TREES THAT
ARE DEAD FALL AND ARE STREWN
ABOUT ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THERE FOR
FIFTY PLUS YEARS AS FUELS.
THAT WILL --
BURN IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS THE
CALM.
AND SO WE DO HALF WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT IF WE DO INVEST IN
REFORESTATION AND PLANTING.
SOME OF THOSE AREAS IN THE BACK
COUNTRY SOME OF THAT FUEL DOES
NEED TO BE REMOVED THE TREES
NEED TO BE DROPPED.
BUT THERE'S AN ECOLOGICAL RE
GROUND AS WELL SO THERE THIS
IT'S A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE.
AND WE REALLY JUST NEED TO FOCUS
ON THOSE ON THOSE --
HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND
WHERE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE SAFE AND
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING
TO BE SO WE HAVE ANOTHER
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION CHALLENGE ALSO SO
WHILE WHILE IT MIGHT BE.
MIGHT WORK FROM AN ECOLOGICAL
POINT OF VIEW WITH THE WITH THE
FOR THE FORCE THAT IS ALSO
INCREASING THE EMISSIONS THAT --
WE MAY BE ABLE TO SPEED THAT UP
IF THEY WERE CHAPTER OR ARE SOME
FROM REMOVED.
I'M CONCERNED WITH THE BALANCE
YOU KNOW --
AND I'M WONDERING WHEN WE GET
THE TIP HIT THE TIPPING POINT ON
PREVENTION AND SUPPRESSION YOU
KNOW THAT IT'S NO IT'S IT'S NOT.
A SECRET THAT THE BULK OF THE
MONEY THAT'S BEING ASKED FROM
THE AGENCIES BEFORE S..
ALTHOUGH WE'RE NOT.
CONSIDERING THAT RIGHT NOW WITH
THE FULL LOOK FOR TO THAT IN SUB
TOO BUT IT'S ON SUPPRESSION AND
THE NEW MONEY THAT'S COMING IN
IS BY THE ADMINISTRATION'S POINT
OUT BODY ALITALIA'S REPORT.
ISON SUPPRESSION WHEN DO WE
MEET THE TIPPING POINT BECAUSE
IT SEEMS.
TO ME THAT IF WE IF WE DOUBLED
DOWN ON THE PREVENTION TO REMOVE
SOME OF THE FUELS THEN WE MIGHT
NOT NEED.
FOUR HUNDRED RESPONSES FROM THE
CITY'S CHANNEL I DON'T HAVE
FIRES IN MY DISTRICT BUT THE CAL
FREMONT.
POLICE DEPARTMENT SAN JOSE THEY
WERE ALL FROM RESPOND THERE'S
THIRD THEY RESPONDED SO FAR
MAYBE THIS YEAR I'LL BE.
I'LL BE FILLED WITH THAT BUT I'M
JUST SAYING THAT THAT THAT THE
RESPONSE BUT THERE AGAIN I THINK
THAT THEY THEIR CHARGES IS
DIFFERENT WIN.
IF WE'RE INVESTING.
MY QUESTION IS IS THAT ON THESE.
AN OUNCE OF PREVENTION IS WORTH
A POUND OF CURE RIDER WITH A
VICE VERSA POUND THE PREVENTION
FIRST NOW SECURE.
PUT SO.
HELP ME WITH THE A CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WITH
THESE EXPECTATION OF GIGANTIC
FIRES AND MODICUM OF PREVENTION
I MEAN I I I I I. E..
I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT WE COULD
DO MORE IN THE PREVENTION FEEL
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
ESCALATE --
THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
[inaudible]
AND A MINUTE AND THEN.
TAKE THE SURVEY PLEASE PLEASE.
YEAH OKAY --
JUST JUST JUST CLEAR BY --
A COUPLE OF THINGS --
EVERY ACRE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
CAN BURN WILL BURN SOME DAY AND
SO WE WE HAVE WE HAVE TO KIND OF
KEEP THAT IN MIND SO.
YES MAYBE.
EACH OF OUR AREAS DOESN'T HAVE
IRE EVERY YEAR BUT HOPEFULLY
NOT NEXT YEAR --
ANNA AND I WOULD --
REFLECT THAT THIS COMING YEAR
THAT HAS ALL THE INDICATIONS OF
BEING JUST AS AS POSSIBLY COULD
TELL BECAUSE AS LAST YEAR AND
THE YEAR BEFORE --
SO RELATED TO THE THE
SUPPRESSION VERSUS PREVENTION --
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO PARSE
THOSE OUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT CAL FIRE --
EVERY FIRE ENGINE THAT THAT --
THAT COMES INTO OUR SYSTEM --
IS BOTH SUPPRESSION.
AND PREVENTION.
AND THOSE ENGINE COMPANIES ARE
CUTTING DOWN TREES IN SOME CASES
THEY'RE BUILDING A FIRE LINE TO
DO PRESCRIBED FIRES.
THEY'RE PUTTING FIRE ON THE
GROUND AND DOING PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROJECT WORK THEY'RE DOING FUEL
OTHER FUELS READ IT READ
REDUCTION WORK THEY'RE DOING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTIONS --
BUT IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE SO ANY ANYTHING THAT YOU
INVEST IN OR OR THAT THE STATE
INVESTS IN --
RELATED TO RESOURCES THAT ARE
CAL FIRE RESOURCES DO BOTH --
ALL OF THE INVESTMENT WHILE IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT AS WELL.
IN IN OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERSHIP THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED.
SUPPRESSION BECAUSE WE DON'T
EMPLOY D..
MUTUAL AID RATE RESOURCES FROM
IN THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA
DOING.
PREVENTION.
NOW THEY MIGHT DO PREVENTION IN
THEIR IN THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AREA.
BUT AS FAR AS THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA THE THOSE
RESOURCES DON'T DO THAT SO
ANYTHING THAT YOU THAT HAS A CAL
FIRE PATCH ON IT IT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED.
AS BOTH PREVENTION AND
SUPPRESSION AND BY AND LARGE.
THAT INVESTMENT IS IN PREVENTION
BECAUSE WHILE THEIR TRAINING
THEY'RE GETTING PREPARED.
TO DO SUPPRESSION AND PREVENTION.
THEN WHEN THEY'RE NOT TRAINING.
THEIR ONLY RESPONDING TO
INCIDENTS WHEN THEY'RE INCIDENTS
GOING.
ALL THE REST OF THE TIME THEY'RE
DOING PREVENTION ACTIVE.
SO VERY MUCH --
THE ENGINES.
AND AND THE CREWS --
THE THE SENATOR NIELSEN THE THE
CCC CREWS THAT WERE ADDING VERY
MUCH ARE PREVENTION RESOURCES.
SO I THINK I'D LIKE TO CAN MAYBE
MAYBE TALK FURTHER --
AT SOME POINT ABOUT HOW HOW WE
CAN MAYBE BREAK THAT DOWN IN
PERCENTAGE WISE IT FORWARD KIND
OF YOU GIVE A BETTER --
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON OF
OF PREVENTION VERSUS --
AND I I GUESS MY FINAL QUESTION
MADAM --
CHAIRS AT THE BUDGET AS FOR
HUNDRED NINETY NINE NEW --
POSITIONS OR SEIZE SOMEONE FULL
TIME HOW WOULD THAT HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE HAD MADE A
DIFFERENCE IF YOU HAD THEM IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND AND
JUST.
TO ENTERTAIN ME GIVE ME A BREAK
DOWN ON THE PREVENTION
SUPPRESSION.
WORK THERE WITH THEM BUT IF YOU
HAD THEM DURING THESE BIG FIRES
WHAT.
DIFFERENCE IF ANY WOULD HAVE
MADE.
THAT IS A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
I I I HOPE I DON'T SURPRISE YOU
BY THE ANSWER --
THE WELL IF I A I COULD BREAK
THEM DOWN I'D LIKE TO I'D LIKE
TO DO THAT AND A MORE SYSTEMATIC --
I'VE.
WAY IN THE FUTURE BUT IT CAN BE
BROKEN DOWN AS AS TO HOW MUCH OF
THE INVESTMENT WILL BE
PREVENTION VERSUS SUPPRESSION --
AND WE WILL --
RELATED TO WHAT WITH THE IMPACT
OF BàN.
BY THE IMPACT.
OF HAVING MORE FIREFIGHTERS --
AVAILABLE TO US ON THE GROUND
WOULD HAVE BEEN THAT WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET PEOPLE OFF
THE LINE.
AND BACK HOME. TO SEE THEIR
FAMILIES AND NOT HAVE TO BE OUT
ON FIRE ASSIGNMENTS. FOR FORTY
FIVE TO SIXTY DAYS --
WHICH HAS A VERY A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT IN THE MORALE WHEN YOU'RE
OUT ON THE LINE BITING FIRE AND
THE ABILITY TO KEEP GOING
KNOWING THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO GO HOME AND SEE YOUR
FAMILY.
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO DO THAT THIS
LAST YEAR.
WE HAD WE HAD HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF FIREFIGHTERS THAT
DID NOT GO HOME ALMOST ALL
SUMMER LONG --
THEY MISSED A LOT OF OF FAMILY
EVENTS AND AND IT'S TAKING A
TOLL NOW --
I A I A PERSONAL FRIENDS THE
THAT ARE VERY MUCH --
HURTING.
NOT SLEEPING.
ARE AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
FIX AND THIS IS THAT'S ANOTHER.
ASPECT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE WE'RE TRYING TO GET THE
SUPPORT FOR OUR OUR FIREFIGHTERS
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO DO THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING.
ON BEHALF OF THE OF THE CITIZENS
OF CALIFORNIA AND CONTINUE TO
RESPOND. TO THIS INCREASING
INDUCED --
EVENT THAT WERE.
WHAT LIVING TO HOLD THE REST MY
QUESTIONS RANDOM CHAIR AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING THEM
WITH YOU ALL?
MENTORSHIPS SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
UP UP PICK UP WHERE YOU LEFT OFF
THEIR DIRECTOR --
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU ON BOARD
NOW -- DICK
PORTER AND YEAH YOU.
AND YOUR EXPERIENCE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS HUGE YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF ALL THE STATE WIDE
NOOKS AND CRANNIES JUST SOMEONE
WHO REALLY UNDERSTANDS THE
OPERATIONS A GIFT TO THE STATE
AND I KNOW YOU GOT BIG SHOES TO
FILL BY NOW YOU'RE GONNA FILM SO --
SO THANK YOU FOR FOR BEING THERE --
IN ON THAT NOTE.
IT'S A DARK STATISTIC BUT THE
SUICIDE RATES ARE ACTUALLY
OVERCOMING THE FIRE LINE DEATHS --
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO MORE.
MORE THE MEN AND WOMEN.
FIGHTING FIRES OR SHOULD LOSE
THEIR LIVES FROM SUICIDE THAN
THEY ARE FROM ACTUAL RISKS.
THE OBVIOUS FIRST RISK OF THE
JOB AND THE PTS I ISSUES REAL
AND WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
REALLY HARD ON THAT THIS YEAR WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR BRING IN
FORD -- SOME
PROPOSALS ON STUDYING THIS
FURTHER LOOKING AT THE WELLNESS
SIDE OF THINGS --
BECAUSE YOU KNOW EVERY PEOPLE
ARE HEARD AND YOU CAN'T JUST --
CRAM THAT AWAY AND JUST PRETEND
LIKE IT'S NOT REAL.
RESULTING IN ALL KINDS OF
STRANGE TENSIONS OUT THERE SO --
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT -- I
WANTED TO GET A SENSE --
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
PULL IN THAT THREAD FROM THE
LAST PANEL ON THIS SORT OF THIS.
MULTI YEAR PLANNING QUESTION AND
ALSO.
THIS NOTION OF OKAY WERE TRYING
TO STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN
SUPPRESSION PREVENTION BUT IS IS
THE OVERALL LIKE RIGHT SIZING
THAT OVERALL NUMBER.
I THINK YOU HEARD DIRECTOR GIVE
THE DUDE SHE SHOULD TALK ABOUT
IT DIDN'T INSERT A BROAD SCOPE
BUT HOW HOW ARE YOU ALL THINKING
ABOUT THIS TO DEAL WITH IN TERMS
OF ACTUALLY RIGHT SIZING THE
BOTH.
NEAR TERM AND LONG TERM --
BUDGET YOU KNOW ALLOCATION SAID
THE SCOPE OF THE RISK.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
I THINK NEAR TERM AND LONG TERM
TO ACTUALLY A REALLY GOOD WAY TO
THINK ABOUT IT --
THIS IS SO --
CHIEF PORTER MENTIONED THAT --
THESE ENGINES SPECIFICALLY ARE
BOTH.
SUPPRESSION IN PREVENTION AND
THE REASON WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR
YEAR ROUND ENGINES KINDA
UNDERSCORING CHIEF PORTERS POINT.
REASON WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR YEAR
ROUND ENGINES AS OPPOSED TO
SEASONAL.
ENGINES IS TO REALLY DOUBLE DOWN
ON THE FIRE PREVENTION --
A PROJECTS IN DURING THE OFF
SEASON.
WE COULD HAVE EASILY.
TRIED TO KIND OF SAVE SOME
GENERAL FUND MAYBE AND JUST SAY
WELL WE'LL DO THIRTEEN NEW
SEASONAL.
ENGINES BUT I THINK WE'RE
GETTING TO THE POINT OF WITH --
LOOKING OF RETURN ON NVESTMENT
NOT WANTING TO BE PENNY WISE
POUND FOOLISH.
AND WE BELIEVE THESE --
THIRTEEN ARE AND WHAT YOU WOULD
CALL NO REGRETS TYPE INVESTMENTS
IN.
WE SO GETTING MEN TO KIND OF HOW
WE LOOK AT THINGS --
FISCALLY AND KIND OF THIS RETURN
ON INVESTMENT ONES.
WE WORK WITH CAL FIRE AND SOME
PRELIMINARY DATA AND A
PRELIMINARY KIND OF RISK FACTORS
SEARCHES FIRE IGNITION SEARCHES --
HIGH HAZARD SEVERITIES OWNS SUCH
AS HAVE OVAL STRUCTURES.
AND CONCLUDED THAT.
ADDING IN THE NEAR TERM THIRTEEN
ENGINES IN SOME OF THESE
STRATEGICALLY LOCATED PLACES --
WERE CLEAR NO REGRETS
INVESTMENTS BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A LONG TERM
PROBLEM.
HANDED THAT CALIFORNIA IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE INITIATING
A MORE OF A STRATEGIC PLANNING.
PROCESS.
GOING FORWARD IT LOOKS AT MANY
OF THESE VERY THINGS THAT YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT TRYING TO TURN OVER
TO PORTER TO REALLY TALK ABOUT
KIND THIS LONG TERM STRATEGIC
PLANNING THING THAT THEY ARE
INITIATING INITIATING.
THANK YOU OF MATT A AND YES WE
IN IN OUR REDRAFT OF OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN --
WHICH IS IN PRINT --
WE HAVE FOUR GOALS AND GOAL
NUMBER ONE IS ASSESSING OUR CORE
CAPABILITIES --
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE --
ARE SUPPRESSION PREVENTION --
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT.
AND FIRE MARSHAL ACTIVITIES IN
THE ALL THE ALL THE ALL ALL THE
WHERE WE HAVE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND --
AND SO WE'RE GONNA DO A TOP TO
BOTTOM REVIEW OF OF WHAT OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE AND WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE FOR THE FUTURE AND
LOOKING.
YOU KNOW TWENTY THIRTY DOWN THE
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD --
ARE WE POSITIONED --
APPROPRIATELY TO BE ABLE TO MEET --
THE MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT --
AND TO GO FORWARD AND THEN
STARTED --
TO PLOT A COURSE --
TO CORRECT ANY DEFICIENCIES AND
IF WE HAVE ANY OVERAGES AND
OTHER AREAS WILL WILL WILL WILL
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THOSE AS
WELL AND AND YOU KNOW REPROGRAM
THOSE KIND OF THINGS.
AS YOU DEVELOPING THAT STRATEGIC
PLAN ARE YOU FOR YOU CONSIDERING
SORT OF THE RISK MITIGATION
ACTIVITIES OR MAYBE OUTSIDE YOUR
PURVIEW AS WELL IN TERMS OF HOW.
TO THE BY DOWN THAT RISK I MEAN
I I'M I'M THINKING AGAIN ABOUT --
THE CREATED RIGHT ONE OF THE
MAJOR CONDITIONS SOURCE IN THE
STATE -- AND
ONLY SO MUCH WE CAN GET DONE ON
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT OR TIMBER
MANAGEMENT SOME OF ITS IN HOME
HARDENING IN IN THE BUILDING
CODES IN IN LAND USE PLANNING
SOME OF IT'S ABOUT GREAT
PLANNING AND WHERE ARE WHERE WE
GENERATE POWER AND CAN WE DO IT
IN A DISTRIBUTED.
WAY SO AT IS SPECIALLY IN THOSE
AREAS UTILITIES MAYBE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SHUT OFF POWER BUT THEY
DON'T WANT A BUNCH OF ANGRY
RESIDENTS SAYING.
WHY THEY GO DARK BUT?
THERE ACTUALLY OUR SOLUTIONS
THAT HAPPENED OR HOW YOU SHOULD
INTEGRATING THOSE AND
NONTRADITIONAL --
FACTORS INTO THE STRATEGIC
PLANNING TO HELP YOU.
IN A GREAT MOOD.
SHE'S NOT PLEASE LET IN THE THAT
IS THAT IS A KEY COMPONENT TO
THIS THIS PLANNING PROCESS WHICH
IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN EVEN WE
WHERE WE WERE EIGHT TEN YEARS
AGO AS FAR AS STRATEGIC PLANNING
WE REALLY HAVE.
TO LOOK AT THE THE TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
US AND LOOK AT THE ABILITY. TO
TO BRING --
WAYS OF ANALYZING DATA THAT
REALLY DIDN'T EVEN EXIST THE
LAST TIME WE DID OUR STRATEGIC
PLAN IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE SO.
A GOING FORWARD ALL OF THAT'S
GOING TO BE PART OF OF THE THE
FORMULA THAT WE'RE USING --
OF COURSE IT WILL BE MOE
FOCUSED IN IN CERTAIN AREAS OF
OUR STRATEGIC PLANNING THAN IN
OTHERS -- WE
DO -- WELL
THERE ARE OF SOME PROMISING
THOUGHTS TOWARD THE FUTURE AND
IN THE SUPPRESSION.
OF WILDFIRES ARE USING --
REMOTE SENSING AND OTHER HUMAN --
TYPE OF OF INTERACTION WITH THAT
FIRE THAT'S HAPPENING --
RIGHT NOW THERE IS THERE IS
NOTHING THAT REPLACES THE BOOTS
ON THE GROUND.
AND EVEN OUR AIRCRAFT ARE ALL
GEARED TOWARD.
SLOWING OF FIRE DOWN SO WE CAN
PUT BOOTS ON THE GROUND --
SO SO IT'S A VERY IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S GOT A VERY --
HUMAN GROUNDED ELEMENT --
IN OUR STRATEGIC PLANNING BUT WE
ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THOSE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES --
WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT AT
THE DATA THAT'S NOW BECOMING
AVAILABLE THROUGH --
THE CPUC --
AND THE THE THE THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS THAT THE
UTILITIES ARE ARE ARE BRINGING --
FOR REVIEW WHICH THAT THEY'RE
ALL DUE ON THE SEVENTH OF OF
THAT THE FEBRUARY SUS. ONE WEEK
OUT -- WILL
BE STE THOSE --
WITH -- CPUC
THAT WILL INFORM AND GIVE US
MORE DATA TO TO UTILIZE TO KIND
OF HONE IN ON THOSE AREAS THAT
ARE MOST VULNERABLE IN THE GRID --
AND AND THEN BE ABLE TO TAILOR
SOME OF OUR PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES --
TO THOSE THOSE AREAS AND THOSE
NEEDS SO ALL OF THIS IS COMING
TOGETHER RIGHT NOW --
WE'RE WORKING ON OUR EXECUTIVE
ORDER FOR FORTY FIVE DAY
EXECUTIVE EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
IS GOING TO INFORM.
THESE DECISIONS AS WELL GOING
FORWARD --
AND AND THEN OUR OUR INNOVATION
SPRINT -- IS
ALSO GOING TO TO DO THAT THROUGH
THE RFI SQUARED PRO PROCESS SO.
THE THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON ON GETTING
US THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
TO REALLY MEET THAT GOAL --
ONE TO THE BEST THAT WE CAN
POSSIBLY --
GET FIDELITY WISE LOOKING INTO
THE FUTURE A BUT I DIDN'T HEAR
THOUGH --
BUILDING CODES AND LAND USE.
BECAUSE IT'S SORT OF JUST.
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM IN A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS OBVIOUSLY HAVE.
PRIMARY AUTHORITY ON A LOT OF
THOSE QUESTIONS BUT IS A YEAR
THINK INTO THE THEY DO AND THE
REASON YOU DIDN'T HEAR ME SAY IT
IS BECAUSE I I GLOSSED OVER I AM
SORRY NO NO NO I I'M JUST
BECAUSE WE WE ARE VERY MUCH OKAY
AGED IN.
LAND USE PLANNING AS WELL --
WE HAVE --
STAFF SINCE --
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WE BUILT A
LAND USE PLANNING.
A GROUP AND WE ARE WORKING WITH --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
YOU KNOW IF THE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL -- TO
INCREASE THEIR SAFETY ELEMENT --
COMPLIANCE WITH AND AND THEN --
INTEGRATE.
THOSE.
YOU BUILDING CODE ELEMENTS AND
AND THEN ALSO INFRASTRUCTURE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE KEY TO
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD JUST --
I WOULD OFFER.
ASSISTANCE AS YOU GO FORWARD ON
MY AND I'M SURE MANY OTHER
MEMBERS HERE IF WHAT COMES BACK --
SAFE FROM THE UTILITIES FOR
THEIR WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
ISN'T IMAGINATIVE ENOUGH OR IF
THEY'RE IN TOO MUCH OF A FOXHOLE
FRANKLY RIGHT NOW TO THINK AHEAD.
WHERE THEIR BALANCE SHEETS ARE
THREATENED OR THEY MAY NOT KNOW
IT DO THEY EVEN WANT TO BE IN
THE PROCUREMENT BUSINESS AT ALL
WE'RE HEARING SOME OF THEM DON'T --
IT THERE THERE'S SORT OF AN
INHERENTLY DEFENSIVE POSTURE
RIGHT NOW AND SO I'LL BE CURIOUS
TO SEE WHAT THOSE PLANS LOOK
LIKE BUT I THINK.
THERE MAY BE SOME THINGS THAT
THEY JUST CAN'T EVEN DO ON THEIR
OWN AND THAT THE STATE MAY HAVE
TO COME UP WITH SOME CREATIVE
NEW WAYS. TO TO TO CUT THAT RISK
BACK MAY I WONDER.
YOU KNOW WE LOST ALL
COMMUNICATIONS INFRASTRUCTURE IN
A HUGE.
SWATH OF TERRITORY DOWN LA
VENTURA COUNTY --%
WHICH AFFECTED BOTH YOUR FOLKS
ON THE GROUND AS WELL AS
RESIDENTS TRY TO DEAL WITH
EVACUATION --
IT'S A SINGLE POINT OF FAILURE
REALLY THAT WE'RE SEEING WHERE.
BACKUP POWERS MAYBE NOT THERE OR
THE THE INFRASTRUCTURES GETTING
BURNT DOWN INDIRECTLY GIVE THE
DUDE YOU JUST CAN YOU MAKE A
COMMENT SORT OF ON WHAT YOU SAW --
THROUGH THAT EXPERIENCE AND
MAYBE SOME LESSONS WE LEARNED
FROM THAT.
WELL I'M JUST AN AIRY I GOT I
GUESS THIS FOCUS ON SOMETHING
THAT REALLY IS CRITICAL TO ALL
OF US NOW AND AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE PUBLIC IS --
DEPENDED UPON.
AND SOMETHING MYERS POINT WITH A
LATE MORNING AND THAT IS.
CELL PHONES AND AND YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN TO THAT
LEVEL THAT PEOPLE ARE LIVE AND
LIVE OFF OF THE CELL PHONES AND
GET UP THEIR INFORMATION OFFER
THOSE.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT PROVIDES
DATA INTO THE CELL PHONES THAT
INFORMATION MOVING THE THE
SIGNALS FOR MARTIN WARNING --
ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO HAVE THAT
FOR GOING TO DEPEND A FOR FOR
PUTTING ALL OUR EGGS IN YOU KNOW
TO THE TO THE DEGREE INTO THAT
BASKET WE NEED TO HAVE THAT.
SYSTEM RESILIENT NOW.
NOT EVERYTHING THE GOVERNMENT AS
A CONTROL EVERYTHING SOME OF
THIS IS PRIVATE SECTOR RIGHT IN
THE CASE OF IN CASE OF OUR CELL
SITES WHICH WHICH THE CELL SITES
ARE JUST FOR MOVING ALERT
MORNING WE WERE USING THAT --
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE INFORMATION
AMONGST ALL THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES WE ARE MOVING. TO A
BABY A PLATFORM --
WHERE YOU'RE BROADBAND BEING
RELATED TO THE INTER OPERABILITY
BROADBAND THE CAPABILITY
REQUIRES THAT?
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT SO.
IN THE CASE OF THE OF YOUR FIRE
CENTER --
YOU KNOW.
WHO FOR EXAMPLE?
THE FIRE BROUGHT DOWN SOMETHING
LIKE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SITES OF
CELL SITES THAT WERE CRITICAL
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE SITE TO
COMING DOWN BUT THE BUT THE BACK
CALL.
THE FIBER IN AND SO.
WHEREAS WE COLLECTIVELY
APPROACHES IS NOT JUST FOR US
BUT WE NEED TO INCORPORATE AS I
MENTIONED.
EARLIER --
SHOW OR ON MORE LIKE ABOUT THE
ENGAGING INSURANCE COMPANIES --
TWENTY ONE FIGHT EFFORT WE NEED
TO BRING IN --
OUR TELECOM PARTNERS EXCEPT WE
NEED TO BUILD PUBLIC SAFETY
GRADE.
LEVEL RESILIENCY INTO THAT AND
WE NEED TO HAVE BACKUP SYSTEMS
IF IF IF THAT SITE NEEDS TO BE
NOT IS DEFENSIVELY.
CLEARED BUT YOU TO HAVE A
BATTERY OR GENERATOR BACK UP WE
NEED TO KNOW WE NEED TO KNOW
THAT WE CAN COUNT ON THAT
YOURSELF.
TO ALL THE PUBLIC --
ACCORDINGLY SO THIS IS A BIG.
BIG PIECE OF A COLLECTIVELY
BETWEEN THEM THE CAMPFIRE IN THE
WALLS THE FIRE SOMETHING LIKE
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE SITES
THAT WENT OFF LINE AND AND THEN
THE CHALLENGE COMES WITH.
TELECOMS HAVING TO RESPOND
MOBILE UNITS BUT THEN I WAS
HAVING TO TURN TO GOVERNMENT
SYSTEMS ARE TO OUR MILITARY
PARTNERSHIP THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS AND IT'S NOT UNIQUE
TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FIRES
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES.
WERE JUST AS BAD AND AND SO WE
THAT'S A BIG DEAL BECAUSE WE
BECAUSE OF FOR DOING EVACUATION
ORDERS.
IN A TIMELY FASHION OUT WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO COUNT ON THOSE --
AND SAYS WE DON'T CONTROL ALL
THAT IT HAS TO BE A PARTNERSHIP
OR THEIR MINIMUM STANDARDS
THOUGH THAT.
WE AS A STATE IMPOSE ON THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS DID
IN TERMS OF WHAT.
WHAT THEY HOW HOW RESILIENT THEY
HAVE TO BE RIGHT NOW IS THAT
PRETTY DISCRETIONARY --
WHO ARE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS OFFICE DOES
PROVIDE?
GUIDELINES FOR THEM --
TO TO AND BUT IT SOME.
OTHER COMPLEXITIES WITHIN THE
BOOKING OF OVERSIGHT YOU KNOW
FROM FROM THE STANDPOINT OF THE
STATE -- SO
WE WERE WE CAN --
AND IT'S NOT LIKE THEY DON'T
WANT TO DO IT BUT IT'S A IT
COMES DOWN --
TO SETTING UP PRIORITY BASED
UPON COST AND GETTING OUT AND
AND GETTING THAT DONE BUT WOULD
YOU SAY I MEAN AS YOU'RE
DEVELOPING THIS.
BOLD NEW STRATEGIC PLAN A
KALIFORNIA IN SOME OF YOUR
INVENTORY I MEAN DO YOU EVEN
HAVE THE INFORMATION OF WHERE
OUR VULNERABILITIES ARE RIGHT
NOW WITH THE STATE OF STATE.
EVERY SINGLE CELL TOWER IS IN
THE STATE I MEAN IS THAT IS THAT
DATA.
IS AVAILABLE TO YOU I THINK WE
HAVE A PART AYE MIKE MIKE I GIVE
YOU A 100% YEAH BUT I'M I'M
ALMOST POSITIVE A PRETTYGOOD
IDEA TO OUR PUBLIC SAFETY I MEAN
WE CAN KNOW.
WHERE A LOT OF THE HIVE OWN
ABILITIES ARE BUT?
THE INDUSTRY ITSELF GOING TO
KNOW REALLY THE BEST AND THAT'S
AGAIN -- AND
WE BRING THEM INTO THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER DURING
EMERGENCIES TO BE ABLE --
TO TO OF GET THAT BUT THAT
THERE'S THERE'S A LOT MORE IN
THAT AREA THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
ACTUALLY BEFOE LA OR DID YOU
JUST SAID DO YOU GUYS HAVE A
COMMENT ON ON THIS THIS SAYS.
STRATEGIC PLANNING QUESTION AND
ANY ADVICE ME YOU GUYS ARE YOU
ALL FOLLOWING THAT AND OTHER
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
BE.
AS COMPREHENSIVE AS THEY NEED TO
BE AND INTERFACE AND ALL THE
OTHER AGENCIES I MEAN.
AND WE CAN HAVE MORE DETAILED
AND COMMENTS FOR YOU AS WE GO
THROUGH THE SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS I THINK WE AT THIS POINT
JUST WANTED TO SORT OF RAISE
THIS IDEA OF YOU MIGHT WANT TO
START WITH AN ASSESSMENT OF
WHERE THE CAPACITY IS AND WHERE
THE GAPS ARE.
AND AND IT YOU'RE ALSO GOING TO
WANT TO THINK ABOUT HOW BROADLY
DO YOU GO WITH IT AND YOU START
BRINGING IN THESE OTHER THINGS
LIKE YOU KNOW UTILITIES AND
PREVENTION.
AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT THAT
YOU CAN DO JUST BETWEEN CAL FIRE
IN -- YES ON
THIS SORT OF DIRECT FIRE
SUPPRESSION RESPONSE TIME AS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT ADDING
FIRE ENGINES AND HELICOPTERS AND
AN AIRCRAFT IN MUTUAL AID
RESOURCES. TO LOOK AT AND YOU
KNOW WAIT WAIT WE'RE IN WHAT
CASES DOESN'T MAKE THE MOST
SENSE TO ADD A CAL FIRE ENGINE
VERSES MORE MUTUAL AID RESOURCES
AND THAT SORT OF THING AND SO.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU MAY
WANT TO BE THINKING MORE BROADLY
THAN JUST WITHIN CAL FIREON AND
HOW THAT THAT THAT THAT SORT OF
ASSESSMENT WOULD BE COORDINATED --
BUT YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO THINK
ABOUT HW BROAD YOU GO BECAUSE
IF YOU MAKE IT SO HUGE AND
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS AND
AND AND IS IT GONNA HAVE THE
LEVEL OF DETAIL YOU NEED TO
REALLY INFORM.
SOME OF THESE BUDGETARY
DECISIONS WERE YOU THINKING OF
PREVENTION AND FIRE RESPONSE AND
AND AND STAFF AND EQUIPMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA SO I MEAN AS IT
MISTER ONLY YOU SAID.
THING IN NEAR TERM AND LONG TERM
THEN.
KEY HERE RIGHT SO HELPING MAKE
SURE THE CAL FIRE NO YES HAVE.
THE THE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO GET THE JOB DONE TO GET JUST
SURVIVE THE YEAR.
HOPEFULLY PREVENT MORE PEOPLE
FROM DYING OR MORE WHOLESOME IN
LAWS BUT THEN ALSO TRYING TO GET
SOME.
GOING IT'S GOING TO BE.
REALLY REALLY SCOPED OUT WHERE
WE CAN ACTUALLY DRIVE LONGER
TERM POLICY OVER ON THE GRID.
OVERALL OUR COMMUNICATINS
INFRASTRUCTURE MINIS HAS THINGS
BETTER USE IT TAKES.
DECADES BUT WE JUST GOT
ACCELERATE THIS IS FAST WE CAN'T
HEAR AND SQUEEZED INTO. FIVE
YEARS OR TO SPRINTER WHAT
WHATEVER THAT LOOKS LIKE BUT
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT EFFORT.
AND WOULD LOVE IT SOME POINTED
TO DRILL DOWN A LITTLE FURTHER
ALSO ON YOUR YOUR NEW VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMMATIC HE I ARE
I KNOW THAT JUST WAS RELEASED --
SO WE WANTED WE WANT TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU FEDERAL RESERVE MY
REMARKS FOR LATER SO.
THANK YOU YET --
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
SETTING UP THIS HEARING AND FOR
ALL OF THE EXPERTS WHO'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATING SO FAR --
ONE IN.
FIVE I HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AROUND
OUR STRATEGIC PLANNING AND OTHER
THINGS BUT I JUST WANTED --
TO COUNTER DOOR VICE CHAIRS
ASSERTION THAT ARE IN MADE FIRE
CREWS ARE LESS RELIABLE I DON'T
THINK WE'VE THERE'S ANY EVIDENCE
THUS FAR.
THAT THOSE CREWS ARE LESS
RELIABLE AND I THINK IN FACT.
WE HAVE RELIED ON THEM QUITE
EXTENSIVELY.
IN ALL OF THE FIRE RESPONSES
ENDS NOT ONLY IN THE FIRE
RESPONSES.
LAST COUPLE OF REALLY TRAGIC
YEARS BUT ALSO IN OUR OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION.
ACTIVITIES IN A AND I DON'T KNOW
IF -- T.
POOR IF YOU WONDER REFERENCE
THAT IT ALL BUT AS FAR AS A
QUALITY OF A CREW --
ARE ARE IN MAKE CREWS --
INDIVIDUALLY EACH ONE OF THEM IS
A TYPE ONE HIGH QUALITY CREW.
AND THE FIGHT FIRE ALONG SIDE.
HOT SHOTS AND ALL THE ALL THE
HARDEST WORKING --
FIREFIGHTERS OUT THERE.
THERE THERE LED BY OUR OUR
CALIFORNIA CAPTAINS LETTER THAT
ARE LEADING THEM.
BUT THEY ARE VERY HARD WORKING --
CREWMEMBERS.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM NOW.
THE IT'S KIND OF COMES --
TO HOW MANY WE HAVE IN THE
SYSTEM AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
THOUSAND INMATES SHORT OF OUR OF
OUR NEED TO HAVE ALL OF OUR
CREWS COVERED AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE THE WEAKNESSES WERE
RELATED TO INMATES IT'S IN THAT.
OF OF THE SYSTEM TO SUPPLY US
WITH ELIGIBLE INMATES --
TO TO THE PROGRAM SO THE CCC
CREWS ABSOLUTELY THEY ARE.
EQUALLY AS AS STRONG AND HARD
WORKING AS INDIVIDUAL CRUZ IT'S
JUST THE THE CAPACITY OF AN A
NUMBERS ISSUE BUT CERTAINLY NOT
A THE LIABILITY ISSUE --
SO THEN I I EIGHT I THINK. ONE
OF THE STRUGGLES THAT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE.
IS GIVEN THE THE CHALLENGES WERE
FACING [inaudible]
KNOWING THAT.
THIS PRESENCE OF FIRE AND VERY
CATASTROPHIC FIRES IS GONNA BE
CONTINUAL.
WHERE DO WE PUT?
OUR RESOURCES AND I APPRECIATE.
THAT -- FROM
CAL FIRES POINT OF VIEW YOU
DON'T DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN.
THE FORESTER THE WILD FIRE FIRE
VERSUS THOSE THAT HAVE OCCURRED
IN OUR WILD LANDS URBAN
INTERFACE --
BUT I THINK.
I AND I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR YOUR
OPINIONS BUT GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
FROM A FIRE ECOLOGY POINT OF
VIEW.
NOT MANAGED OUR FOREST LANDS.
IN A WAY THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
OPTIMAL FOR FIRE REDUCTION FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
AND IT SEEMS AND ALSO SO MUCH OF
THOSE THAT THAT ACREAGE IS.
FEDERAL.
THAT TO ACCOMPLISH THE TYPE OF
FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITY IN
THOSE LANDS.
IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WOULD
BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT.
NOW.
THE OBVIOUSLY THE IMPACT OF
THOSE FIRES SO THE MENDOCINO
COMPLEX FIRE WAS MANY MORE ACRES
THAN THE OTHER FIRES THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED.
SO IT WAS VERY BAD FROM A CARBON
POINT OF VIEW IN VERY BAD FOR ME --
QUALITY POINT OF VIEW THOUGH
MAYBE AIR QUALITY NOT AS BAD AS
THE URBAN --
INTERFACE ONCE BECAUSE YOU'RE
PUTTING A DIFFERENT SET OF OF
PARTICULATE MATTER AND CHEMICALS
INTO THE YEAR WHEN YOU'RE
BURNING THINGS THAT HUMANS HAVE
STARTED TO AFFECT VERSES.
OF TREES AND SCRUB AND SUCH
[inaudible]
ON BUT THE COST TO US FOR IN
TERMS OF PROPERTY.
IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC LOSSES IN
CLEAN UP ND OF COURSE HUMAN%
LIVES IS FAR GREATER.
IN OUR INTERFACE AREAS.
AND THE THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
WHILE IT IS PRIVATE PROPERTY IN
MANY CASES IT SEEMS LIKE WE
MIGHT HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITY. TO
DO MORE WORK TO ME TO LESSEN.
THE FIRES THERE THEN.
PUTTING OVER EMPHASIS ON BE --
FORCE MANAGEMENT AND I I'D LIKE
TO HEAR --
I'D LIKE SOME SPEED.
THIS DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A
CONCLUSION BY ANY MEANS OUR WE
WE HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES SO
WHAT IS OUR BEST FROM A
STRATEGIC PLANNING POINT OF VIEW
WHAT IS THE BEST PLACE. TO
DIRECT THOSE RESOURCES
[inaudible]
AND I'M GONNA START THE ANSWER
WITH IT'S COMPLICATED --
A REALLY IS --
BECAUSE WELL IN THAT THAT
INTERFACE AREA WE HAVE A LOT
MORE POINTS OF NEED OF
PROTECTION.
THE COST AND HIGHER COSTS TO DO
SO AND HIGHER COST OF LOS.
ALL ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE ARE
THERE -- AND
AND THAT IS NEEDS TO BE --
A ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES --
THE THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS IS
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE START TO GET --
TO WHAT YOU REFERRED TO
PREVIOUSLY --
A MORE HEALTHY FOREST ECOSYSTEM
STATE.
MORE OF AN ABILITY FOR OUR
FOREST LANDS TO BE ABLE.
TO HANDLE NATURAL AND NON
NATURAL STARTS OF FIRES AND AND
ALLOW MAY BE SOME MORE ACRES TO
BE BURNED IN A HEALTHY.
WAY -- WHICH
SHOULD TO ALL OF THE FIRST
COMPARED.
TO THE V. FOUR WE AREA YES
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE AND
INTERMIX AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THAT'S AND THAT'S
PRIMARILY WHERE ARE OUR ENGINES
ARE.
CURRENTLY AND OUR OUR ASSESSMENT
WILL LOOK AT THEY NEED --
TO ADD ENGINES IN IN THOSE KIND
OF WE WE OR INTERMIX AREAS
BECAUSE REALLY THAT IS SO I'M
THINKING OF PREVENTION NOW
VERSUS JUST I UNDERSTAND AND
THEY AND THEY ARE PREVENTION
OKAY SO THOSE THOSE ENGINES ARE
THERE. TO SUPPRESS FIRES AND
THEN WHEN THEY'RE NOT
SUPPRESSING FIRES THERE
PREVENTION REMEMBER AND I AND I
AND AND I'M GONNA WORK ON ON ON
KIND OF MORE ARTICULATING THE
THE PERCENTAGES OF OF TEIR THAT
WORKLOAD THAT THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING --
IN THAT --
FOR YOU FOR THE FOR THE FUTURE --
BUT WELL WELL WE WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON ALL OF THESE THINGS --
AND AND THEN I'M GONNA COME BACK
TO CRUISE ON THAT.
SO THERE IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
WHY WE NEED MORE OF OUR OUR FREE
FIREFIGHTER CREWS WHETHER
THEY'RE THE CCC WHETHER THEIR
FUTURE CAL FIRE FIRE FIGHTER
CREW.
THOSE ARE THE CREWS THAT CAN
WORK IN THOSE INTERFACE OR IF
THOSE INTERMIX AREAS WE WE WE
ARE RIGHT NOW IT IT'S IT'S NOT
SAFE TO PUT INMATES IN SOME
SITUATIONS.
AND SO WE NEED THOSE FOR FREE
FIREFIGHTERS IN IN THE MIX IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT WORK
AND THAT'S GROWING THAT PROGRAM
WILL ALLOW US --
WORK IN THAT THAT WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE AND URBAN INTERMIX
AREA -- TO
DO MORE OF THE PREVENTION WORK --
DOING PRESCRIBED FIRE IN THOSE
AREAS IS VERY TEDIOUS BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY UNTIL WE DO ENOUGH OF
THIS OTHER TYPE OF WORK TO GET
TO A STATE WHERE WE CAN.
PUT FIRE ON THE GROUND SAFELY --
AND WE HAVE A COMMUNITY THAT'S
GOING TO ACCEPT FIRE ON THE
GROUND --
THEN.
WE'LL GET TO THAT AS WELL THESE
OUR FUTURE STATES AND I THINK
FIVE YEARS MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT --
SHORT SENATOR STERN ON ON
TURNING THE THE TABLES BUT WE'RE
GONNA DO EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY
CAN. TO TO SHORTEN THAT TIME
LINE -- BUT
WE'RE WE REALLY ARE TALKING
ABOUT DECADES THIS IS THIS IS A
SEA CHANGE AND I THINK YOU'VE
YOU'VE HIT ON IT WITH THE THE
PREVENTION AND THE KIND OF THE
PRE FIRE AND AND MANAGEMENT OF
AND FOCUSING ON THE AREAS WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT THAT.
THE PEOPLE FIRST BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO LOOK AT THE HEALTH OF
THE FOREST AND THAT'S PART OF IT
YOU'VE BEEN FOCUSING SO FAR AND
WHAT [inaudible]
THE STATE.
AGENCIES WOULD DO AND I WONDER
IF WE SHOULDN'T BE LOOKING MORE.
AT WHAT WE SHOULD BE EXPECTING
FROM OUR PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND FROM POTENTIALLY OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHERS --
AND I SAY THAT AS REPRESENTATIVE%
OF THE AREA WHERE BEFORE.
THE TUBS AND CAMPFIRE HAD THE
WORST FIRE WITH THE MOST LOSS OF
STRUCTURES AND LYFT WHICH WAS
THE OAKLAND BERKELEY TUNNEL FIRE.
AND WE STILL HAVE A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE WE HAVE MANY PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO ARE NOT WE HAVE.
LAWS AND RULES EACH OF OUR
JURISDICTIONS.
THAT ARE IMPACTEDOF LAWS RULES
AROUND DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
AND BUILD OF OPPRESSION SUCH AND
YET.
IT IT'S YEAH EXACTLY TO THE IT
MAY BE BETTER THAN OTHER PLACES
I DON'T KNOW NOT FULLY.
NOT WHERE WE SHOULD BE.
AND OF COURSE.
WE ALLOWED FOR THE COMPLETE
REBUILT.
IN ALL THE AREAS THAT WERE WHERE
AND THAT FIRE WAS NOT THE FIRST
FIRE SO IT --
BUT I HAVE A TWO OTHER COMMENTS
ABOUT SOME MATERIAL THAT WAS IN
OUR DOCUMENTS BUT JUST ANY OTHER.
ANY FROM OUR PANELIST ON WHETHER
WE SHOULD BE PUTTING SOME MORE.
EXPECTATIONS ON TO ASSIST US.
YOU WANTED TO TAKE THE FIRST --
YES WELL I I'M JUST TO SAY I
LIKE I SAID I AGREE WITH YOU ON
THIS THIS HAS TO BE --
A WHOLE COMMUNITY APPROACH IT
IT'S NOT JUST A CAL FIRE ISSUE
RIGHT OR STATE ISSUE.
YOU KNOW WE PUSH OUT HAZARD
MITIGATION GRANTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS --
IN GENERAL AS AS A STATE IS YOUR
RISKIEST CALIFORNIA AS WE WE
NEED TO REINFORCE WHAT I CALL
CULTURE PREPAREDNESS THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE ACROSS ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT RIGHT.
AND AND IT SPEAKS TO WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AFTER THE OAKLAND
HILLS FIRE IF YOU DRIVE UP IN
THE SAME HILLS TODAY.
IT'S IT'S GOT A WEIRD TO THINK
THAT YOU WE WILL BE BACK AT THE
SAME PLACE YEAH PRETTY FIRE
AFTER A NINETY TWO PEOPLE SO I I
THINK THAT THAT.
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ALL YOU KNOW
JUST LIKE OUR SAYS CENTER STERN --
PUBLIC PRIVATE NON GOVERNMENTAL
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO SOLVE IT
TODAY.
IS WHAT.
ARE AGENCIES WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT IF THERE'S SOMETING THAT
WE NEED TO ENACT BECAUSE YES
IT'S A AND I DON'T MEAN THIS IS
NOT.
IS LOVELY TO SAY WE NEED THIS
WHOLE.
PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP
EVERYBODY ON BUT BUT WHAT IS IT
THAT WE NEED TO DO WHEN WE THE
DEFINITION OF CRAZINESS AS THEY
SAY IS TO CONTINUE TO DO THE
SAME THING THAT DOESN'T.
PRODUCE THE RESULTS SO.
ANY RECOMMENDATIONS AN INSIGHT
ON THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO US
AND THAT BRINGS UP MY NEXT POINT
WHICH IS WHEN I LOOK AT THIS
DOCUMENT.
WHERE WE ARE GIVEN?
THE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT.
FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY TO TWENTY TEN
DEVELOPMENT WITHIN OUR WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE GROUP 20%.
AND A COURSES I JUST START YOU
STATED EVEN IN MY AREA IT WAS
QUICKLY REBUILT.
BUT THEN ADDITIONALLY ON PAGE.
FOUR OF OUR DOCUMENTS IT SAYS
THAT ACCORDING TO A UCLA STUDY
AN ESTIMATED ONE MILLION NEW
HOMES ARE EXPECTED TO BE BUILT
IN THE HIGH RISK WILDFIRES ZONES
AND I'M SURE.
THAT THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THREE
PLACEMENT OF THE ONES WHO WERE
JUST BURKE BURN OUT.
AND I'M LIKE OKAY AT WHAT POINT
DO WE THAT.
WE MAY HAVE TO DO IT DIFFERENTLY.
AND THAT'S WITH EVERY BIT OF
COMPASSION TO FOLKS THAT.
HAVE YOU KNOW.
LOST THEIR LOST LOVED ONES LOST
PROPERTY LOSS IT'S JUST THAT WE
I MEAN IF WE LOOK FOR EXAMPLE
AND THE CAMPFIRE.
THERE ALREADY WAS REPORT THAT.
WHEN THE POPULATION THERE WAS?
WAS A THIRD OF WHAT IT HAD BEEN.
THAT THE THERE WAS ALREADY ALL
OF THE DATA TO SHOW THE DANGER
SIGNALS OF THE FACT THAT THERE
WAS ONLY ONE ROAD.
THROUGH THE AREA AND THE DANGER
SIGNALS NOT ONLY OF ACCESS FOR
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL BUT THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE.
IN THE EMERGENCY TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT.
SO I THINK WE WE HAVE.
TO WE CAN'T JUST BE IN REACTIVE
MODE WE'VE GOT TO PUT SOME
THINGS INTO PLACE. TO HELP
MINIMIZE THIS EXPOSURE COST AND
AND REAL CONSEQUENCES.
PEOPLE LOST LIVES.
A REAL RELATED TO A LOT OF THAT
IS LAND USE PLANNING --
AND IT'S IT'S WHAT WE CAN DO AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO HELP INFORM.
THE THE LOCALS AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY WE HAVE WE HAVE THIS
GROUP -- OUR
LAND USE PLANNING GROUP THAT IS
WORKING WITH ALL OF THE COUNTIES --
AND AND IT'S TAKEN SOME TIME BUT
THE ACCEPTANCE OF OF THAT GROUP
HAS HAS GROWN.
EXPONENTIALLY IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS FOR OBVIOUS REASONS.
AND WORKING WITH THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY IN REVIEWING OF OF THE
SAFETY ELEMENT.
OF OF GENERAL PLANS AS THE
GENERAL PLANS ARE BEING REVIEWED
AND UPDATED IS KEY TO THAT BUT
THEN ON THE RECOVERY.
THAT GETS BACK IT'S TEDIOUS AND
HANDED THERE IS OFTEN REQUESTS
FOR WAIVERS.
FROM SOME OF THESE VERY RULES
AND AND THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET INTO GENERAL PLANS.
THAT ARE THE BEST PRACTICES TO
SAVE PROPERTY --
ANY AND IT'S EIGHT IT DOES
INCREASE THE COST OF OF
REBUILDING AND SO.
THERE'S THERE'S A BALANCING ACT
THERE THAT THAT REALLY PLAYS OUT
AT A LOCAL LEVEL THAT THAT IS
PART OF THIS EQUATION AS WELL I
THINK.
WHEN THERE'S NO GUARANTEE WE
WOULD ENACT BUT I THINK IT'S
WORTH IT FOR US TO GET
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO WASTE
BECAUSE THIS THE IMPACT TO THE
STATE IS HUGE AND HAS?
STATE LAWMAKERS WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT -- MY
pFINAL QUESTION IN POINT IS
THERE'S REFERENCE IN OUR
DOCUMENTS AROUND THE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM.
AND I'M SURE WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT THAT MORE OTHER TIMES BUT
IN ADDITION TO OUR NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM BEING INADEQUATE.
OUR EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM WE
ENCOUNTERED IN ALL THE FIRES WAS
INADEQUATE AND THAT WE RELY
PRIMARILY ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
SOME OF WHOM USE --
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM SOME OF OR ARE
YOU KNOW MORE EFFECTIVE.
BUT I WAS IN CHILE IN NOVEMBER.
AND THEY USE A SYSTEM.
SIMILAR TO OUR AMBER ALERT WHERE
IT OVERRIDES CELL PHONES AND IT
IT.
BASICALLY ALERTS PEOPLE THROUGH
THEIR CELL PHONE WHETHER IT'S ON
OR OFF.
OF WHEN THERE IS AN EMERGENCY IN
THEIR AREA AND AND WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO WHETHER THEY NEED TO
EVACUATE STAND PLACE OR WHAT
HAVE YOU.
AND I WONDERED IF THE STATED
CONSIDERED.
DEVELOPING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AND WE HAVE THE AMBER ALERT.
TECHNOLOGY ALREADY IT ALREADY
EXISTS WE ALL GET THOSE.
WHY WE COULDN'T DO STATEWIDE?
EMERGENCY ALERTS IN A SIMILAR
FASHION.
SO -- YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT --
SOME WEEKS --
AMBER ALERTS ON A IS IS THE SAME
SYSTEM THAT WE ARE PROPOSING IN
THE GUIDELINES --
THAT ALL JURISDICTIONS IN THE
STATE.
UTILIZED --
IT'S CALLED WE AS THE WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM --
IT IS A FEDERAL SYSTEM DEVELOPED
AND AND AND STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
PLUG INTOTHAT SYSTEM --
IS CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AND AND
GET BETTER --
EVEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRES --
AND AND IT IS THE SIX SYSTEM
THAT THEY WILL DO MATTER WHERE
YOU ARE IF YOU'RE TRAVELING FOR
NOT FROM THE AREA BUT YOU'RE
TRAVELING THROUGH.
ITS BASED UPON OUT OF A POLY
GONE THEY THEY THE GEO FENCE IN
THE AREA AND THEN THEY'LL PUSH
OUT A MESSAGE.
OF WHAT WE WANT STILL LOW IS
BECAUSE EVENTS ARE HAPPENING.
IMMEDIATELY WE WE WANT
AUTHORITIES TO MAIN IN THAT
LEADERSHIP ROLE OF BEING ABLE TO
PUT THOSE.
ALERTS AND WARNINGS OUT OF THE
STATE IS HERE AS A AS A BACK UP
BUT THIS IS REALLY LOCAL WHAT
THE HOW AMBER ALERT WORKS TOO
WELL AMBLER TO LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE IT'S A
CENTRAL LOCATION --
THAT'S RUN BY THE HIGHWAY PATROL
AND THE HIGHER PATROL COP OUR
VIRTUAL --
OKAY PUT THAT OUT SEE WHY TO ALL
ITS DIVISIONS AND ACROSS THE
BOARD ON THIS IS AND BECAUSE YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE WHEN THEY DO --
KIDNAPPINGS ARE THEY'RE MOVING
SOMEBODY ACROSS THE STATE --
IT'S IT'S IT WORKS BETTER IN
THAT FASHION THIS ONE IS MORE
DESIGNED FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IMMEDIATELY ACTIVE SHOOTER FAST
MOVING WILDFIRE HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS INCIDENTS --
AND IT IS --
IT IS BUILT INTO THE NEW
RELEASED THIS THIS NEXT WEEK.
YOU'LL LET US KNOW IF IT NEEDS
ANY KIND OF STATE.
ACTION MORE WE'RE GONNA CAM
WHERE WE WILL COME BACK TO YOU
ON THAT FOR SURE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
Q. AND SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH RENDON CHAIR
UNETHICAL RAPID FIRE MANAGER
THAT WORKS FOR YOU --
MARCH THIRTEENTH THERE'S GONNA
BE JOINTLY JUST HAD A MEETING
WITH DODD IN FIVE ALONG WITH
NATURAL RESOURCES IN TERMS STERN
ON ALL ISSUES OF BUILDING WITHIN
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE --
IN LOOKING AT NEW STANDARDS AND
THEN WILL BE PROVIDING --
THAT WITH THE WILL BE THE WILD
URBAN IN ON WHICH WE HIV
GOVERNMENT IN.
THANK YOU GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE --
AS WELL CENTER RESOURCES MARCH
THIRTEENTH ON AND I THINK THAT
AS CENTER STIR AND SKINNY CENTER
SKINNER BRINGS UP SOME REALLY
GOOD POINTS --
ON THAT ISSUE SO --
WERE IN THE FOCUSING ON THAT
SENATE BILL --
EIGHT THREE THREE WHICH HAS BEEN
FOCUSED RECEIVE ALERTS VIA SB
EIGHT THREE THREE WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED --
TRADITIONAL LAND LINES --
ON ALERT TO YOUR CELL PHONE ON
ANY.
NGUYEN IMPORTANT PIECES IS NO
LONGER AN OFTEN IT'S AN OPT OUT
SYSTEM --
THROUGH EMERGENCY BROADCAST
RADIO TELEVISION TELEVISION AND
STATE HIGHWAY ELECTRONIC
BILLBOARDS TO THERE'S GONNA BE
FOR AND MEDIANS MEDIUMS THAT
WILL BE --
THOSE ALERTS WE DISTRIBUTED ON
ONE AGAIN SAY THANK YOU TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND OF
COURSE TO THE GOVERNOR AND CAL
FIRE FOR RECOMMENDING THIRTEEN
ENGINES.
THAT ARE IN --
IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR OUT WITH
CAL FIRE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT --
WHERE THE LA I WAS FOCUSING IS A
LONG TERM PLAN BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO BOTH FIRE PREVENTION AS WELL
AS FIRE RESPONSE I LOOK I THINK
THAT MAKES SENSE?
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS --
AND I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THAT THE CHIEF'S COMMENTS ON
THIS AS WELL.
WE HAVE YET. TO GET BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE IN --
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AS FAR AS
THE THE LEVEL THE ENGINES IN THE
STATE.
AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT FIRE FIGHT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT PTSD OF
FIREFIGHTERS YOU TALK DIRECTLY
WITH.
THOSE WHO ARE IN THE RANKS OF
CALIFORNIA --
THERE ARE OUT ON STRESS THEIR
OUT AN INJURY --
BOTH EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL.
IN THE BEST WAY TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THAT IS TO BE ABLE TO
GET THEIR RANKS UP TO WHERE WE
WERE IN THE SEVENTIES --
AND THAT IS WHY WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE TO THAT THIRTY ONE
NUMBER.
I'M ALSO REALISTIC AND I AND I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS
AND WILL LOOK TO THE CHIEF ON
THIS I ALSO KNOW --
FOR WILL SOON WE CAN'T DO IT ALL
IN ONE YEAR.
MEANING A TAKES.
X. AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE ABLE TO
GET A NEW ENGINE I'D TO BE ABLE
TO STAFF UP --
IN SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE I THINK
WE NEED TO BE A TO SEE A PLAN
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY FOUR TO
THIRTY SIX MONTHS. TO MINIMUM TO
BE ABLE TO GET TO THAT NUMBER OF
THIRTY ONE THE LARGEST MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLIEST
WILDFIRES IN THE STATE HAVE BEEN
TAKING PLACE SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND IS
UNACCEPTABLE THAT WE CAN'T GET
BACK UP THROUGH THE RANKS AND
THE LEVEL OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE SOME ACCEPTABLE --
AND I DO WANNA COMPLEMENT THOUGH --
WHERE THE GOVERNOR HAS BEEN AS
FAR AS MOVING US TOWARDS THAT
ONE A COMMON GOVERNOR BROWN AS
WELL?
AND WE NEED TO BE A GO FOR THIS
YEAR.
FROM OUR NUMBERS FROM LAST
YEAR'S DISCUSSION IT'S GONNA
MEAN EIGHTY FOUR TO EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION ONE TIME THAT'S TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE THE ENGINES AND
AND TO BE ABLE --
TO HIRE THE STAFF ON GOING IT'S
GOING TO BE ABOUT SIXTY TO SIXTY
FIVE MILLION BUT THOSE ARE ALL
THOSE ARE THOSE NUMBERS ARE
TWELVE MONTHS OLD.
BUT I THINK THEY'RE STILL PRETTY
ACCURATE.
IN GETTING BACK TO WHERE
DIRECTOR DUTY AND MENTION
REGARDS TO THE ISSUE OF THE 85%
OF THOSE WERE COMING FROM MUTUAL
AID. TO THE NORTH A FIRESTORM
THREE HUNDRED FIRE ENGINES WERE
REQUESTED IN THE FIRST TWELVE
HOURS OF THE INCIDENT.
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY ARRIVED.
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS THE GOLD STANDARD
IN THE STATE AND WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS STRESSED --
AND WE SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
BOOTS ON THE GROUND ERROR
EQUIPMENT.
I'M IT SO WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THE LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL --
WE'LL JUST TAKE DOWN HERE MADAM
CHAIR AND THEN ALSO IF IT'S OKAY
VENTURE HAVE THAT THE CHIEF OF
RESPOND INDOOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
DO WANT TO SAY AGAIN THANK YOU
TO THE GOVERNOR FOR PUTTING THAT
SIX POINT SIX APPROXIMATELY AND
BE ON THE FOCUS ON MENTAL HEALTH
FOR THOSE FIREFIGHTERS AND IF WE
NEED TO BETTER GO FURTHER AS WE
GET I JUST MENTIONED.
IN REGARDS TO THAT FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME --
ON RESEARCH FOCUS ON FIRE
FIGHTER HEALTH ON THE LONG TERM
EXPOSURE FOR SMOKERS WELLS --
TOXIC CONDITIONS.
THE OTHER ITEM THAT WAS
DISCUSSED LAST YEAR AND I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO BE A FOLLOW UP
WITH --
GOVERNOR BROWN A IN HIS WISDOM
STARTED OUTFITTING EACH CAL FIRE
RATE WITH --
TRANSPONDERS TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE EACH TREE
GAZING ANYONE TIME --
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE THE
ALWAYS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THOSE FIRE ENGINES THAT ARE
RESPONDING TO A LARGE --
WHILE THEN FIRE IN SOONER COMING
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SO JUST LIKE WE HAD A CHALLENGE
WITH THE POLLY KLAAS CASE WHERE --
LAW ENFORCEMENT WERE ON
DIFFERENT CHANNELS AND I KNOW
UNABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER I LOOK AT THIS THIS IS
VERY SIMILAR ISSUE WE HAVE CAL
FIRE WHO WAS ON ONE SYSTEM.
BUT WE DON'T WE ARE TRACKING
WHERE THOSE COMING IN FROM
AROUND THE STATE I THINK WE NEED
TO START MOVING.
TOWARDS THAT --
WITH THOSE ENGINES AT LOCAL GUY
AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL.
NINE ONE ONE IS A ANTIQUATED
SYSTEM IN THE STATE IS
ANTIQUATED WE'VE SEEN CHALLENGES --
WITH.
WE SAW CHALLENGES AND CINNAMON
CARRIES WE SUCH CHALLENGES IN --
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S TIME
TO RIP THE BANDAID OFF AND
FINALLY START INVESTING I
APPRECIATE THE THE FIRST YEAR
FUNDING. TO BE ABLE TO GET THIS
STARTED BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO HAVE A DIFFICULT CONVERSATION
BOTH DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
HAVE.
FULLY FUNDING THE MODERNIZATION
IN.
NINE ONE ONE TIME.
WE DO TRY LAST YEAR BY IN TRIED
TO THE VERY LAST YOU A FEW HOURS
OF A SESSION TO BE A TO GET IT
DONE.
AND THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE --
AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS
IN ON THAT.
THE LAST ITEM --
WILL SAY.
IN I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON AB SEVENTY THREE NAY
BE SEVENTY TWO NEXT WEEK --
BUT JUST AS A LITTLE BIT OF A
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT WHICH IS
COMING BACK --
UNDER -- THE
BILL.
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION NEXT WEEK IN
REGARDS TO WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION IS VERY BROAD OF
IMMEDIATE POTENTIAL HAZARD AND
THE REASON I BRING THAT UP IS.
ESPECIALLY AFTER A WHILE IN FIRE
WERE SEEN THIS --
IN CINEMA MEDINA LAKE IN NAPA A
RUSSIAN DEBRIS WERE AT DEBRIS
PHONE FLASH FLOODING IN IS THAT --
AS PART OF THE DEFINITION I KNOW
WE DON'T NEED --
THE ANSWER HERE TODAY BUT THAT
IS ITEM WOULD LIKE TO BE A FLAG
FOR NEXT WEEK THANK YOU SO MUCH
BEEN CHAIR IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH
THAT WOULD YOU PLEASE.
OKAY -- AND
I I WILL I WILL TALK TO THE
NUMBERS AND TO THE TRAINING AND
THE AND THE DEPLOYMENT TIMELINE --
THE ITEMS --
THAT YOU SENATOR BROUGHT UP
RELATED TO THE ENGINES --
FIRST ONE POINT OF CLARIFICATION
JUST STATE I'M IN A I'M A
REITERATE SOMETHING MY
PREDECESSOR.
HAS ALSO STATED.
ON THE RECORD AND TRUE --
FROM.
FROM OUR RECORDS --
IT WE ARE A THIRTY THIRTY ONE
ENGINES SHORTER.
IN OUR INVENTORY THAN WE WERE --
THEN AND NOW.
AND PART OF THAT IS IN THE IN
THE INTERCEDING TIME --
IN THIS IN THE LATE SEVENTIES
THE ORANGE COUNTY WENT AWAY --
TO A CONTRACT COUNTY AND EIGHT
OF THOSE ENGINES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY STATE.
FUNDED ENGINES ARE STILL STATE
FUNDED ENGINES BUT THEY'RE IN A
CONTRACT COUNTY SO THAT BRINGS
THE NUMBER TWO TWO AT TWENTY
THREE NUMBER.
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH NOW
WHAT I'VE SAID --
AND AND I I I BELIEVE --
AS MISTRAL ME SAID IS THAT IS A
NO REGRETS STARTING POINT WE'VE
WE'VE BEEN CLEAR TO THAT --
I AM VERY COMFORTABLE SAYING
THAT WE NEED MORE THAN THAT AND
AND I'M VERY COMFORTABLE SAYING
THAT.
THAT -- WE
NEED TO GET BACK TO AT LEAST
WHERE WE WERE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND PROBABLY BEYOND
WHERE WE WERE IN. NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO IN END USER OLD
NUMBERS AND CHIEF IF YOU DON'T
MIND JUST CHIME IN ON THIS SO
RIGHT NOW I THINK IT PEAK.
OF THESE ARE MY NOTES FROM LAST
YEAR YOU HAVE APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
SEASONAL AS WELL AS FULL TIME
ENGINES ACROSS THE STATE IS THAT
STILL GOOD ENOUGH.
SO WHAT IS THAT IDEAL NUMBERED
ENGINES THAT YOU'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU CAN DIFFERENTIATE STAFFING
AS FAR AS FULL TIME VERSUS
SEASONAL BUT WHAT IS THAT NUMBER.
YEAH I I CAN'T I CAN'T SPLIT
THAT OUT AND THAT CAN BE PART OF
OUR STRATEGIC PLANNING PROCESS
THAT I WAS --
COVERING PREVIOUSLY --
I AM COMFORTABLE SAYING THAT
IT'S GOING TO COME TO OR IT OR
EXCEED THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
LEVEL -- WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY THOUSAND
ACRES -- FOR
EACH ENGINE --
ACROSS THE STATE THEM THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF THE THE ROUGH
NUMBER --
THAT EACH ENGINE IS PRETTY
PROTECTING AND AND IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S VARIABLE OF COURSE BUT
IF YOU IF YOU LOOK AT IT ACROSS
THE STATE THAT'S ABOUT WHAT IT
IS.
AND THAT'S A LOT OF GROUND FOR
EACH ENGINE.
AND WE ARE THROUGH OUR
ASSESSMENT --
ARE GOING TO DETERMINE WHERE WE
NEED ADDITIONAL --
AND WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE MIGHT BE
NEEDED -- TO
TO HOUSE THOSE --
AS FAR AS DEPLOYMENT --
IF WE WERE --
TO LOOK AT THIRTY ONE ADDITIONAL
ENGINES THAT WOULD. THIRTEEN OF
THOSE WOULD BE INCLUDED IN THAT --
THIRTY ONE THAT'S APPROXIMATELY
AN ADDITIONAL. THIRTY WEEKS OF
OF TRAINING THAT WE WOULD NEED
FOR THE STAFF THAT WOULD BE THE
COMPANY OFFICERS ON ON THAT THE
THE PERMANENT STAFF.
AND THAT'S THIRTY THIRTY WEEKS
THAT WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE --
ALLOCATED OUR IN OUR CALENDAR
CALENDARS FULL OF A WITH
TRAINING NEEDS WE COULD DIVERT
AND AND CHANGE SOME OF OUR SO WE
COULD PROBABLY REDUCE THE WOULD
NEED SOME SOME --
TRAINING --
COMPONENTS --
IT IN THAT.
PROBABLY LIMITED TERM POSITIONS
TO DO THAT BUT WITHIN THE TWENTY
FOUR AND THIRTY SIX I CAN GIVE
YOU OF THAT MORE SPECIFICALLY
BUT I I'M SURE WE COULD MEET
THAT TIME FRAME --
TO EITHER PROBABLY THE THIRTY
SIX FOR CERTAIN AND TWENTY FOUR
IS LIKELY --
AND THEN THE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
ASKED FOR COMMENT BUT I WANTED
TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING THE THE THE CONCEPT
THAT WE'RE GOING FORWARD ON THE
THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
EMPLOYEES --
WE WE HAVE EMPLOYEES THAT IT
THAT DO --
THEY DO A MISSION THAT THAT FEW
DO AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ARE
ABSOLUTELY A HUGE HELP IN OUR
SYSTEM.
BUT THEY DON'T STAY OUT FOR
FORTY FIVE DAYS --
TYPICALLY IF THEY RE THEY ROTATE
IN AND OUT.
AND THAT'S PART OF OUR OUR
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PROGRAM
ADDRESSING THAT AND IT ENSURING
THAT WE ARE TAKING CARE OF OF
WHAT ARE.
OUR DIFFERENT FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHIEF AND LOOK
AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS --
WE ARE ALL GRATEFUL FOR THE THE
PREVIOUS LEADERSHIP OF GOVERNOR
BROWN --
YOUR PREDECESSOR AT YOU CAN LIVE
IN VERY GRATEFUL --
NEESON YOURSELF HAVE HAVE
ADVANCED THIS BUDGET --
IN THIS IS NOT AT ALL TRYING TO
THROW STONES TO BE ABLE TO GET
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE AND WHERE
WE NEED TO BE --
AS WE CONFRONT WHAT IS IN FRONT
OF US NOW.
IN IT'S CLEAR THAT WE NEED
ENHANCE RESOURCES APPOINTMENT.
PERSONNEL AS WELL AS TECHNOLOGY
TO BE A TO COMBAT THE REALITY
THAT IS HERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SO --
WOULD LOVE IT WORKING OBVIOUSLY
WITH THE BUDGET SUB CHAIR AND
MADAM CHAIR HERE WITH BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
ON JUST GETTING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING.
OF WHAT.
IF THOSE NUMBERS THAT I HAD
MENTIONED ARE STILL ACCURATE I
DON'T NEED HIM NOWAND THEN THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS HOW
LONG DOES IT TAKE. FOR AVERAGE
ENGINE TO BE OUTFITTED.
SO FROM START TO ACTUALLY ON THE
STREET IS HOW LONG TWELVE MONTHS
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
IT'S PROBABLY IT'S THE A A THIRD
THERE'S ANOTHER IT'S COMPLICATED --
WITH OUR WITH OUR PROCUREMENT
PROCESS SOMETIMES THAT DELAYS
THINGS -- IT
IN ORDER TO GET INTO A CONTRACT
PERIOD WHERE WE CAN FOR
SKATEBOARDER THE ENGINE SO ONCE
THE ORDER AND ONCE THE ENGINES
ORDERED --
WE CAN HAVE IT ON THE GROUND --
DEPENDING ON AND OUTFITTED --
THE THE OTHER PIECE OF THAT IS --
IF WE'RE ORDERING A LOT OF
ENGINES A BIG NUMBER THEN IT
GETS STAGGERED OUT INTO.
BUT EACH ONE FROM ONE ENGINE
START TO FINISH WE WOULD EASILY
HAVE IT.
ON THE GROUND --
OPERATIONAL WITHIN A YEAR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE PUT ANY ITEMS IN TURN
FINANCING ATTACHMENT.
THANK YOU --
SO.
I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT I GUESS
TO RECOGNIZE IT I'VE KIND OF
THREE POINTS ONE IS.
ITS.
THE FOCUS ON THE ENGINES IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND IT'S ONE ELEMENT AS
PART OF A CONFERENCE OF HOLISTIC
PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS.
SO IT'S ALSO FAIR TO SAY THAT --
WE DIDN'T HAVE --
A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY STATE OF
THE ART HELICOPTERS --
THEY COULD FLY YOU AT NIGHT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE BUT WERE
PROPOSING TO CONTINUE THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE --
SEVENS.
SEE ONE THIRTY FEDERAL OF AIR
TANKERS TWENTY FIRST.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE DIDN'T
HAVE -- A
FIRE DETECTION CAMERAS THAT ARE
NOW CAN BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY TECHNOLOGY --
IT TO BETTER ASSIST --
FIRE DETECTION IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE EITHER SO.
ARE ARE THINKING IN THIS PACKAGE.
IS.
IS IT MORE LOOKING FORWARD --
TO S. T. PORTER MENTION IN THE
STRATEGIC PLANNING PROCESS.
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS FORWARD AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT CAL FIRE IS
EQUIPPED.
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY WITH --
WITH.
A STATE OF THE ART UPDATED --
CAPABILITIES THAT INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL ENGINES TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL CREWS AS WELL AND SO
WE THINK THAT GIVEN THE LIMITED
RESOURCES.
THAT THE PACKAGE THAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU IS THE MOST --
STRATEGIC.
ASSET ALLOCATION SO TO SPEAK
BETWEEN AVIATION RESOURCES
BETWEEN TECHNOLOGY BETWEEN
ENGINES --
TO PUT THE STATE IN A FORWARD --
IN THE MEANTIME.
CAL FIRE WILL BE DOING THIS LONG
TERM STRATEGIC PLAN LOOK HIM
WILL BE COMING BACK IN AND
TALKING ABOUT THOSE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
I'D ALSO SAY THAT.
AS THE MET MADAM CHAIR MENTIONED
IN THE BEGINNING.
OF NEXT WEEK YOU'LL BE THERE IN
THE COMING WEEK SHOULD BE TALK
ABOUT BUDGET RESILIENCY --
PART OF IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
STAND IN THIS IS PART OF A
LARGER PACKAGE OF THE BUDGET.
AND AS PART OF THE LARGER --
BUDGET ARCHITECTURE OF THE
BUDGET -- OF
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SENSITIVE
TO MAKING SURE THAT WERE --
FISCALLY PRUDENT IN TERMS OF ON
GOING GENERAL FUND.
AND SO -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS PACKAGE NON
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE IT HAS SUCH
A GOOD RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
IN TERMS OF OF DEALING WITH
THESE RISKS BUT WE WANT TO BE
SENSITIVE TO THE FACT THAT --
OF THE ONE OF A KIND OF CORE
PRINCIPLES OF BUDGET RESILIENCY
IS IS THAT WE DON'T KNOW --
HAVE ONGOING GENERAL FUND
RESEARCH IS THAT WHEN THE WHEN
THERE'S A SHORTFALL WE JUST TAKE
IT ALL BACK.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS
THESE THIRTEEN ENGINES.
CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED IN THE
LONG TERM --
BECAUSE THERE'S TO STRATEGICALLY
IMPORTANT --
AND I HAVE A BUDGET THAT IS ABLE
TO MAKE THESE COMMITMENTS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS SO WILL WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS BUT THAT'S KIND OF
HOW WE WERE THINKING ABOUT IT IN
TERMS OF PUTTING.
THIS UP PACKAGE BEFORE YOU.
AN INTERVIEW THIS RESPONDENT
I'LL BE BRIEF LOOK --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS AND I'VE ONLY
BEEN HERE FOR YEARS START MY
FIFTH.
A YEAH BEEN SPECTACULAR TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH IN REGARDS TO
THE FIRES THATWE'VE HAD.
A KEY THE BUZZER --
IN THE PRIOR TO HER JERRY CROW
FOOT -- WAS
NOTHING SHORT OF AMAZING --
AND I HOPE YOU DON'T TAKE MY
WORDS AS BEING CRITICAL BUT
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IN THE AREA
THAT I REPRESENT NEARLY EIGHT
THOUSAND HOMES HAVE BEEN LOST.
AND I HAVE BEEN --
INITIALLY A BIT OBSESSED WITH
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE KEEPING
OUR COMMUNITY SAY.
SO WHAT I WILL SAY IS INVESTING
SIXTY MILLION PER YEAR TO BE
ABLE TO GET BACK TO MADE SEVENTY
LEVELS WHEN IT COMES TO CAL FIRE
FIRE ENGINES.
IS A LOT LESS THAN HAVING IS
BEING TWELVE BILLION PER YEAR
UNINSURED LOSSES.
THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET THAT'S
GOING TO GET US OUT OF THIS
REALITY THAT WERE IN IT'S GONNA
TAKE ENHANCE FIRE PREVENTION
WHICH IS WHY THIS LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR
ADVANCE TO BILLION DOLLARS.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT IN THE
SEVENTIES AND AT THE SAME TIME
THOUGH LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
BLACKHAWKS WE ALREADY IN UP
TWELVE WE'RE GOING TO BE GETTING
TO THIS YEAR.
WE HAVE VIGT NAM THEIR
HELICOPTERS THAT ARE STILL
FLYING IN THE SKY.
WE TALK ABOUT THE C. ONE
THIRTIES WE'RE GONNA BE GETTING
ONE MAYBE THREE YEAR --
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OVER
A SERIES OF YEARS SO.
I DON'T NEED A STRATEGIC PLAN TO
BE ABLE TO KNOW WE ARE LOWER
THAN WE SHOULD BE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE NUMBER OF ENGINES THAT
NEED TO BE ON THE ROAD IN THIS
STATE PROTECTING STRUCTURES IN
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
IN SO -- WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING REALLY WELL
TOGETHER NOTHING CRITICAL ABOUT
WHAT I HOPE MY WORDS HAVE COME
OFF TODAY AND FROM TO FINANCE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ALL BEEN
SPECTACULAR TO BE TO WORK WITH.
GOVERNOR BROWN WAS SPECTACULAR
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS ALL OVER IT
AND HE'S MAKING PHONE CALLS AND
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING WHAT WE NEED AND
WHAT I'LL SAY IS.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
IN ALL DESCENDED THEIR AND KNOW
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
GREATER CONVERSATION.
SHAKE THAT SILVER MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SOME.
I THINK THE OTHER AGENCIES I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
SPECIFICALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
FOR THE CONTINUED PRIORITIZATION
OF FINDING THAT RIGHT BALANCE
WITHIN OUR BUDGET.
CONSTRAINTS.
I HAVE A THE SPECIFIC QUESTION
RELATED TO NINE ONE ONE
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
WITH FIRE EVENTS WE HEAR A LOT
ABOUT TRYING TO IMPROVE THE
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE ALERTING
RESIDENTS OF A PENDING.
DISASTER OR THREAT TO THEM.
BUT WE ALSO RELY ON NINE ONE ONE
TO REPORT THE FIRST DICE TO SEE.
A POTENTIAL FIRE IN WITH THE CAL
FIRE STRATEGY OF MASSIVE EARLY
RESPONSE.
GETTING THE EARLY NOTICES
CRITICAL.
TO WE LEARNED THROUGH A TRAGEDY
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO IN THE BIG
SUR COAST.
IN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE WHO DIED IN A BLOW A
HOLE IN THE ROCK SEGERA PADA
BEACH [inaudible]
HIS FRIENDS.
DIALED.
NINE ONE ONE BUT WERE NOT HONEST
SERVICE OF ANOTHER PROVIDER THAT
HAD CELL SERVICE IN THAT AREA.
SO ALL JUST USE NAMES THEY WERE
ON VERIZON.
THAT DIDN'T CONNECT THEM.
TO NINE ONE ONE THERE WAS AN
EIGHTEEN T. SERVICE PROVIDER
THAT IF THEY'D HAD EIGHTEEN T.
SERVICE.
THEY COULD HAVE CONNECTED
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS GOT THERE.
THE YOUNG MAN'S LIFE WAS LOST I
DON'T KNOW FOR EARLIER RESPONSE
WOULD HAVE CHANGED THE OUTCOME
BUT IT BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION.
A GAP THINK IN IT SEEMS LIKE
ANYONE WHO DIALS.
911- REGARDLESS OF THEIR CELL
PROVIDER.
IF THERE'S A CELL TOWER THAT
RECEIVES THAT MESSAGE.
HEAVY ARE YOU AWARE OF THIS
SITUATION OF IT.
A NON CONNECTING COULD THERE BE.
A RESPONSE OF THE PROVIDERS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
THE WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE A
PLAN WITH THEM IF YOU DIAL 911-
IN THE HEAR YOUR SIGNAL THEY CAN
RELAY AT TO A NINE ONE ONE
OPERATOR.
SURROUNDING A I DON'T KNOW OF
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE ENOUGH TO
LOOK INTO IT --
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT YOU
KNOW TYPICALLY WHEN WHEN IF.
IT'S A GNOSTIC THERE IS A
CAPABILITY IF YOU'RE ON ONE
CARRIER THAT'LL IT'LL BE CLOSE
TO A SITE AND THEN IT GOES AND I
ONCE SYSTEM.
THAT SAID THERE'S PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT ARE THAT ARE VERY
VERY --
SKETCHY I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
WITH WEEK ABILITY TO TO MOVE THE
SIGNAL AT ITS INFRASTRUCTURE THE
COASTLINE BEING ONE OF THEM --
FURTHER NORTH YOU GO IT BECOMES
MORE SKETCHY --
GETS INTO MY MY POINT EARLIER
ABOUT RESILIENCY BUT I ALSO WILL
TELL YOU THAT THE UPGRADE OF THE
NINE ONE SYSTEM WHICH WAS.
FUNDED AND AND BUILT IN THE
SEVENTIES MCKAY --
THE NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM
THAT WE ARE WORKING ON AND
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT NEED TO
BE BUILT OUT.
ADDRESSES MORE OF THAT HELPS TO
BUILD AN AND FILL THOSE GAPS
THAT.
THAT EXIST --
BY USING DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES --
TO BE ABLE TO SENSE OF TEXT TO
THE NINE ONE ONE WHEN YOU CAN'T
GET A SIGNAL WHAT YOU CAN GET A
TAX THEY WORK ON DIFFERENT
PLATFORMS --
THE ABILITY --
TO TO A BETTER POSITION OR
IDENTIFY THE LOCATION OF THE
CALLER.
AND BE ABLE TO GET RESOURCES
THERE FASTER RELIABILITY IN THE
CALLING --
AND HOW THEY DO THAT ALL OF
THESE THINGS AND MANY MORE COME
WITH --
GOING FROM AN ANALOG --
BACKACHE SYSTEM TO SEE STATE OF
THE ART AND AND MOVING THIS FOR
SO IT'S VERY CRITICAL THAT WE WE
MOVE FOR WITH THAT NINE ONE
PLEASE I REALIZE THERE.
OF OF OUR SEVENTY MILES OF BIG
SUR COASTLINE THERE'S ONLY ABOUT
FIVE MILES THAT HAVE CELL
CONNECTIVITY THROUGHOUT THAT
STRETCH.
THERE ARE SOME NINE ONE ONE CALL
BOXES IN THOSE SO I THINK WE
NEED.
TO KEEP ACTIVE EVEN THOUGH THEY
SEEM MAYBE ANTIQUATED BUT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A CELL PHONE
CONNECTION.
A CALL BOX IS THE NEXT BEST
THING.
BUT IF YOU COULD EXPLORE THAT
QUESTION OF ONLY BEING ABLE TO
CONNECT WITH NINE ONE ONE WITH
YOUR SERVICE PROVIDER WHEN THERE
COULD BE ANOTHER CELL TOWER THAT
COULD HEAR THAT.
MESSAGE --
I'D APPRECIATE WILL I WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN THAT SPECIFIC I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
VERY MUCH --
SENATOR MONTAIGNE'S [inaudible]
AND SHE ORDER --
THE EDGES WERE TECHNOLOGY I
APPRECIATE ALL THE QUESTIONS YOU
ANSWERED AND MY THE NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE THAT SERVE ON SUB TO
IN IN YOUR COMMENT THAT YOU
WOULD BE.
GETTING BACK TO US WITH FUTURE
ANSWERS I'M I'M SURE YOU CAN
FULLY EXPECT THAT SUB TO
HEARINGS WILL BE THE PLACE WILL
EXPECT. TO GET MOST OF THAT
INFORMATION --
ANSWERS I HOPE HAT YOU'LL BE
READY AND PREPARED TO GIVE IT TO
US.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
LET'S MOVE NOW INTO OUR THIRD
AND FINAL.
PANEL FOR TODAY THE THIRD PANEL
IS DISASTER READINESS PROPOSALS
MANAGER IS A POSSIBLE GIVING A
QUICK BY BREAK.
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S A BIT LIKE
THREE OURSELVES YOU KNOW I'M IT
IS.
AND YOU KNOW I'M WITH YOU ON
THAT MUSICAL RIGHT HERE.
A RIGHTS.
I SHOULD OF ALPHA.
WHY DON'T WE TAKE A?
FEW MINUTE POSSUM WHEN I SEE THE
PARTIES ARE BACK IN WILL.
RECONVENE
.
WILL FIRST HEAR FROM.
JOSH GO VERY SINCE THE PROGRAM
BUDGET MANAGER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WILL AGAIN HEAR FROM --
HELEN KIRSTEN WITH THE LA JOH.
AND AGAIN THE SECURITY CHIEF
FROM THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FORGET IT
GETS STARTED.
THANK YOU JOSH TARGET APARTMENT
FINANCE SO --
IDEN GOING TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER --
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
PREPAREDNESS PROPOSALS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET --
PERHAPS THE CURSE OF BEING ON
THE FINAL PANEL IS A MY COMMENTS
WERE MAINLY GOING TO CIRCLE
AROUND NINE ONE ONE WHICH IS
CLEARLY BEEN A TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION MULTIPLE TIMES SO.
I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF AS I GO
THROUGH THAT --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
RESOURCES FOR THE CONTINUED
ROLLOUT OF THE NEXT GENERATION
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM CONSISTENT
WITH PROPOSALS THAT WERE
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET --
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM IS OUTDATED USES OLD
TECHNOLOGY AND IS PRONE TO
OUTAGES DURING MAJOR DISASTERS.
AND PROPS TO SENATOR NIELSEN'S
CONCERNS AND TRYING TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT PICTURE ABOUT WHAT
THE UPGRADE TO THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM ACTUALLY INCLUDES A MAJOR
COMPONENT OF THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM IS THE MICROWAVE NETWORK
WHICH IS ALSO.
RECEIVED --
SOME ATTENTION HERE TODAY A
CALIFORNIA HAS AN ANTIQUATED
ANALOG MICROWAVE NETWORK THAT
MUST BE UPGRADED TO A DIGITAL
NETWORKS SO THAT ALTERNATE
CONNECTION IS AVAILABLE TO RE
ROUTE CALLS TO OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE.
WHEN THE DISPATCH CENTER IS
DAMAGED EVACUATED OR OVERWHELMED
CURRENTLY A DISPATCH CENTER IS --
GENERALLY LEADING TO BE A SINGLE
CONNECTION THAT TYPICALLY NOT
HARDENED AND CANNOT SURVIVE A
DISASTER WHEN THE DISASTER
OCCURS THE INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE
DAMAGE TO THE POINT WHERE CALLS
CANNOT BE ANSWERED AND OR RE
ROUTED.
AT OR SENT TO A ANOTHER DISPATCH
CENTER DISPATCH CENTERS --
TYPICALLY HAVE A SINGLE BACKUP
DISPATCH CENTER IN A NEIGHBORING
CITY OR COUNTY.
DURING AN EVACUATION OR HEAVY
CALL VOLUME THOUGH HOWEVER CALLS
491-1 SERVICE CAN BE RE ROUTED
TO ONLY THE SINGLE ALTERNATE
DISPATCH CENTER WHEN BOTH
DISPATCH CENTERS NEED TO BE
EVACUATED. NINE ONE ONE CALLS
AGAIN CAN BE --
CANNOT BE RE ROUTED --
UNLESS ALTERNATE CIRCUITS ARE
MANUALLY RE ROUTED WHICH IS A
PROCESS THAT CAN TAKE TWELVE TO
TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
WITH NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE
ONE AND THE NEW DIGITAL
MICROWAVE NETWORK CALLS TO ANY
DISPATCH CENTER CAN BE RE ROUTED
TO ANY OTHER LOCATION IN THE
STATE PROVIDING A HARDENED.
REDUNDANT SYSTEM THAT IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE SCOPE OF
DISASTERS CALIFORNIA HAS FACED
IN RECENT HISTORY --
ADDITIONALLY ALL JUST HIGHLIGHT.
TWO OR THREE OTHER FEATURES OF
THE NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM THAT IF I BELIEVE ALL
ALSO BEEN MENTIONED ALREADY HAD
THROUGHOUT TODAY'S DISCUSSION --
IT WILL DELIVER INCREASED
LOCATION ACCURACY FOR WIRELESS
CALLS WILL PROVIDE STATEWIDE
COMMON DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
ALERTS AND WARNINGS IT WILL
ALLOW AGENCIES TO UTILIZE STATE
OF THE ART MAPPING IN ORDER TO
BETTER LOCATE CALLERS --
AND IT WILL ALSO INTEGRATE WITH
THE FIRST RESPONDER NETWORK
AUTHORITIES NATIONWIDE WIRELESS
BROADBAND NETWORK INITIATIVE
KNOWN AS FIRST MET THE
CALIFORNIA OPTED IN TO LAST YEAR --
THE SECONDARY COMPONENT
COMPONENT OF THE UPGRADED NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM IS THE PIECE THAT
WAS ALSO INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S
PROPOSAL --
WHICH IS THE MODERNIZATION OF
THE AND RESTRUCTURING OF THE FEE
THAT SUPPORTS THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM WHICH IS THE THAT HAS
STATE EMERGENCY TELEPHONE NUMBER
ACCOUNT FEE ALSO KNOWN AS SATNA.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PER DAY --
PROPOSES TO RESTRUCTURE THAT FEE
EFFECTIVE JANUARY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THE
EXISTING FEE HAS BEEN FUNDING
THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE HOWEVER
THE REVENUE HAS DECLINED
PRECIPITOUSLY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
AS IT IS BASED ON AN OUTDATED
MODE OF COMMUNICATION INTEREST
STATE VOICE CALLS.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS ANNUAL
REVENUE HAS DECREASED FROM OVER
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
JUST SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS LAST
YEAR WHICH WAS TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THE LOWER THAN JUST THE
YEAR BEFORE AT EIGHTY THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE FEE STRUCTURE
IS INADEQUATE TO EVEN SUSTAIN
THE LEGACY NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM.
ABSENT THE BUILD OUT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM
THAT CALIFORNIA DESPERATELY
NEEDS.
THE REVISED FEE STRUCTURE WILL
INCLUDE A FLAT RATE MONTHLY
CHARGE ON ALL ACCESS LINES THE
RATE WILL BE DETERMINED ANNUALLY
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVELY
APPROVED SPENDING PLANS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET.
AND JUST BRIEFLY --
THERE ARE MULTIPLE OTHER
PROPOSALS AND IN THIS BUDGET
RELATED TO EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE TO
JUST ENTION A FEW --
THERE'S A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
IN THE CURRENT YEAR 200-018-1915
MILLION FOR A PUBLIC OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT AND GOING TO THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS TO THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
FOR STATEWIDE PUBLIC EDUCATION
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES PRIMARILY --
FOR GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS --
THERE'S FUNDING FOR AN UPGRADED
INTEROPERABLE RADY.
INTEROPERABLE RADIO NETWORK --
OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD TO THE
RADIO NETWORK WILL BE UPGRADED --
SO THAT RADIO SYSTEMS ARE
INTEROPERABLE AND CAN
COMMUNICATE ACROSS SYSTEMS AND
THE ADVENT OF DISASTERS. TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS HAS ALSO
BEEN INCLUDED FOR AN ONGOING PRE
POSITIONING PROGRAM WHICH IS
ALSO RECEIVED A EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY.
AND ALL THE OTHER IS THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE DISASTER
RESPONSE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT THAT WE'VE PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED AS WELL --
THAT'S ABOUT IT FOR MY OPENING
COMMENTS HAPPENING ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THERE.
THANKS SO MUCH US IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE NINE WE SUMMARIZED OF THE
pTHAT ARE IN THE BUDGET --
FINANCE COVERED AT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM JUST A COUPLE
OTHER ONES I WANT TO HIT ON VERY
VERY QUICKLY --
THERE'S AN INCREASE IN FEDERAL
TRUST MANDATORY OF SIXTY MILLION
THAT'S RELATED TO THE HAZARD
MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM I
MENTIONED THAT PREVIOUSLY --
THE STATE IS SLATED TO TO
RECEIVE.
UPWARDS OF A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FEES
HAZARD MITIGATION --
GRANT SAID THAT CAN GO TO STATE
AGENCIES AS WELL AS LOCAL SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
QUITE A BIT OF FINDING ON THIS
WOULD PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS A THORNY --
FOR YES WOULD MINISTRIES GRANTS
BUT IT'S IT'S REALLY LEGISLATURE
MAY WANNA KEEP IN MIND --
THERE'S ALSO DOCUMENTATION OF
TWENTY MILLION FOR CDA ANOTHER
SIXTEEN MILLION THAT SCHEDULE
FOR THE EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM AND THAT SOMETHING ELSE
THAT'S BEEN AN ONGOING THING THE
STATE IS INVESTED IN ITS --
EARTHQUAKE REALLY WAITING SYSTEM
IN THIS WOULD COME OUT FINISHED
BASICALLY THE BUILD OUT BUT NOT
DEAL WITH THE ON GOING --
FUNDING FOR THAT PROGRAM.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TEN ALL
QUICKLY GO OVER JUST A COUPLE OF
VERY HIGH LEVEL PRELIMINARY
COMMENTS WE HAVE WE'RE STILL
ANALYZING ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS.
BUT BUT THESE ARE JUST A FEW
THINGS TO KEEP IN MIND --
SO ONE COMMENT IS JUST THAT
SOMEBODY'S PROPOSAL'S LACK
DETAIL AT THIS POINT --
I CERTAINLY THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ANYONE COMING AND BUT BUT KNOW
THAT THERE ARE FEW PROPOSALS
THAT DON'T --
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
DOCUMENTATION BEHIND THEM YET ON
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION ONE IS IS
ONE I KNOW YOU'LL BE CONSIDERING
THAT SOON --
THE NINE ONE ONE PROPOSAL AN
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING THERE'S
DOES YOUR SORT OF CONTINUATION
FROM LAST YEAR BUT THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF INFORMATION ON THIS
YEAR'S PIECE --
SO THOSE ARE SOME EXAMPLES THE
LEGISLATURE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
IT'S COMFORTABLE WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY RECEIVE --
IS SUFFICIENT --
TO MAKE TO HELP TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO FIND
THESE PROGRAMS WHETHER MORE OR
LESS THAN --
THAN THE ADMINISTRATION OR THE
SAME ABOUT THE MYSTERY IT'S
ABOUT FUNDS SOURCE --
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS REALLY
RAISE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT FUND
SOURCE THE MINISTRATION MAKES
VARIOUS CHOICES ABOUT HOW TO
FIND.
ON SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS FOR
EXAMPLE THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM
WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT -- YOU
KNOW THERE'S CURRENTLY A FEW
STRUCTURE THAT'S IN PLACE AND
YOU DECISIONS ABOUT.
DO YOU WE WANT TO CHANGE THAT
HOW DO YOU WANT TO CHANGE THAT
STRUCTURE ON TO SUPPORT BOTH THE
BUILD OUT OF NEXT GEN AS WELL AS
JUST THE CONTINUATION OF
SUPPORTING OUR NINE ONE SYSTEM --
HOW MUCH RELY ON THE GENERAL
FUND IS A LOAN OR --
ACTUALLY JUST AS A CONTRIBUTION
VERSES THOSE THOSE --
FOR OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS --
SIMILAR ISSUES REGARDING
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING --
WE'VE FUNDED SOME GENERAL WE'VE
SPENT GENERAL FUND TO BUILD OUT
THE SYSTEM --
LAST YEAR THERE IS A REPORT THAT
RAISE SOME OPTIONS OF POTENTIAL
CHARGES THAT COULD BE IN PLACE
TO FUNDS THAT SYSTEM IN ON A
ONGOING BASIS BUT NO DECISIONS
HAVE BEEN MADE.
SO THAT SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURE'S --
LIKELY TO HAVE TO CHECK TO TO
TACKLE -- IN
THE COMING YEAR HOW WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT'S THE BEST SOURCE OF
FUNDING --
SO THAT WE HAVE A GOOD
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING --
TO AND THEN A FINAL --
CONSIDERATION IS THAT --
YOU SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS
REYES CHOICES ABOUT THE TIMING
OF FUNDING ON NOTABLY AT AS THE
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER VERY
SOON THERE SOME THESE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE FUNDED --
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
CERTAINLY THERE'S AN URGENCY TO
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS --
BUT YOU'LL HAVE TO TRADE OFF
THAT URGENCY VERSES ON JUST THAT
THOSE PROPOSALS WILL GO THROUGH
THE TYPICAL BUDGET PROCESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS ON FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THIRTY NIELSEN FOLLOWED
BY CENTER MORE LOT.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR GIVING
SOME SPECIFICITY TO THE NINE ONE
ONE HAD THAT INFORMATION BEENAVAILABLE TO ME YOU'VE.
LAST YEAR THEN MAYBE THINGS
COULD BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT --
BUT THIS IS HELPFUL TO KNOW THAT
WHAT IS A PLAN THERE IS A PLAN.
A WHAT WE WILL ALSO NEED TO DO
IS THOUGH ESTABLISHING SOME WHAT
I WOULD CALL BENCH MARKS.
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM.
I DON'T WANNA WAIT WAITING A
FULL YEAR. TO SEE HOW THINGS
WENT WE NEED TO BE ASSESSING AS
WE GO ALONG IT'S GOING TO BE
QUITE A COMMITMENT OF THE
RESOURCE IS NOT AS MUCH AS SOME
OF THESE TECH PROJECTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN EMBARKING ON OVER THE
YEARS BUT BUT WE WANT TO KEEP
TRACK OF IT.
BUT I WANTED TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE ASSESSMENT AND NOW
I'VE I FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
THAN I DID BEFORE BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME SPECIFICITY TO IT.
SO THE MORE LAW.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON THE
INOPERABLE INTEROPERABLE
SPEAKING --
PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO SYSTEM --
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED MEGAHERTZ SYSTEM.
AND WE GOT EVERYTHING EVERYBODY
COORDINATED INSIDE OUR EIGHT
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES AND BILL TO
THE TOWER ON CATALINA ISLAND SO
WE HAD EVERYTHING TAKEN CARE OF
BUT WE GET THAT TWENTY YEARS AGO
SO I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS.
WHY ARE WE WHY IS AHEAD IN THIS
IN PLACE ALREADY WHY WE'RE WE'RE
PUTTING? TEN SIXTY MILLION OVER
FIVE YEARS BUT IT.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN THERE SOONER SOME MAYBE OR
SOME HISTORY THAT I'M NOT A
FAMILIAR WITH.
SO A FIRM MAYBE SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL DETAILS --
WOULD DEFER TO ADD DIRECTOR
GULAR DUTY BUT I THINK IT IS
THAT FAIR TO SAY THAT ALSO --
THERE SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT RELY ON
PUBLIC SAFETY RADIOS AND THERE
HAS BEEN --
INDIVIDUALIZED EFFORTS TO
UPGRADE RADIO SYSTEMS --
DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION FOR HAS RECENTLY
BEEN UPGRADING THEIR RADIO
SYSTEM AND PARTS OF THOSE
UPGRADES INCLUDE PIECES OF INTER
OPERABILITY BUT I THINK THIS --
STATEWIDE APPROACH HERE MANAGED
BY -- YES IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON PROVIDING THE
BACKBONE AND ABILITY FOR ALL
THESE RADIO NETWORKS --
THAT ARE THE MOST UP TO DATE I
THINK P. TWENTY FIVE CYNG
COMPLIANT RADIO SYSTEMS TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE COMMUNICATE --
AT WHICH IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
IN A DISASTER EVENTS AND
EMERGENCY EVENTS WHERE YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE --
AGENCIES MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS
RESPONDING ALL TO THE SAME
INCIDENT TRYING TO COMMUNICATE.
HOW WILL THIS BE A MATCHING
PROGRAM WHERE ORANGE COUNTY IS
ALREADY YET MAYBE ESTABLISH WHAT
WOULD HAVE TO UPGRADE --
I BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD
PROVIDE KIND OF THE BACKBONE AND
ABILITY FOR LOCAL ENTITIES TO
COMMUNICATE ON THE INTEROPERABLE
NETWORK BUT I BELIEVE IT IS A
FEE FOR SERVICE TYPE APPROACH
BUT THE BY --
DIRECTOR GILLARD WHICH IF WE
HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
THANK YOU.
SIR I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION RIGHT NOW I HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT TO FIND
OUT EXACTLY.
HOW THAT'S GONNA LINCOLN BUT THE
IDEA BEHIND THE UPGRADE OF THE
SYSTEM?
WE HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE SPIRIT
SYSTEMS AS WELL THIS ALSO WILL
ALLOW BETTER INNER ABA BILLION
PLUGIN ON THOSE ON THOSE SYSTEMS
SO -- BUT I
I CAN GET BACK TO YOU ON WASTE
MORE SPECIFICS ON THAT GREAT THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPT
DEPARTMENT HAS A WEBSITE OF OF
WHAT THEY'VE DONE IT'S STILL TO
OUT SO IT MIGHT BE.
HELPFUL ON THE SIXTY MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
GOING TO THE NEXT GEN --
NINE ONE ONE WITH TEN MILLION
THIS YEAR --
I LIKE YOUR TERM OF
RESTRUCTURING THE FEE MATCHES
AND INTERESTING TAKE ON IT WHICH
IS SORT OF IN MY THOUGHT ALL
ALONG THAT I I TRY TO WORK WITH
REGINALD SALVADOR LAST YEAR AND
I BUILT A PRETTY GOOD FILE OF
TRYING TO COMMUNICATE.
WITH DUE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM AND SO I APPRECIATE.
WHAT ELLIE --
SAYS SOME SOME REQUEST BLACK
DETAIL AND I'M STILL GETTING A
LACK OF A DETAIL THAT TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT.
WHAT'S THE CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT WILL IT COST
OUR WE IMPLEMENTING COMPARED TO
CURRENT TECHNOLOGIES WE'VE GOT.
THE COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY FOR
WORKING ON FIVE G. HOW WE ARE
WAS AT ALL FITTING IN WHAT'S THE
OVERALL GAME PLAN AND AND AND
THEN.
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE SYSTEMIC
CHANGES.
PEOPLE TO WEAR WATCHES ANYMORE
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOOKING AT THEIR
CELL PHONES.
RIGHT MOVIES THE KIDS ARE MORE
WATCHES IN LEARNING.
SO SO YOU KNEW THAT LAND LINES
WERE DECREASING FOR A LONG TIME
AND THAT SELLS.
CELLPHONES EXPANDING AND AND SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
YOU KNOW SEEMS LIKE IT'S
LANGUAGE WORK CAN BE DONE.
YEARS AGO AND I AGAIN IS JUST
ONE OF THOSE MAYBE THERE'S A
HISTORY TO IT.
MAYBE YOU COULD FILL ME IN ON
THAT.
IT'S CERTAINLY BEEN AN OUTDATED
LONG OVERDUE --
RESTRUCTURING OF THE FEE IT'S
BASED ON INTRASTATE VOICE CALLS
WHICH AS YOU WOULD IMAGINE AND
ALLUDED --
TO IS A DYING --
MODE OF COMMUNICATION AND AS
PEOPLE MAKE LESS CALLS --
THERE'S LESS REVENUE AND THAT'S
KIND OF JUST THE MOST I GUESS
SIMPLISTIC OVERVIEW OF WHY THE
REVENUE HAS STEADILY DECLINED
ITS DECLINE THOUGH TO A POINT
WHERE IT CAN'T SUSTAIN LEGACY
NINE ONE ONE EXPENDITURES AND
EVEN IF WE WEREN'T.
PROPOSING TO FURTHER --
BUILD OUT A NEXT GENERATION NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM AN UPGRADE THOSE
SERVICES --
THERE WOULD BE PROBLEMS AND WE
WOULD YOU KNOW BE FACING A A
SIMILAR PROPOSAL TO RESTRUCTURE
THE FEE IN A WAY THAT MATCHES --
CURRENT MODES OF COMMUNICATION
WOULD YOU GET THERE LET ME HELP
YOU GIVE ME SPREADSHEETS AND
PROJECTIONS AND FORECASTS OF
WHERE YOU'RE GOING SO.
MAYBE IN THE DAY IT IS IN THE
TAX INCREASE WHICH IS BECAUSE
IT'S REQUIRING A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
IT INFERS THAT IT'S MORE OF A
TAX AND FEES I'D LIKE. TO TO WE
CAN DO TO MAKE IT LEAR AND
UNDERSTANDABLE TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS --
WE BELIEVE IT REQUIRES A TWO
THIRDS VOTE I THINK THAT THERE
ARE --
CERTAINLY DIRECT BENEFITS TO
EVERY -- OF
THE AT ALL OF THE SURCHARGE
PAYERS CLEARLY RECEIVE A DIRECT
BENEFIT FROM THEIR PAYMENT INTO
THE SYSTEM HOWEVER THERE ARE
NUANCES WITH --
VISITORS FROM OUT OF STATE WHO
FOR EXAMPLE WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THE SYSTEM BUT NOT NECESSARILY
PAIN INTO CALIFORNIANS NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM SO WE BELIEVE THAT IT.
IS A TWO THIRDS VOTE IS PRUDENT
ON IT -- THE
LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT A SUFFICES
TO GIVE YOU COMFORT IT'S A BIT
COMPLICATED BUT ALSO ON A KIND
OF SURFACE LEVEL AND LOOKING AT
AROUND A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN TOTAL EXPENDITURES FOR THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
AS YOU MAINTAIN THE LEGACY NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM AND UPGRADE TO
THE NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM AND THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WAS INTRODUCED
LAST YEAR A PROVIDED A PROCESS
WHEREBY THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WOULD COLLECT.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF ACCESS LINES AND
SUBSCRIBERS EACH YEAR AND WOULD
THEN COMPARE THAT TO THE TOTAL
COST OF THE PROGRAM FOR THAT
YEAR WHICH ARE APPROVED THROUGH
THE BUDGET.
AND THEN YOU KNOW IS TO
BASICALLY THAT SIMPLE MATH THAT
SETS THE FEE FOR THAT CALENDAR
YEAR AND WE'VE.
TRIED TO UTILIZE THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT YEAR THAT
IS PROPOSED IN THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THAT'S PROPOSED TO ALSO --
TRY TO MITIGATE SOME OF THESE
LIMITED TERM BUILD OUT COSTS.
DIDN'T MITIGATE THE IMPACT THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE ON KIND OF A YOU
KNOW QUITE A LOT QUOTE ON QUOTE
SPIKE IN THE FEE THAT'S CHARGED
AND TRIED --
TO COMES MOVE THAT OUT SO THAT
YOU'RE NOT SEEN A LARGE
FLUCTUATION --
OF THE MONTHLY FEE --
YOU -- YEAR
OVER YEAR SO RELATIVELY FLAT
DURING THE BUILD OUT.
IT WAS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
CELL PHONE COMPANIES ARE ALREADY
PAYING A FEE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
IS THAT IS THAT NOT CORRECT.
AS PART OF THEIR ABILITY TO TO
OPERATE IN THE STATE THEY WERE.
ALREADY PAYING A FEE TO THE
STATE CAL OR ACTUALLY PAYING
THEM FOR THE SERVICE THAT THEY
PROVIDE AS BACK WHICH IS WHICH
IS I MEAN.
YOU KNOW THE FEE IS COLLECTED BY --
THE USERS --
WHICH ARE THE PEOPLE WHO USE
THAT.
WE USE CELLPHONES OR HAVE A
PHONE BUT BUT THE IT WE CONTRACT
WITH THE YOU EASIER TELECOM
UTILITIES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
AS OF SERVICES SO --
THERE'S AND AND THAT'S ALSO PART
OF THE RESTRUCTURING AS WELL AS
BEING ABLE TO GET EFFICIENCIES.
IN THE IN THE OLDER SYSTEM --
IT VERSUS THE NEWER SYSTEM IN
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THEM BE MORE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW AS YOU INCREASE
YOUR TECHNOLOGY CAPABILITY
YOU'RE GONNA BUILD IN SOME
EFFICIENCIES TELL.
KATE MARA LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
ANALYSIS I LOVE DETAIL
[inaudible]
THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK ANY FINAL
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
BEFORE OPEN UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR THE TIME
TODAY AND ON THESE REALLY.
COMPLICATED TOPICS BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOU ALL AND THEN PUSH
IT WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
COMING YEAR AND THE FEELING IS
MUTUAL NEWS OR IMPORTANT ISSUES
ON THE WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO DRILL DOWN ON LIKE TO OPEN UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
AND ONE PERSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALL MAY SO THE
SENATE FOREST TRUST AND I'LL BE
BRIEF GIVEN THE HOUR.
EYES ONE TO GO BACK TO SOMETHING
BOTH SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI IN
SENATOR SKINNER HAD BEEN RAISING
ON SORT OF THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
WHERE SHOULD WE WE WE WORKING.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT THIS IS SORT OF TO
HAVE OUR URBAN --
ARE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
CHALLENGES AND YOU HAVE OUR
WILDLAND AREAS WHERE WE HAVE
THESE FORESTS HEALTH CONDITIONS
IN A WATERSHED HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT ARE REALLY.
DEGRADED TO THE PAST MANAGEMENT
LONG TERM FIRE SUPPRESSION THE
REALLY TO ALMOST AND FUELS
REDUCTION AND ACTIVITIES LIKE
THAT DIRECTLY ROUND.
COMMUNITIES BUT A LOT OF THAT
AND REDUCING THE RISK THERE IS
GOING TO COME DOWN TO HARDENING
HOMES WORKING WITH HOMEOWNERS TO
HELP REDUCE THE RISK.
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE SORT
OF YOU KNOW STRUCTURE THE
STRUCTURE CONFLAGRATIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN AND SANTA ROSA AND IN
PARADISE IN THE WIL THE FIRE.
MRS THAT'S ONE ENORMOUS
CHALLENGE OVER TO HAVE TO HAVE
SORT OF AN ONGOING.
EFFORT BOTH ON THE STATE LEVEL
AND FROM LOCALS AND DIFFERENT
CENTER PROGRAMS THE OTHER IS OF
COURSE.
HOW DO WE TRY AND RESTORE MORE
RESILIENCE TO ARE FORESTED AREAS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY PAST
MANAGEMENT AND HISTORIC MINING
AND?
YOU KNOW IRE SUPPRESSION BEING
A VERY SIGNIFICANT PART OF THAT
AND THAT'S ALSO A HUGE CHALLENGE
AND ONE THAT I DON'T THINK WE
CAN IGNORE THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE --
SUSTAINED INVESTMENTS IN TRYING
TO RESTORE RESILIENCE THEY'RE
BOTH MECHANICALLY ENTER
PRESCRIBED FIRE SO WE CAN GET
BACK TO A CONDITION WHERE FIRE
ON THE LANDSCAPE IS NOT
INHERENTLY CATASTROPHIC BECAUSE
THERE IS NO SORRY OR WE DON'T
HAVE FIRE.
IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF WHEN
THANKS THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
A GOOD.
AFTERNOON WITHOUT JEFF MASTON
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. FOR FRAUD
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH BOTH CALLOW YES
AND CAL FIRE ON THE PHONE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
PROBLEMS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH
THE GOVERNOR AND THE COMMITTEES
FOR THE OUR PRE POSITIONING
MONIES THAT WERE GRANTED LAST
YEAR WE THINK THAT'S A GOOD WAY
TO START.
AND KICKSTART ARE --
REFINED.
FROM A PERSPECTIVE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
DURING THE CAMP HILL WILL CEASE
FIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
44% OF ALL RESOURCES THAT WERE
THERE --
THAT'S THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF OF
RESEARCH IS YOUR HEAD AT THOSE
INCIDENTS BUT I I NEED TO REMIND
YOU THAT WOULD LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HAS NOT RECOVERED FROM THE
RECESSION.
HARTFORD FARMERS ARE SMALLER
TODAY THAN THEY WERE IN THE
SEVENTIES AS WELL AND A LOT OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH --
UNFUNDED MANDATES BY THE STATE
AND ALSO SOME OF THIS TAX SHIPS
THAT HAVE OCCURRED BY THE STATE
SO THAT IS AN IMPACT RECKLESS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS A WHOLE.
LESLIE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
ENHANCING.
THE OF SURVIVABILITY OF HOMES IN
INTERFACE WE GENERALLY DO THAT
AS DO ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BY
ADOPTING THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CODE.
CALIFORNIA FIRE CODE REALLY
LIVES WITHIN CAL FIRE AND TO THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE TO YOU HAVE A
MECHANISM RIGHT NOW. TO STOP
SOME OF THE ISSUES ABOUT WHERE
WE BUILD HOMES HOW WE BUILD
HOMES AND HOW RESILIENT THOSE
HOMES ARE WHILE FAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FINAL TWO WITNESSES PLEASE YOUR
NAME.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KATE DARGAN --
AFTER THE INTRODUCTION I'LL BE
SPEAKING TO YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE SAFE COUNCIL.
I WAS THE PAST STATE FIRE
MARSHAL FOR CALIFORNIA UNDER
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER'S
ADMINISTRATION A THIRTY YEAR CAL
FIRE RESPOND --
FROM FIREFIGHTERS THREE CHIEF
NATIONAL BOARDS COMMISSIONS AND
CONSIDERED AN EXPERT IN WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE ISSUES.
SO TODAY I WANT TO SPEAK TO YOU
AS A BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE SAFE COUNCIL.
LIKE ALL OF YOU WE FEEL THE NEED
TO LIFT HARDER THAN WE HAVE IN
THE PREVIOUS TWENTY FIVE YEARS
SINCE WE STARTED AS A AS A
NONPROFIT. TO THAT END WE
ANNOUNCED TODAY I THINK CHAIR
WOMAN HOW YOU WERE SHE'S ME
MITCHELL.
YOU RECEIVED A A PRESS
ANNOUNCEMENT WE'VE EXPANDED OUR
BOARD WE HAVE ADDED.
THE PAST DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE
ROOM IN THE HALL THE TO OUR
BOARD IN ADDITION TO OUR CURRENT
CHAIR JERRY DAVIES FROM THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY PASSED FIRE
CHIEF FROM VENTURA COUNTY.
UTILITY EXECUTIVES THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY EXECUTIVES AND A HOST
OF OTHER FOLKS THAT CAN HELP
BRING SOLUTION MAKING FROM THE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
SIDE OF THE EQUATION.
SO.
THAT'S JUST AN INTRODUCTION TO
THE FIRE CITY COUNCIL WE HAVE
HAD A CHANCE TO COMMENT AND
THINK CAL FIRE FOR THEIR REQUEST
FOR OUR OPINIONS IN TERMS OF THE
FORTY FIVE DAY RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST FOR GOOD
IDEAS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO CHAMPION FIRE
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION AS I
CRITICAL SOLUTION TO THESE
ISSUES AND SO WE VALUE AND
REALLY APPRECIATE VERY
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS.
FROM OF FROM THE COMMITTEE TODAY
THEY'RE ALL ON TARGET IN OUR
OPINION AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LIFTING HOWEVER WE CAN BOTH
THROUGH THE AGENCIES ARE THROUGH
THE COMMUNITY EVENTS.
AND AND ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE TO YOUR HEARING PROCESS
IN TERMS OF EXPERTISE A LAST
CALL OUT.
FEBRUARY EIGHTH THROUGH THE
TENTH THERE WILL BE A NORTHWEST
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
CONFERENCE THAT'S A GRASSROOTS
EVENT HELD AT SEA RANCH WITH
OVER US SIXTY ATTENDEES AND MANY
OF THE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
INTENT TO SPEAK OF PUBLIC
COMMENT AT ASTON TO QUEUE UP NOW.
SEEN ON THESE WILL BE OUR LAST
TWO NEXT WITNESS.
LAUREN COLUMN SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY.
WE COMMEND THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND ARE GAD TO SEE
A GROWING FOCUS ON SAVING HOMES
AND HUMAN LIVES.
THE HUMAN DEVASTATION OF RECENT
FIRES SEASONS HAS SHOWN THE NEED
TO INVEST IN COMMUNITY SAFETY
FROM THE HOME OUT RATHER THAN
FROM THE WILD LANDS AND WE KNOW
THAT PRUNING AND REMOVING
VEGETATION.
FROM A HUNDRED FEET SURROUNDING
A HOME IS VITAL TO SAVING A HOME
AND POTENTIALLY THE PEOPLE AND
THAT.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF SIN OF SYMBOL PRODUCTS FROM
ATTIC VENTS SCREENS TO GUTTER
COVERS TO FIRE RESISTANT
SHINGLES AND CITING.
THAT ARE EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE AT
SAVING HOMES FROM WILDFIRES WE
ALSO KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THE WILD AND
URBAN INTERFACE.
LACKED THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
TO TAKE EVEN THESE SIMPLE STEPS
TO SAVING THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES. TO THIS END WE URGE
YOU TO DIRECT FUEL MANAGEMENT
AND WHILE FAR PREPAREDNESS FUNDS
TO ASSIST LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS
PERFORM DEFENSIBLE SPACE
TREATMENTS.
AND HOME HARDENING MEASURES TO
THAT COULD SAVE THEIR LIVES IN
THE NUMBER INEVITABLE EVENT OF A
WILDFIRE THANK YOU.
WITNESS MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TERRY MCHALE
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES.
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL.
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE FIRST OF ALL
WANT TO MENTION HOW EXCITED WE
ARE TO A ONE TOO OF LISTENED TO
OUR NEW DIRECTOR.
WHO SPOKE SO ELOQUENTLY ABOUT
THE HARD WORK BEING DONE EVERY
DAY?
BY THE FIREFIGHTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN HIS WILLINGNESS TO
DEFEND THEM IN THE LONG LONG
HOURS THAT THEY SPEND ON THE JOB --
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS GOVERNOR
FROM HIS BUDGET AND FROM HIS
FIRST APPEARANCE IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE IN FROM HIS
WILLINGNESS TO COME TO OUR
CONVENTION.
THAT HE TO CARES DEEPLY ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES ARE FIREFIGHTERS
ARE FACING.
WE KNOW FINANCE HAS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT JOB.
OF BALANCING OUR NEEDS WITH OUR
RESOURCES.
I WHICH IS CLOSE IT BY SAYING
THIS THAT WHILE WE DO HAVE.
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY TECHNOLOGY --
WE HAVE DISCOVERED THIS YEAR
THAT OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE
WORKING.
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION TYPE HOURS.
AND THAT THEY ARE OUT THERE ON
THE FIELD FOR FORTY AND FIFTY
DAYS.
AND THEN THEY GO HOME AND THEY
HAVE TO WORK IN THE FIRE HOUSE
SO THAT SOMEONE ELSE GOES OUT.
AND THEY THEY MAINTAIN THE HOME
GROUND THE WORK YOU DO ALSO WANT
TO SAY THAT THE ANALYSIS TODAY.
IT'S REALLY ANY BUT WE SHOULD
JUST READ THE EVERYBODY ANYBODY
WHO'S INTERESTED IN WHAT'S GOING
ON SHE JUST READ THAT EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS IT WAS REALLY WELL DONE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS
FOR THAT SHOT I AGREE --
THESE BUDGET COMMITTEE ANALYSES
ARE.
WONDERFUL HISTORICAL DOCUMENTS
WE SUGGESTED THAT ALL OF OUR
NEWLY ELECTED COLLEAGUES USED
HIM AS A POINT OF REFERENCE TO
BRING US ALL UP TO SPEED.
AND SO WE THINK STAFF TO
CONGRATULATE THEM AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY
AND TODAY'S HEARING IS ADJOURNED